Fake loop.
Oh, there you go.
Hello, everybody.
Hello.
It is 1120 p.m.
But here we are.
It's your daily scheduled Twitch stream where I forgot about
the sponsors.
I said I clicked yes on on the Twitch sponsor tab.
You know, whenever I see them, I'm like, oh, I'm gonna do
that.
Oh, Marvel Rivals.
I'll be playing Marvel Rivals anyway.
Oh, Subnautica 2.
That seems like a game I'd be playing soon.
I have plenty of time to do all of that.
It expires tomorrow.
What happened to all the time I was gonna have?
What happened?
Well, the Rivals one expires next week, but then I'll be
traveling next week, so I was like, oh, I might as well get
it all done in one day.
It's just like, it's an endless cycle, guys.
It's an endless cycle.
I'd be like, don't worry.
I have plenty of time to do this.
It's like an entire month.
Where did that month go?
Where did it...
I thought I had an entire...
What do you mean, it spires tomorrow?
Bali, thank you for the 500 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
Here for the pattern from Doki developing a fear of the
ocean.
All right, thank you for the 105 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
You need to go to bed.
comfy but no I was like I was not even doing this a lot
earlier but I had a lot of work to do today and yesterday
and also like my entire last three three months but but but
I did get some work done today so I was like you know what
well this is also technically work as well so I'm just going
through the checklist right now it's like okay this looks
nice tomorrow I gotta I gotta roll it
I gotta quickly turn that out pop pop pop pop all right um I
need a side uh other than that okay wait let me
uh let me double check stuff I want to talk about it right
down this time I wrote stuff down okay yes it's like I said
it's an endless cycle like clockwork we are back here
because I forgot I click yes through some sponsors on the
sponsorship tab so today we're gonna be going through we got
decided we want to do subnautica 2 first or uh marvel rivals
so I'll make a poll for you guys to decide if you want
rivals first or subnautica first um let's see um how do I do
polls again every time I come back I'm like how do I do the
commands again post Which, which game first, um, Subnautica
2, or Marvel Rivals.
I'll make it two minutes.
Fight, fight it out, dragons.
Um, but yes, for those who don't know, I'm also, I also
decided to stream today as well, because, uh, I'm trying to
do as many streams as possible, because, uh, tomorrow, not
tomorrow, sorry, next week, uh, I will be traveling again.
um and uh for another work trip i know i've been traveling a
lot lately for this especially for this year alone i have
been uh whoops okay guys i gotta restart the stream wait
wait actually can i fix the bit rate oh i can fix the bit
rate okay sorry guys i realized i was on 1300 bit rate sorry
13 000 bit rate so if i if you guys were buffering my bad um
it's fixed now.
I knew I forgot to change something, so the bit rate is
fixed now, so I'm sorry if you guys were buffering earlier.
Oh, yeah, too much HD.
That's a lot of bitties.
Professional streamer, hey, this is my second stream ever
now.
Do you guys remember from the collab with Duty?
It's only my second stream.
But yes, next week, I will be traveling again i can't say
what i can't reveal anything yet but all will be revealed
very uh very soon not like super soon but like soon tm so uh
who's winning the poll currently okay subnautica um but yes
uh i will be doing a another work business trip again next
week i will be gone for a whole week i know i i didn't i
didn't realize it was for a whole week i thought it was
gonna be like maybe like three to four days from like what I
was originally told of the plan and they're like oh it's
gonna be a full week I was like oh okay I was like oh okay I
was really you know I was getting back into the groove of
things too I was just like oh yes getting back into the
streaming part of everything ever since because of the last
work trip um and another work trip before that and then it's
every time i get back into the group of things like here's
another work trip you gotta do so this has been the most
traveling i've ever done in my life within like and it's
only been half of 2026 too um so and then we have to go on
another trip worth trip for the concert too in july so i
feel like i feel like i'm flying almost each month i'm
flying out for a bit for like works but these are all
amazing opportunities and um and honestly you know like of
course i have to say yes to them when will ever come up
again as well like a lot of these things are very great
opportunities great experiences um um and you know um if i
don't say yes to them when we'll ever get to have this
opportunity again in the future so um but it's it's gonna be
amazing whenever it is revealed and whatever i can show you
guys I can't even the thing is I can't even show you guys
photos coming back from this work trip because it is secret
it is secret so I can't even show like photos of anything
I'll just come back and be like I'm back it's it's it's
ultra super secret um so uh whenever whatever is is revealed
um i can show every show you guys everything but for now
it's just i will be gone um i will be gone next week and um
we do have like a one at least we have one youtube video
that we can upload for when i'm gone next week and i am
planning on doing an off collab i'm trying to organize an
off collab as well um for next week i don't know if it's
gonna work out in the end but uh we'll see just be me i'm
gonna try and get a stream in i want to get in a stream but
if i can't not get an off clap i will try and get a stream
because actually um i do want to stream something for you
guys i want to hang out with my dragoons and stuff so um
even though i'll be gone i'll be gone away i still want to
stream for you guys um let's see what else i'm looking
through my notes today
Did you guys hear about the new Street Fighter character
that got announced?
Um, what's his name?
The...
I forgot to pronounce his name.
Um...
What's the...
From Yujiro.
Yeah, Yujiro.
I forgot his name, but I know all his memes.
Yeah, I was the Baku character.
Yeah, I was very surprised.
Because, like, isn't this whole thing is that he can't lose,
too?
Or sorry, not Street Fighter.
Tekken, Tekken.
Sorry.
uh the new character in Tekken um uh yeah this whole the
whole thing is that he can't lose right so it was I thought
it was funny that he's like how is he gonna how is he gonna
lose in Tekken yeah he's he's the strongest guy the
strongest guy on on earth
he's not he pretends to lose
interesting to see how how they how they do it with him and
say i'm tired yeah he lets you win um but other than that
all right the poll is okay i didn't see the results of the
poll who won i'm all over the place right now my mind you
know how it's like sunday and monday is always rest day um
so my brain is like not in streamer mode i'm so chill right
now i'm like Sonatica 1 at 86%.
Like, I'm literally not in stream mode right now.
I'm just like, how do I?
How do you do, fellow chatters?
I am a streamer.
How, um, how is your, how is, what is the weather?
Wherever you live and how was your day?
Uh, I'm working on fumes at the moment.
It's true.
It's only my second stream ever.
Hello.
I hope everyone has a very nice day today.
And we are all enjoying today's stream.
Wowie.
Words are how do you talk to chat?
How do you make conversation?
Hello, fellow streamer.
Hello, fellow chatter.
Any first time chatters here?
Press one if you're a first time chatter.
Oh, other than that.
um oh yes yeah but we just started doing uh long form
content again uh well we're trailing editors at the moment
uh for long form content and we just recently received some
videos for uh from the trials uh in our editors and uh hope
it goes well i do know i do know like right now the youtube
algorithm algorithm is favoring long form content again so
we're gonna try uploading those It's been something that I
wanted to do for a while and I kept putting on hold over and
over again But this time this time it's finally in motion.
We have a thumbnail artist and also several editors that are
going through trial periods And we'll see how it goes So
it's just gonna be like video like streams that I just
edited down so people who you know Who don't can't make it
to streams and stuff who don't have the time to watch my
very long streams They have the long form content to catch
up on excited.
You guys want to click on the link pinned in the chat or use
the command new vid.
It really does help a lot to like, you know, maybe give a
like to video or like a comment.
It really does help out a lot for the future for the series.
What else?
What else do I want to talk about before we jump into
Subnautica?
I also need to read the rules on the... You know, I was
like, remember to read the terms and conditions on the
sponsor.
I did not.
I was like, oh, Subnautica.
Yes.
I have to read the rules of like what I need to say and what
do I need to do because I definitely might have not done
that.
14.
Thank you for the 150s.
Thank you.
We rather eat a goat baby or a matter baby.
What's a matter baby?
I need a goat baby.
It's like baby cows.
Baby cows are fucking delicious as well as baby deer too.
um and they're pretty good meat or a mat what got him what
wait what oh baby sheep too is pretty good what's the oh or
oh what's the matter baby i'm gonna eat your baby goat guys
it was my second stream
This is my second stream, guys.
Not much.
What's the matter with you?
Scar, thank you for the thousand biddies.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm really fried right now.
I actually am.
I'm so, I, I, okay.
Another reason why is that I woke, I slept at night in the
morning today.
I couldn't sleep.
I know my bed is so fucking cut.
comfy but I couldn't sleep at all I like I legitimately like
I had I was just like doing work and playing apex because I
had to learn apex guys I have an apex tournament this week
um and I had to like I was just playing apex for like a
couple of hours uh till I think like till 7 or 8 a.m um and
then because I had to like learn learn how to play the game
because of the new meta the new like the legends that go
fast slide legend because you know I know my weakness if
things when things go too fast I start panicking because
it's it's too fast so I have to like get used to the speed
of the slide uh because I'm playing conduit so I have to get
used to the speed of everything um so so so I like I played
around to like 7 a.m but I still couldn't sleep so I just
stayed up until I was like absolute like I was like okay now
I'm tired I'm it's like I was like oh I guess I'm a little
tired.
I guess I can sleep now and then I have to wake up around 2
p.m.
Because obviously you know dad's like please feed me.
I've been up since I only had like what 10 11 12 1 2 3 I
mean 6 hours sleep is fine.
6 hours sleep but still like my sleep schedule is not okay
right now it's it's pretty fucked right now.
I don't know how to fix it.
I don't know I'm just tired.
I don't know.
tired i don't know what to do scott i didn't even take
nappies i didn't even take my nap i've been taking a nap in
like at least two weeks now scott thank you for the three
gifted subs thank you thank you um what else oh yeah i want
to talk about something else but i'm trying to remember um
what else i want to talk about about I think that's it I
mean I do have other stuff I feel like I'll save this for
I'll save this for tomorrow's stream when we're on YouTube
because because I still need to remember to upload twitch
vods one day one step at a time guys one step at a time
look we got our long form content the twitch vod channel is
another step.
It's the Twitch VOD channel.
It's a problem for another day.
One day it'll happen.
I'm just a little bit behind in steps.
All right, let's boot up Subnautica.
Let's get that in here.
right now it's it's like i it's i've been conditioned to
like see sunday and monday as like rest day so like um so
every time every time like if i when i stream on those two
days i'm just i'm not ready my brain's just like what are
you doing this is your brain is off day We are not rebooting
the system here.
You're going in on 1% battery.
10 years later.
Let me read this before I start anything.
All right.
Must.
Okay.
Sorry, there's a lie Let's put this game up before I do any
of this Okay, enable Yes, please It has been enabled I'm
reading, guys I'm absorbing the dial I'm absorbing the text
right now Alright Alright, are you guys ready definitely not
scripted dokey
a very all right very legit coming from my heart dokey yeah
thank you for that gifted stuff thank you thank you very
very legit live improv dokey all right sound guy I might
need your help too If any sound guy is here, please use
Discord to communicate with me.
Alright.
Let's get in here.
Confirm.
Your graphics card version is below the recommended...
I'm not upgrading.
It's recommended I'm not.
You can't bait me.
You won't get me.
you can't bait me into doing this not again don't worry
about that warning not this time i learned not this time
yeah very authentic dokey not scripted at all dokey reading
from my heart i mean i'm saying it from my heart yeah i'm
just reading my heart guys These words come from within.
I'm lagging because I'm compiling shaders right now.
All right.
As soon as I compile shaders and we're in, in, we'll start
reading.
At my heart.
When I say reading, I meant reading my heart, guys.
We'll start reading my heart.
All right.
Wait, actually, let me adjust the settings real quick.
I like how when I tap, okay, there you go.
I like that tab out.
I can still hear the music.
know that i'm alive um all right oh where did it go oh there
it is all right i'm ready okay
this stream segment is sponsored by unknown worlds a new
world awaits alongside an all-new story you're a pioneer
traveling to a distant world but something is amiss The
ship's AI insists you carry on the mission.
This world is too dangerous for humans to survive, unless
you change what it means to be a human.
What creatures, intelligent or otherwise, await your
arrival?
Play alone or with up to three friends in an online
multiplayer co-op, whether exploring mysterious ruins,
building custom bases, or adventuring deeper into the world.
The challenge of this planet will test your ingenuity.
and ability to adapt in unexpected and curious ways.
Survival depends on utilizing the right tools alongside
basic items such as your scanner and flashlight.
You'll find recipes for more advanced tools, equipment, and
submersibles.
But submersible, submersibles, submersibles, submersibles.
These are more, that's what you know.
from my heart.
Paces are more customizable with an overhauled building
system.
New tools allow for greater adaptation to the world.
From towering underwater cliffs to lush coral fields, this
aquatic alien world is brimming with vibrant and
breathtaking biomes, each teeming with diverse ecosystem and
unique creatures, but something isn't right.
The world is out of balance.
What happened here?
What happened to you?
And more importantly, where are you?
Uncover a rich world full of mysterious life forms from the
smallest fish to the largest lilyphans.
Scan creatures to learn more about them and take samples for
studies.
As you learn more about this world, evolve your genetics to
adapt your body for survival.
This world is vast and deep.
of waters descending into a dark unknown wander and danger
lurks around every corner to survive this planet you'll need
to push beyond your boundaries and unlock the secrets of the
strange world yay um this is actually gonna be my very first
time playing subnautica I've never played Subnautica before
but I heard that this currently um that reached like what
one million plus sales within like a couple of hours so um I
heard about a lot of great things about the game like I said
I've never played Subnautica before I don't think I know
about it is that um in one of the other Subnautica games you
can eat the penguins that's all ate the baby penguins or I
mean you eat the baby penguins or do they just not do
anything you just kill for fun right um that's the only
thing i sort of know about one of the older subnauticas i
don't i remember it's something about the baby penguins you
could kill them i just know that you could kidnap the baby
penguins that's all i know um what else um but yes but they
did add multiplayer to it uh which is the one first i heard
that this is like one of the newest things they added to the
game which you can play with your friends but it's also in
early access right now so they'll add more to it later on um
all right let's try subnautica like i said i've never played
this game before so we're going in blind all right let's do
the setting stuff uh let me turn the sensitivity down i feel
like i always have to turn that down um i guess we're good
play single player uh yes survival creative unknown i mean
survival i guess all right i've never played any of the
subnautica's before this would be my very first time
experiencing subnautica i'm a baby i'm a subnautica baby the
new life begins so let pioneer the print oh can I customize
um alright let's customize oh I can just change my suit okay
I'll be yellow I'm gonna learn how to swim today alright
reset to factory settings I'm going to learn how to swim
today.
13 minutes?
I'm going to live for 13 minutes?
Oh my god, I'm a baby.
He actually just printed me out.
Oh shit, wait, I have no oxygen.
Highly pressurized air is destroying your lungs.
Oh, that's not good.
Can I do anything to fix that?
Uh, I mean, I'm still alive.
I'll boot it up.
Boot sequence.
You're the QI.
Your life is my job.
My job is your life.
Okay, that's cool.
I wish I could make full introductions, but curtesies must
wait.
We are both going to die if we stay here.
There's another Noah node in the life pod outside.
Get me there, and I can get us both to safety.
Alright, I'll download you.
in slow motion under 60 oh wait i am dying oh yes here's
that theory that we're slowly dying because oxygen is
technically it could might be toxic to us and that's why
we're slowly dying you'll feel better you'll be better the
last pioneer didn't make it to the life pod i'm activating
their black box signal oh no wait my last printed body wait
i'm 3d printed I'm like Mickey 17.
All right, let me turn down the sense.
It's not even real.
It just 3D printed me.
Voices up a little bit.
Okay, let me...
I'll boost up the overall.
All right, sound guy.
Let me know what's better.
to adaptation oh my god i'm so slow i'm dying
oh they go to your one sub they could thank you wamba thank
you for the twitch prime they could thank you oh press the
buttons okay this this you senses too much i thought i keep
going lower but it's still so high What the fuck?
Like, do I have to go at five?
Why is the scent so high?
Okay, that's much better.
Please proceed to the sampling pavilion to adapt.
The body cannot survive exterior conditions.
Where's the sampling pavilion?
I'm slowly dying.
I don't know what a sample... Oh, there.
Do I just Touch you.
You must adapt alien traits to survive.
Oh, am I mutating?
Oh
Oh my god, I'm a mutant.
Disgusting.
Okay, I can breathe the air now.
All right, nice.
Okay, nice.
I'm him and he's me now.
I'm mutated.
All right, this should be okay.
I'll put it at 10.
So it's like in... I wish I could put it at like 7 or
something.
Oh, it sounded.
Let me know the volume's better.
Well, now I'm not dying.
Yeah, where?
Oh.
Oh, can I not get into the suit?
Can I breathe a little bit?
I want to be a part of you.
Oh, I'll just...
swim fuck it it's fine I can hold my I can hold my breath is
he dead I could just take his clothes off all right nice
yeah but I can literally take his suit a dead man doesn't
mean I can't strip him he's dead what's he gonna do
all right upload.
Okay, sound effects can come down.
Okay, thank you.
The sleep aid was extremely confined.
Access mission state.
I'll access it.
What's going on?
Where are we?
Advisor node, ISV, C-I-D-S-B-3.
Between us, I prefer Noah.
You are the QI, the qualified investigator.
Wear it with pride.
We have made violent planet fall.
I don't know the status the cicada or the 40,000 souls
stored in its quartz memory I am just one newer node I
printed support the colonists stored in sleep Bay 3 but if
things go wrong I am authorized to print a QI or two for
sure I don't they just print multiples of me to complete the
mission to build a human not enough match for that you will
have to lead the way are you ready to begin chair I can't
release shut the tyranny of matter you'll have to swim out
and release them manually they're on the back of the pod
outside the passage yeah can they just print 10 of me and
then like we can rebuild society with that i can't release
the life pod the clamps have corroded okay i'm gonna grab
the life pod oh that's my spine all right i'm making
pre-print myself
Alright, well, it's corroded shut.
Also, I have to set the sound effects down a little bit.
Alright, sound guy.
I fixed the sound effects.
Where am I supposed to...
Where is the corroded area?
Right here?
Oh!
Alright.
Oh, fixed.
Yay!
I have opposable thumbs.
Hello.
That is easy.
Yeah, but the more you print out of me, then the faster
things can go.
Like, we're already leaving the printer.
Like, we have so much materials, apparently, to keep
reprinting myself.
Oh.
Yeah, I assume I have no rights.
Because I'm just, uh, I'm just filament.
So it's like, what's the point of not printing more of me?
Like, I'm just, I'm literally just a three, I'm just, I'm
just filament.
all right music and sound effects come down a little bit
okay oh nice submonautica too is that 3d printed as well
well i'm not where am i i gotta put this down all right
sound guy let me know if it's better
I printed 26 colonists before the sleep day drown many of
them more than yeah why did you stop to reincarnate you from
digital storage support your work and if necessary reverse
your death if I lose track of my colonists I am empowered to
send why didn't you stop to track them down do this for me
and I can offer you hazard oh that's where the multiplayer
part Because I have no friends!
That's why he stopped.
Oh, that's what it means with multiplayer.
Oh!
He's like, you don't deserve friends.
You're gonna die alone.
Alright, that makes sense.
That makes more sense now.
Friends aware.
He stopped because you're a loser.
I'm not a loser!
I don't need friends!
Like he knew.
He had to stop with one.
Not even the cicada answers.
We are alone.
I've sent your PDA the standard No, it's because he believes
in me.
He was like, we don't need more than one.
This call of this is so efficient in what she does.
That's why, guys.
No one believes in me.
He's like, we just need one to get everything done.
Alright.
Okay, I need all of these resources, I guess, for stuff.
Yeah, I'm super efficient.
Uh...
Let's see.
I'll keep going back to reprinting myself.
Scorpi, thank you for tier 1 sub.
Thank you.
He knows.
He knows that we just need one dokey.
And I I can get the job done.
Can I eat him?
Is that...
Get over here.
I'm hungry.
What does he do?
Oh, shit!
Oh, oh, that's not good.
Wait, how do I...
eat him?
Maybe I can't just eat the things I found in the wild.
How do I scan it?
Uh, oh there it is.
Digestive incompatibility.
But how do I become adaptable to it?
Oh, shit sorry oh i have to locate gene donor all right all
right well oops i fucked up my body a little bit wait can i
eat you oh oh oh what's this oh it's oxygen it's the next
oxygen pocket he's like please stop eating it and i was like
oh i wonder if i can eat it what if i cook it I could eat it
if I cook it.
Some filters brine into drinkable fresh water.
This may be an adaptation to the seawater's anomalously high
viral load.
All right.
I was like, are you sure I can't eat this?
Let's grab all of these.
The pushable locker can be hand carried or attached to a
hard point.
Avoid workplace friction.
Inform your coworkers before moving their stash.
box a little oh hey let's climb up all right what is this oh
where did it go I can't digest this either what can I digest
okay oh okay oh I made water nice uh what is thank you for
the uh Thank you for Twitch Prime, they can thank you.
Alright, let's...
Poetic Advisor has transmitted an alert.
Notice the intrusive and persistent heart icon.
Return to the life pod at your convenience.
Remember that you are in command of the mission.
Is that...
Where is...
Is that... I'm here.
Oh, here you go.
I'm monitoring noxiously elevated viral loads in seawater.
Assays detect bone-blistering levels of cadmium, lead, and
chromium.
This planet is already killing you.
We have to know if the lifeguard biobed can help.
Okay.
Find a convenient way to die.
Your black box will phase your mind to the biobed.
I'll print you in a new body.
You can return to your point of exit to retrieve dropped
items.
Regular reprinting may help slow down environmental
contamination.
Oh, that's convenient.
solution but for now i can just respawn it's like i got a
cold just kill yourself just kill yourself in some nautica
too just just get him and i'll be okay now and i'll be okay
all right all right um well i guess i'll pull away my water
all right oh wait i'm holding okay okay Goodbye, Noah.
Ah, yes, drowning.
The most...
The least painful way to die.
Not on this gift, you think you were gifted a tier one so?
Thank you, thank you.
Oh.
Oh shit, wait, I found stuff though.
Alright.
Might as well grab as many things I can before before I
drown.
Don't worry, I'll just reprint myself.
That's what Noah said.
Just reprint yourself now.
God, it's so hard to drown.
Wait, what if I eat him?
Maybe I can...
I'm gonna eat you.
Oh.
Oh, I can't eat you.
I can't just grab you and be like, um...
Oh, goodbye.
I wonder if I'll get reprinted.
Oh, I can't even read.
Oh, yay!
You have experienced conditions incompatible with life.
Your brain state has been restored to a new body.
I uploaded myself to the cloud.
That's easy.
Wait, where did I die?
Okay, wait, give me a sec.
Oh, is that my body?
Wait, where's my body?
for the dead oh wait where did my body die oh my god i don't
even know what a dead body looks like a dead filament body
is that me oh that's me there it is all right nice all right
i got myself all right yeah i'm like i decay so fast in the
ocean All the fish is already eating my body.
All the alien fishes.
All right, I did it, Noah.
Are you proud of me?
Uh, I'll make this.
I don't know what this is.
Only this demilitarized switch axe is approved for colonial
fabrication.
Oh, in untrained hands firearms are primarily used to harm
other colonists or the self.
What can I do is this?
What is that?
What is it?
I'll figure it out.
Don't worry.
I'll figure it out later.
And she never figures it out again.
I'll figure it out later, guys.
I can figure this out.
If I put you guys down, would you guys move?
Hello, little guy.
I'm gonna eat you later when I'm thirsty.
Oh, hello.
What are them?
Just here.
I want more of these.
Oh, hello.
Oh, what's that sound?
What is that?
Wait, I want...
Can I put these guys in my house?
Oh, yoink.
Yoink.
Can't even eat you, but I want to keep you in my little
house.
Oh, what's this?
Yoink.
Oh, I'm drowning a little.
Don't worry.
Alright.
I got my oxygen.
What's that?
Oh.
Oh,
come over here.
You have a great place to...
Oh, why are you running away?
That place is beautiful to live in.
It's just a little bit cramped, but don't worry.
Don't worry.
That means we get to be closer together.
Don't be needing that.
Noink.
Oh.
I'm just decorating my house, guys.
With exotic creatures.
Making my house look fancy.
Come on, get over here.
Ooh.
Oink.
Wait, where's my house?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, I swam really far away.
I'm the invasive species right now.
I'm literally the invasive species.
Oh, oh, where are you hiding?
Oh, you thought you could hide from me?
Alright.
Oh, I see you.
I see a little guy.
Ooh, come on.
Come on.
Ooh, he led you to me.
Led me to you guys.
Oh, come on.
Oh, oh, hey.
I need more of you.
There we go.
I'm the new predator.
The food chain.
I'm the new apex predator in the food chain.
Oh, I can't drop you.
You actually need to survive in water.
Unlucky.
I'll just put you in storage.
I'll put you in a box.
I guess I'll put you in storage.
How do I do it?
How do I use this?
Where did it go?
Uh...
advisor has transmitted an alert return to the life port at
your convenience okay oh
anina contact i've located the black box of anita gotshaw
the colony purser partial voice data okay so hungry oh he's
so hungry she said you had a knack for holding things find
out what happened
okay they love it here what do you mean look at them they're
vibrating with excitement you love it here on my ship right
you're slowly adapting to their new ecosystem look at them
be ashamed of yeah you guys it was shame you guys don't like
it you want to know what happened to the last guy that
didn't like my ship you want to know what happened Hmm?
That's what happened.
You're so happy.
You see, I told you you're so happy.
You look so happy to be here.
All right, guys.
All right, we gotta...
Guys, what do I do with this?
I don't know what this is.
It looks like a...
It looks like a hammer.
It feels like I can't hammer anything.
Oh, I can make more food.
It's so incompatible.
Oh, harvester!
Okay, I see.
Okay, I can harvest more stuff.
They said, like, Anita.
They, like, put it on my map.
I don't know where it signals.
Why can't I see it on my map, though?
Oh, I see it now.
Oh, I see it.
It's over here.
Alright, that's Anita.
Where's the other one?
There were two.
Oh, I guess I go to Anita.
Back to you tier one sub.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, so it is a hammer.
I was like, that looks like a fucking hammer.
And it was.
Where are more of the slugs?
Do you think they know?
Well, I kidnapped all the slugs so they can't warn the
others.
Okay.
Doink.
Ooh.
It's very pretty.
How's that?
I got that back up because I'm going to drown.
I mean, it's alright.
They can just reprint me.
Potential donor found.
Suit surface detects molecules matching the organism from
the sea.
Can I touch this?
I am so hungry.
I'm so hungry.
Hello.
All right.
I'm going to touch you.
Oh,
wait.
After I touch him.
After I touch him, I'll be able to eat all the fishies.
All right.
I'm going to touch you.
with me now.
I'm adapting alien enzymes to your stomach lining.
You may now- Now I can eat all of you.
Now you serve a purpose to my body.
Noink!
Oh, wait, we gotta grab these.
Hey there.
I've adapted.
Now I am the apex predator.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, you thought you could hide?
Well, you thought you could hide in this little cave that
wouldn't find you?
I'll always find you.
Wait, what are these sounds?
So loud.
Alright.
Nice.
I gotta go back.
Oh, wait.
HP, so it doesn't matter.
I can still explore.
What's that?
Oh, is it him?
Was that you?
I wish I could hammer the fish.
I feel like I should be able to use this to hammer the
fish's brain and then eat it later.
Oh, hey.
Noink.
Oh, nice.
New fish.
I'm pretty squishy.
Squishy little heads.
What?
I'm hungry.
Okay.
I'm so hungry.
It's survival of the fittest, guys.
It's got evolution.
I'm adapting to my surroundings.
Okay, now that I can hammer stuff, I can mine this now.
Yay!
There is no sign of plant life on this world.
I can cut the brains.
latex and cellulose committed vegetarians should expect oh
my inventory is full all right we'll have to go back up
all right i'm sad i can't put all the other fishes in down
there
let's see i can only drop these guys all right store the
others
Oh no, my inventory is full What can I make then to make it
less full Oh, I can't make anything Any quartz basic
batteries What the fuck am I gonna do
Um Well I guess I gotta go mine stuff Oh, wait, more snakes
Hello Hello All right, maybe I should stop grabbing more
fish.
I actually got five actual mats.
They're just all swimming out there innocently.
They've never seen an apex predator before.
They're all so vulnerable.
They're all so vulnerable, just letting me take them.
They don't even run away.
They're not even running away.
They've never had someone threading their ecosystem before.
They had it too good for too long.
It's like they want to be picked up.
Exactly.
They're like begging to be picked up and eaten.
This quartz contains dead coral polyps.
It may have formed on or near a coral den.
They've never had a predator in the ecosystem before.
Then dogs were introduced to the environment.
Oh, I need more oxygen.
Oh, wait, but I want to grab you.
What's that sound?
That me?
Oh, no, it's that fish.
Can I grab these?
And no, I can grab this, though.
Oh?
Okay, no.
Alright, we actually needed the quartz, which is good.
Alright, now that I can see, this is a lot better.
Hey there.
Oh, is that a dolphin?
Oh, wait.
Did it bite me?
You bite me?
How dare you bite me?
Do you know who I am?
I am the new ecosystem's apex predator.
I bite you.
You like?
That's right.
Get hammered!
Yeah, I'm gonna show you who's boss.
That's fucking right.
I rule the seas.
all right wait
where's my ship oh it's over there i know there's gonna
there has to be an upgrade where i can swim faster oh oh he
tried to hide oh he heard about it you heard of news of doky
oh
oh you're so lucky you're so lucky i'm coming back for you
you're not running away You're not running away.
You thought...
Oh, you're not running away.
You're coming back into my...
You're coming back into my inventory.
Get back in here.
I thought...
I thought if I dropped that, I can...
I can grab another one.
He's like, oh my god, I'm finally free.
There is no escape.
You live here.
You live in my pockets now.
out all right let's see i need i can have do i have enough
to create this i need a basic battery how do i make a basic
battery i need copper how do i make how do i find copper
um i need more storage space don't judge me noah
Yeah, I do live like this.
What you gonna do, huh?
You're stuck here with me.
Alright, let's try and find copper.
Oh, or...
Alright, after this, let's try and find copper.
Don't judge me.
I'll put you back down there.
I can...
I bring you up.
I can bring you back down.
I throw you back into the ocean, Noah.
It's all I have.
What?
Can a 3D printed filament have hobbies?
This is my hobby.
Oh, shit.
My inventory is full.
Damn, you live like this.
Alright, we have to put this away.
Wait.
Is that not my shit?
Oh, this is my shit.
all right and then oh oh you try to get away from here um
can i drop these oh i can all right i'll drop these too uh
wait where did i put that i put that somewhere did i eat it
where did it go oh shit oh shit that's a lot that's a lot
bigger than i thought it was gonna be okay we're gonna put
this here all right i'm not a hoarder i don't have a problem
i'm just running out of space okay i don't have a problem
all right we gotta find copper
this is equally as important oh my god their shells are so
hard i can't hammer them
What's this?
Oh, a titanium.
I still need to find copper.
Where the fuck's the copper?
Oh, are those more sea sluts?
Colony structure located.
They may be clues to the location of the main habitat.
Alright.
They might have...
They might have copper.
Maybe there's copper growing inside the structure.
Oh, yeah.
Well, I look for copper.
You're right.
slugs are more important.
You're so right.
Where's the door to this place?
Here it is.
No power.
Oh, is that what the battery's for?
What am I supposed to do here?
I guess nothing for now.
Oh, unless...
More slugs!
Oh, shit.
Oh, I actually needed that.
Let's grab this for now.
Yeah, slugs are endgame, guys.
Where did it go?
Okay, nice.
I'm in a space.
Okay, I do.
I still need to find copper.
What does copper even look like?
I just know what Minecraft copper looks like.
Okay.
Hello, copper?
Oh, is that copper?
No, that's not copper.
Yeah, that's it.
I just know...
Oh, my God!
It's free real estate!
They're just begging to be picked up.
Look at them.
They don't even run away.
They're so helpless.
They want...
Guys, they want to live with me.
Look at them.
They're just sitting there.
They could run away, but they... Oh, my God.
There's copper.
I found copper.
all right that has to be copper it's like all brown oh my
god and they're right next to the copper too oh never mind
it's coral never mind well at least i found more slugs oh
shit okay my inventory has too many slugs now uh it's like
they yeah see
oxygen all right let's go let's go back let's put some stuff
away i think i just have too many titanium i gotta stop
picking up titanium let me throw this away so i can pick up
another slug
all right all right guys i gotta free up my inventory so i I
forgot my inventory so I can pick up another slug.
Yeah, maybe I need to pick more up.
Slugs are...
Why else would they be giving us so many slugs?
They must be endgame.
And then...
Put this away, too.
Alright, and...
Yeah, that seems right.
Alright.
All right, back to trying to find copper.
We're still trying to find copper.
Where the fuck are the copper?
If am I supposed to, like, build anything?
You're right back to trying to find more slugs.
Look, I'm saving them.
If they don't want to be saved, why don't they?
Don't they run away?
Why do they just let me pick them up?
Think about it.
Seawater sampling detects a source of genetic adaptations in
this region.
Tracking a broom with viral activity at the same source.
They didn't know what they are.
The fuck?
Where the fuck did I not...
Eat this?
Yeah.
Is there copper in here?
Oh my god, is that copper?
Oh my god, there we go.
We found copper.
Okay, cave roofs.
That's how I define copper.
Alright, we finally did it.
Okay.
Let's grab our oxygen real quick.
Alright, now we gotta go save some more slugs.
We're heroes.
Dragoons.
Oh my god, there they are.
There's one.
Don't worry!
I've come to save you!
I rehabilitate you back home!
Oh, there you go.
I'm a hero.
Don't worry, you'll love living at my place.
It's very roomy and nice.
And you're gonna make, and you're gonna make so many new
friends, too.
You will never be alone.
So Noah gets for not printing more friends for me.
Alright, and then, okay, now I can make, oops, what did I
do?
Alright, now, now I can make a battery.
And by making a battery, wait, what happened to my quartz?
I know I had court.
Oh, it's in here somewhere.
Um.
Did I have courts in here?
I know it was in here in this pot.
Titanium.
Okay.
One, two.
Oh, my inventory is full.
All right, how many do I need?
Oh, I have enough.
All right.
What can I do with a scanner?
Um.
Oh.
I'm gonna get teleporting alien cyborgs and treat his karat
I'm scared behavioral economists still debate why Riley
abandoned a lucrative motivational speaking career to return
to frontier life I need a drop
let me drop my copper alright there you go and then I need
I'm actually picking oh I'm picking up this this.
Do I scan stuff here?
Oh, there's stuff in... Whoa!
Oh!
Scan.
Alright.
Oh, that's how you scan.
Yeah, that's a giant thing above me.
Yeah, but I can't scan these guys.
Oh, wait.
Alright, who...
Alright, who wants to be chosen?
Who wants to be the chosen one?
Oh, my, my, my, my, my, congratulations, you've been chosen.
Don't worry, he's, he got, he ascended, guys, do not worry.
He got chosen to be ascended by God.
Now he's in a better place now.
Yummy, yummers.
Freedom achieved.
Pick me, me.
I want to go next.
Let's see.
Don't worry.
He's so safe now.
He's been chosen by the higher beings above.
He has a higher purpose in life now.
Oh yeah, wait.
Was there anything else I can make?
Oh, I can make rubber.
Oh, hey, hello.
Wait, more appeared.
They're coming to me.
They heard about my life pod.
They heard about the guy who got chosen.
They all want to be chosen now.
All right.
All right, let's see.
What is it, Noah?
Whoops.
All right, what's this?
Air bladder.
Emerging, hemi, inhale to supply to supply.
and you're oh okay i don't think i actually need that i feel
like i need a standard air tank okay i need rubber and
silver how much rubber do i need okay one where am i going
to find silver
they're like yay they picked me oh my god i got chosen
they're like oh my god you're so lucky oh my god it's like
the it's like that anime from about the orphans you know and
how all of them lived and everyone that got chosen lived
wonderful lives because they all got adopted.
It's just like that.
They found like loving parents.
They found their Neverland.
Yeah.
They got chosen for a greater purpose in life.
And they all lived happily ever after.
You just
need to find silver.
Is that silver?
Is that titanium?
That's titanium.
Ooh.
More slugs.
Don't worry.
I'll take you to a better place.
You'll have lots of new friends.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Look, I'm adopting some orphans right now.
Look at all.
these orphans getting adopted.
God, I'm such a caring person.
What's this?
Oh, there's silver.
Wait, I can't even harvest this.
How the fuck am I supposed to, how am I supposed to harvest
that?
Am I scan it?
Yeah, there's, I need, like, I need a bigger hammer.
Oh, there's smaller ones?
Oh, maybe I'll find smaller ones nearby.
Is it that?
Is that small enough?
No, that's just a goddamn stupid quartz.
Apparently, there's smaller ones nearby.
Oh, what are you doing all the way over here?
Nah, that's another titanium.
Oh, hey, what are you doing down there?
Don't worry, I'll save you.
I'm a hero.
Oh, there you go.
I found it.
Oh, shit.
I want to go down there.
Alright, I don't want to die, so I have to go back up.
Whoa!
Wait, what's that?
Can I hit it with my hammer?
Hello there, little guy.
I can't hit it with my hammer.
Can I scan you?
Whoa.
That's cool.
All right, let's go back.
I have silver now.
So I can breathe longer.
I don't know why he's barking.
I have, I fed him.
Is there any more slugs?
I know they glow in the dark now.
Oh my god.
By naming them in the dark is like so smart.
Because they glow.
Because they're begging to be picked up.
See, I told you.
I told you they're begging to be picked up.
Like, yes, Stokey.
Yes, pick me up.
Look, look, look.
If they did not want me to pick them up, why are they making
it so obvious?
Huh?
Oh shit, I got through.
I almost threw this away.
This is quartz.
because that's all i'm saying they don't want to be picked
up why why are they glowing
they're like yes yes i'm right here it's like their sos
signal they're like please save me dokey save me i'm glowing
for you dokey
all right we'll go back to the red door i just need i had
too much too many items and you put some stuff away they're
so pick up pick upable exactly
all right
do I have enough of my storage now oh I do uh alright I want
to build this and then can I put that on do I have that on?
Oh I do nice alright and flippers I don't know I need
flippers.
Okay, I need two rubbers and two fivers.
Oh, I should.
I have that.
It's, like, in this pile somewhere.
Uh...
Water.
Oh, there it is.
Fibers, pulp.
Boop.
There we go.
Alright, and then...
I need two, right?
I need two.
I have another one.
Just, like, in here somewhere.
Okay.
in this pile oh one there's another one i know you're in
here i know i dropped some more somewhere in this pile uh
let's see i feel like i should have more sea slugs hey
that's copper wait i can put these things away
all right how many do i need i need oh i have no all right
now i can make another one yeah
oh okay who wants to be guys guys i just got a message from
god he needs to he said we can let another sisa get chosen
to be let in who wants to be chosen Mini, mini, mini, mo.
Oh, you're so special.
You're one of our special ones.
Don't worry.
Me, me, another chosen one.
You're gonna be special.
God thinks you're special.
So special.
Oh, I can eat them now.
Let's cook this.
Okay, I'll consume.
Actually, I can eat more.
These other fishes don't matter because they won't let me
put them in my house.
Alright.
Wait, what do I need?
Oh, wait.
I want to go into the... Wait.
Is there anything else I need?
Jerky.
First aid kit.
I guess the more I scan, the more I can make.
I'm not scanning a lot of stuff.
I've just been...
I've just been, like, scavenging.
Alright, let's go back.
I can have a lot of oxygen.
I don't feel like I'm swimming faster, though.
Wait, it was this way.
While I remember.
Oh, wait.
Oh, yeah.
I forgot he wanted to talk to me.
I got distracted.
Look, we were having a ceremony there.
We're having a very special chosen ceremony.
It's very sacred.
We couldn't be distracted from it.
I'm what he would call weekly supervisor.
It means I respond well to human guidance.
I can take partial instructions and generate a coherent
concept of operations.
It seems alright.
He seems to be okay.
Jack gave you his PDA pass key so you could play games on
his account.
I can play games?
Oh, that's sweet.
What a nice guy.
I can play video games on his account.
He shared his Steam account.
How do I play video games?
Oh, I just guess I need to look at his black box.
I don't go pee, though.
I'll be right back.
I'm so organized.
There is a system here, guys.
There is a system.
Look, I literally built them a little playpen with all these
toys to climb around in.
Alright, let's grab Chaps Black Box.
There is a system here.
You guys just don't understand.
You guys just can't comprehend it.
Oh, you're tiny brains.
Oh, hello.
Oh, welcome.
Ha ha ha ha.
Alright, let's go get that black box.
Hello.
You're gonna love being part of...
Oh, hey.
Oops.
Scan this.
30 seconds.
Oh!
What?
Oh, maybe...
Oh, oxygen.
30 seconds.
Let's go back up.
Oh, wait.
That's an oxygen bubble.
I don't need to go back up.
Don't worry.
These guys are going to love being part of our family.
I'm rescuing them from the dangerous ocean.
Wait, where's Chap?
Hey, where is he?
Oh, he's down here.
How do I get down here?
That guy seems very friendly.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I was giving a pat in the head.
I was just patting his head.
I'm here to help.
Exactly.
Look, see?
Look at him.
Look, he's so happy.
oh my god thank you my savior thank you for saving me i was
so scared and it's like don't worry i'm a
hero all right let's grab some silver oh hello
oh it doesn't seem very comfy
oh repair tool
more storage space I
mean I'm alive it's fine just a pussy just a little bitch
little bitch boy can't breathe the oxygen huh couldn't be me
what has the
Noah failed to perform its What's a bio?
Why do you feel that it's asking too much of us?
I can't afford to have feelings about anyone's behavior.
I'm acting on reports that the Noah is erratic.
The Noah, that's my Noah.
Printed people should not be allowed to have feelings.
We're here to do a job.
He did not assign us to feel.
Isn't filament technically cheaper than...
Like, robots?
So don't they have less rights than robots?
Why does nobody like the 3D printed people?
I did not print my people to have feelings.
What is this?
Oh, nice.
Oh, my inventory expanded.
Nice.
Alright.
Now I can pick more slugs up.
Yay!
Alright, let's go.
I guess we go home.
Oh, we can start printing more stuff now.
I wonder if I have enough materials, though.
Oh, hello, little guy.
Oh, don't worry, I'll save you.
I save you from the dangerous ocean.
You'll love it back home.
You're gonna feel so safe back where I come from.
Okay, we gotta go this way.
Oh.
hello there look he's shaking with excitement that's why
whenever i get near him he starts shaking he's so excited
all right where is i guess i should go to the welcome center
just to start scanning more stuff
yeah i'm giving i'm building a community for them exactly
see now they don't have to be alone guys i'm i'm literally
building them a community
all right scan complete hello oh what's this habitat builder
oh wait can i build like tanks for my other fishes now yeah
i'm reuniting families here
new life boost oh it's this oh there is i can't build a tank
for them I can build tanks for my food.
Sabotage is a serious crime.
Samantha Ayu's bombing of Altera Labs delayed critical
Carrara research by decades.
All systems online, power connected.
Welcome back, Pioneer.
I'm Sophie Boucher, Corulte Surgeon.
By now you know we're not on Zezora.
We call this planet Proteus.
We don't know when rescue will find us.
For the sake of all our sleeping friends, we have to learn
how to survive.
survive hey fellow dead slave I'm the human Dakota ecologist
take a sip of sea water notice that sweet blood taste under
the salt that's about heavy metals nobody survived past
three months it's a beautiful place to die over and over
again but don't let that beauty seduce you pioneer exposure
to proteus causes a delusion we call maize field syndrome
the call of the sea people may tell you Ignore them.
You remember what Kara did to our homes.
You know, thank you.
Thank you.
We've set up a lab here with a few basic biomods.
They're safe.
But if you start to hear voices, or if you get the urge to
swim to the tree...
Start to?
Don't go.
Have it at least two north.
We'll come pick you up.
See?
All right.
What's this?
Uh, oh!
Release the trail so you can allow it to fall.
of finding your way home slows when you're not moving swims
faster when close to are the sea i feel like i should get
the swim one which one's the active okay dash in any
directions i'll get the dash how do i dash oh oh i'm so fast
now hello i split up the noah having a look around this
structure was connected to street bay three until the base
suddenly moved alone what if you're the last human being in
the whole universe wouldn't that set you free this world is
not the last human on i'm here but it is not for man you'll
join us soon enough we
call this planet proteus we don't know when else you will
find us for the sake of all our sleeping friends we have to
learn how to survive Damn,
there's so many instructions.
You must have power to make air.
Oh my gosh, now have to be a...
Now have to be a handyman.
A solar panel?
Power to make air.
Have power to make air?
Go inside.
Build lockers.
A fabricator.
It will draw from your lockers automatically.
Nice, huh?
Now you have made a perfect work camp.
Later, you can add a room for bio bed.
Processor.
Now I guess I'm a contractor now.
A real bed.
Alright.
Well, I'm going to start my contractor career.
Is that what they call it?
People who...
build the houses.
Oh, is this a where's the where's the solar panels?
I don't have one.
Don't I need to scan a solar panel?
Oh my god, it's the corridor on top of the solar panel?
Oh.
Time to learn how to be a contractor.
Oh, it's included.
Oh, that's good.
Okay.
I was worried about it.
I was like, I don't fucking have it.
I didn't scan no solar panels okay let's grab put these guys
away and then what do we have to make uh wait i scanned so
many things is it not included in here
corrupted is that what they call the people who make houses
wait but i i scanned so many things Where's my blueprints?
What?
I thought I had a lot of blueprints.
They're not?
I'm so confused.
But I scanned all of them.
How do I build?
Oh, the habit...
Okay, I remember.
It's that one thing I found.
I need to find the other one.
I found one.
I found one of them I don't know where the other one is It's
like in the ground somewhere
Oh shit okay Okay it's chosen time It's a chosen ceremony
It's a sacred ceremony Alright before I Choose someone I
gotta eat though Okay Seek caloric intake.
All right.
Yummy, yummy.
Hello, I have a new message from God.
He has decided to choose another special little guy to enter
paradise who wants to be chosen.
Imani, Imani, Imani, I'm all you're so special.
Wait, I'm getting another message.
He told me that a second slug will be chosen tonight as a
pair.
It's never happened before.
In all years, I've been his messenger.
So who wants to be chosen again?
Inny, minny, minny, mo.
Congratulations.
Don't worry.
You're gonna feel great in paradise.
All right.
Yummers.
We gotta find...
Oh, but it's nighttime now.
It's gonna be harder to find it.
Don't worry, they're in a better place now.
They're so excited.
I wanna go and pray.
It's me next.
Me, I wanna get chosen next.
Don't worry.
Everyone has an opportunity to get chosen.
Okay.
They're like, I'm so...
I can't believe...
I can't believe Brenda got chosen.
It should have been me.
I've been waiting for so long to get picked.
When will it be my time to get chosen?
It's not fair.
What if you just reprinted yourself when you were tired?
Maybe you'd never have to sleep.
Miss Sejima, I'm checking out the big coral tower.
What's that's less phobia?
right i'm not scared of the ocean i just hate i just hate
the ocean it's not fear it's just hate
it's just gross yeah
there's a difference like if you live next to something on
proteus you become related
it's because like i always say the ocean is nature's toilet
So your seek is gross.
And also, there's trash island, too.
There's also not the best.
Not just that, but the fact that the ocean, the tunnel of
Elgato, I'm tired of hearing people, stagger out of the...
Alright, let's just go take this back home.
Is there, like, several trash islands now?
It's not even one anymore.
Oh, shit.
I didn't even realize.
I was lagging that badly.
I was just enjoying my time.
I have no...
Oh my god.
Was motion blur on?
I even noticed the motion blur.
I just went...
But everything's medium, though.
Let's see.
I've not been lagging, guys.
Just been having a good time.
Swimming.
Okay.
I don't like being one of the weakest things in the ocean
while I'm not me.
These, they've never seen a, they've never seen an apex
predator before.
Just don't be weak.
It's just that easy.
I'm a wiring kit now.
I kind of craft it.
Oh, a faux functioning fabricator.
on the top of the food chain.
They've never felt a threat before in their lives.
Um...
What was I trying to get?
Uh...
Oh, I need to try to find that area.
I scanned one of them.
I just don't know where the other one is.
Does anyone know... Do they... Is all like similar?
Is they all just know... Oh, hey, another one.
Yeah, I am the food chain.
Hello.
I'll grab that.
Like, I found one of the thing on the floor.
Oh, yeah, I never scanned you.
Where could they be?
Should be inside the boxes.
I can't really see anything right now, though, to be fair.
Look, I have other important things to do.
Like, saving these slugs.
Yes.
I couldn't help it.
I was drawn in.
They needed someone to save them.
My savior complex got to me.
I actually don't even know where they are.
It's really beautiful, though.
I had other...
Exactly.
other priorities here hashtag save the slugs for only the
price of one coffee you can you can contribute to the save
the slug fun for just price of one coffee oh there it is is
that it no that's not it Adopt a slug today.
For the price of one bottle of water, you can help a slug
reach paradise.
Exactly.
Millions of slugs go missing every year.
It's up to us to shoot to save them.
I don't know.
Oh, what?
What the fuck did this show up?
Oh.
Yeah, I was gonna say, where the fuck did this titanium come
from?
They're like, did I get birth to it?
Is that, that, and my Pregante?
Is that, I get birth to more filament.
Oh, copper wire.
Every time I scan something, a little filament.
Oh, shit.
Oh, shit!
I'm okay.
Oh, fuck.
It's all right.
I'm above water.
What is he going to do, huh?
Chase me?
Oh, look.
Look at that.
See?
They couldn't breach my skin.
So he's like, oh, shit.
I gotta go.
This guy.
This guy's scary.
Hey, maybe.
be it.
I can scan something.
Is there anything to scan here?
Damn, nature is scary.
Look at that.
Look, see, he ran away, guys.
Guys, he ran away.
He bit me and was, he broke his tooth.
And then he ran away.
Because he was like, and then he ran away, and then he ran
away.
I'm telling you stories I am the narrator See he's God now
guys He ran away I told You What do you mean He's God I told
you He ran away What a pussy Couldn't even finish The job
Yeah Yeah look at that I told you he ran away it's like fuck
that was the wrong he picked the wrong one to bite he fucked
up
all right what can I make what was I trying to make again oh
you forgot um I guess I gotta put these away
Oh wait, I can't...
Oh, that's these I can't draw.
I'm still trying to find this thing, this scan.
Like, where is it?
I don't know where it is.
I remember finding it, like, around here.
Like, one of them?
But I don't know where the other ones are.
But I'm going to gotta save these guys.
Oh, is it actually over there?
Okay.
Yeah, I've been scanning stuff on my radar, but...
I thought I scanned it.
Yeah, see, I've scanned this already.
But it's not, like, everything on the radar.
I feel like some of the stuff I've already scanned...
Oh, I haven't scanned this.
I guess, like, they want me to scan some of the fishes, too.
Alright.
There's just so many things to scan.
Okay.
All right, scanning, scanning.
The noetic advisor has transmitted an alert.
Return to the life port at your convenience.
All right.
Ow.
I'm fine.
I can just respawn.
Is that a...
That good guy?
Oh, yeah, he's okay.
All right.
No one wants to talk to me.
There you go.
Not even close.
Ooh, hello little guys.
There's so many little fishies here.
Oh, hey, what's that?
Jack the sponge?
What the fuck are you?
Alright, I scanned almost everything.
Near my surrounding area.
Oh, except for you.
Now I scanned everything in my...
Oh, wait.
In my surrounding area.
Let's put you away.
Oops.
Still not making new stuff?
I guess not.
Let's see.
Oh yeah, we have to go back.
Oh wait, Noah.
Noah, fuck.
Sorry, that was the whole reason why I came back.
Alright, Noah.
What do you want to say?
Oh.
I've located Lucretia Kapoor, the mission's AI ethicist.
You may find her final words troubling.
I certainly do.
Why not?
She often asked you to resume your stories when you were
interrupted.
She made eye contact when she spoke.
A considerate woman and not easily frightened.
Signal location uploaded to PDA.
Okay.
Where is that?
Oh, Camp 1.
Oh, another black box.
Okay.
Let's go to that black box.
Yeah, Noah, what the fuck did you do?
Why was she...
Why did you open it?
Noah?
Hmm, starting to trust you less and less right now.
Okay, it's like...
Oh my gosh, it's so far away.
way too.
I want to build my house.
Why am I supposed to build my house if I can't find a
fucking item?
Oh, fuck!
Oh, my god.
With nibblers.
Yeah, they definitely nibbled.
Oh.
That's fine.
Oh, my god, I didn't finish my scan.
I can out swim them.
Look at them running away.
Look at them.
And then they ran away.
Yet again.
You're so scared.
And then they ran away.
Can I scan this entire house?
Maybe?
Can I scan this?
And they wandered away.
Okay, I'm going to grab one of these guys.
and then so I can eat him.
There you go.
How do I get in?
No, apparently they like...
Oh, shit.
Wait.
I thought there would be air outside.
Apparently, what I read is that they got rid of the only DPS
item in this game for the sequel.
I thought that's funny.
yeah it was a knife so you can no longer shank the fishes
yeah no more shanking for us what's that alright nice oh
unlocked it
no more self-defense I don't need self-defense I'm the apex
predator
they gotta self they gotta defend themselves from me hello
do you have enough inventory spill oh shit okay gotta go
back up
all right oh yeah i gotta eat one of the fishes uh yummy oh
shit was it poison I live.
Cool, cool, cool, but it's like sashimi!
What do you mean I can't just eat raw fish?
It's sashimi!
It's fine.
I can live this.
Okay, we'll have a not scan.
Oh, Sonic Resonator.
Oh, I can have a chair.
Hello.
all right what's this oh i just turned that on i don't
understand oh wait all right we gotta grab some air though
up top under 22 seconds oh i'm stuck you're stuck oh shit
wait where am i oh i got more stuck don't go up up is bad
okay down Okay, there we go.
It's alright.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
It's alright.
I made it.
Oh, see.
Not even close.
Not even.
Alright, back down I go.
Did not learn my lesson.
Look at that.
Not even close.
Oh, my God.
I have to go.
I have to go from that way to there.
Let's displace and build more doors.
Never punished.
All right.
Down I go.
There's an air pocket at the top.
All right, we're gonna see if we can find that air pocket.
Do you have to go to the other side for it?
I'm gonna try and go as fast as I can.
Find wherever the fuck that air pocket is.
Oh my god, there it is.
Okay, I found it.
Alright, um...
Unlock that.
Got more blueprints.
Alright.
I need...
That's it, can make a glass now.
And silver ingots.
And a beacon.
I can make a poster, a locker.
How do I make all of this?
Survival multi-tool?
Ooh.
Oh, bioreactor.
Ooh, hey, a bed.
Oh, yeah, I need to start scanning stuff around me.
I'm going to use my scanner to scan a scanner.
And I'll get that lab chair.
what's this oh shit you may be the very last human being in
the universe oh my god i'm human see you get to write the
last chapter of our story see i'm human guys i do have
rights
wait what wait what wait what wait that was not that was not
in the manual i'm gonna die here oh i guess whoops sorry i
got to my air just in time we tried to drag people clear but
they're gone for reprint i'm taking survivors to east of the
tadpole pens swim down the guess we'll never know if i'm
actually gonna die here i'm sorry there were so many buttons
i just wanted to press it
all right let's grab that picked up a pen am i supposed to
oh yeah let's activate this noah they were trying to build a
life farms and biomods that could support 40 000 sleeping
souls i can dig into your one sub dig it thank you were they
sick did the maze field syndrome subvert them we have to
maybe just didn't have enough slugs i've activated dr wu
lang ye see what makes me different from me and the other 25
colonists is that my house has 100 slugs we should salvage
what we can i've retrieved a few files gather all the
blueprints you can especially the scanner station that's
what makes me different from the others that is true i think
that's what i think that's what saved me from dying Noah's
cephalopod uses a central administrator to govern limno also
thank you for the tier 1 sub thank you thank you the slugs
yeah the slugs protecting me reliably controllable by less
intelligent systems such as human operators except under
extreme situations cephalopod inspired an insult to
octopodes not its precious workforce if you become
uncontrolled it'll wipe your memories and start over they'll
just control delete a nice clean you in task why would it
want to change the damn thing is in heaven it's
more than i can say but it's time to
have the calories to spare i will not force anyone to
reprint but i ask that once you are too sick to work you
volunteer for recycling into a new body it won't cure the
permanent damage But it will clean out the metals and virus
for a while.
At least this is fair.
Until we know how to adapt the metals without going maize
field.
So it's whatever in the environment that's, like, causing,
like, slow deterioration.
It's just, like, a bandage fix.
It's just temporary.
Because it always comes back.
Also, Faye, thank you for tier one, so.
Thank you, thank you.
All right.
Oh, I understand.
Narihoto.
what oh shit wait this is bad everything's way too dark oh
my god i didn't even do the one thing i was supposed to do
yeah there's too much oh where's the door oh my god i can't
see anything can you go back up
all right down i go i need to go get that what the black box
i forgot all the bugs it where
is that black box okay it is up here it's like somewhere
here oh only i can access it
stupid noah how can you have fire when you're underwater
That's impressive.
Oh, hey, a processor.
Oh, shit.
Okay, here.
SpongeBob logic.
Alright.
Alright, let's go back.
We got the black box.
We can start printing more.
Oh, it's that sound.
I'm just gonna swim above water.
Not lost.
That's my house.
Is that my house?
See, guys, I'm not lost.
That's my house.
Oh!
Oh, God.
I'm 10 HP.
Oh, shit.
I'm 5 HP.
I'm 5 HP It's okay It's okay I can zoom I can zoom I can
zoom Look at that pussy And he ran away Like a little bitch
Look at that I couldn't even Finalize the kill What a bitch
What a little bitch boy Look at that Look at him running
away I told you guys I'm the apex predator and I made it
back home safely and I bravely swam away all right let's see
oh I didn't get any slugs this time okay I actually need a
um oh my god I failed my mission I didn't grab any slugs how
do I make a med kit I need fiber okay I can make fiber wait
I'm right um excuse me okay that's awkward this is this is a
little awkward um oh that is a little awkward
I forgot about the second building tool.
That's a little...
Oopsie.
Yeah, maybe I can build.
I can build the other stuff.
I can build a chair.
Seek fresh water intake.
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I'll grab food first before I...
Alright.
Yum, yummy.
Alright, it's chosen time.
We're just going to speedrun this.
and you.
Look, we had some budget cuts, so we have to shorten the
ritual, unfortunately.
Oh my god, it's a lot.
Holy shit.
Oh, there you go.
We had to, unfortunately, the ritual had to be you.
Now to be short and do the budget cuts.
Don't worry, you're all very special.
God has told me that even if the ritual is a lot faster but
it's not less exactly it's not less important we gotta get
more followers
I still don't know where to fuck the other builder thing is
no I looked under the house there was no building thing I
got one of them I got one out of the two they don't despond
no they don't look at them they definitely don't despond
No, it's been like that for...
This guy's been here for...
Especially this has been here for a while.
I literally need that one fucking item.
So I can make my thing.
Isn't any of these cubes?
Maybe it's one of these cubes down here.
I have one more thing that's...
One more scanner.
Okay.
I want to build a base, but I don't know where the fuck that
thing is.
Yeah, see, they don't run.
The door is open.
They can leave whenever they want.
They chose to be here.
I didn't close the door, yet they're still here.
It's not here.
Because this is where I touched this guy.
I'm going to scan this anyway.
Remember when I touched this guy?
can eat everything.
It all commits useful genetic material in its core as it
matures, making it a perfect gene donor.
Usually it's above a table?
What table?
Did I finish scat?
No, I still have more scat.
Oh!
Oh, I'm here now.
Okay.
Whoops.
Uh.
I got electrocuted.
That's awkward.
Ooh, that's a little awkward.
Do I need, like...
Yeah, I stubbed my toe on a plant.
Where the fuck did I die?
I was, like, around here.
I'm just surprised there's no, like, markers, too.
Okay, that's where I was.
Okay, it's around here.
Yeah, I remember now.
toe.
There it is.
Eh.
Yeah, I would like death markers.
I guess they think it'd be too easy.
But like this is a little annoying trying to find your dead
body in the middle of the ocean.
I don't know.
That seems like really hard.
The ocean is pretty limitless.
Grab that.
Who is here?
It's here.
early access though so obviously they're going to add more
later all right nice i got nice i'm twirling it all right
that's it i fucking it's marvart rival's time i give up
we'll come back later i don't know where it is i don't know
where it is it's 1 30 a.m i don't want to stay up Too late.
Raven, thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you, Dave.
To be fair, the sponsored portion of the stream ended more
than an hour ago.
I...
It was under the structure where I got...
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Actually, give me a sec.
I need a... I'll find this thing and then...
And then we swap.
All right, I must find it.
All right, apparently it's under this.
Oh my god, is it this?
Oh my god, I swear to God, is it this?
No, that's a pro...
Oh my god, it's right here.
Okay, okay, now I can...
Sync your life port.
A standalone habitat is the next step on your mission.
Look at that.
See, it's that easy.
I feel like...
Why did all the slugs stop spawning near me?
I wonder what...
He must have got lost, guys.
Except for him.
He heard the message.
they all know if you want to be saved head to these
coordinates it's like during the zombie apocalypse and
you're like this uh and then like all the survivors are like
come to the sanctuary it's here if you want to be safe you
want to be saved and oh
all right yeah they're all doing a pilgrimage to to me right
now the holy land Alright, okay, now, what can I build,
technically?
Okay, Habitat Builder.
I need Glass Basic Battery.
I can make Glass.
How do I make Basic Battery?
Okay, I have Copper.
I do have Copper in here.
Okay, there you go.
See?
See, I told you there's a system here.
Guys, there's a system to all of this.
It is organized, but you just can't see it.
Okay, I need Battery.
And then a habitat builder.
There we go.
You have taken a major step towards zero debt day.
How do I recharge this?
A habitat is a vital investment in your future.
A habitat can also be an emotional anchor.
Prove that you've built something to last.
Alright.
It's easier to replace a body than a base.
I mean, I just want I just need a locker, honestly.
Like, this place is fine.
I feel like.
Like, this house is fine.
Just need one locker.
There's nothing wrong with it.
Okay, floor locker.
Oh, I can't build it in.
We cannot build it in here, or is it because of my...
Oh, I do need a base.
But I feel like, you know, it's fine.
It's a little capstone.
a hotel.
Nothing wrong with that.
Scanner station exterior.
Okay, there's the solar panel.
What about like, there was the aquarium that I could build
too.
I saw that.
Oh, a little bit of locker.
Oh, furniture.
Here.
Oh, where's the Reaper light dive then?
The viathan.
Isn't that the... Oh, it's like a model.
Where the fuck is the aquarium?
That's the most important thing, honestly.
What happened to the aquarium?
But I scanned it.
I scanned it.
What's the point of scanning?
Put it next to me.
A valid support surface?
Oh, it has to be underwater?
That's dumb.
Why can't it just be next to my house?
It's float up there Okay, oh, I need a scan to aquarium.
I'll just put it right here You like so Okay
Put it here There you go It's beautiful Wait, why isn't it
not making anything?
Oh, I need to put titanium in.
I thought I had a lot of titanium.
Do I not?
Oh, shit.
Did I actually...
Oh, no, I do.
There we go.
Alright, now I need to add a door.
Uh...
There we go.
I need one titanium and one...
Oh, wait.
I'm just gonna...
Yeah, one titanium and one quartz.
There we go.
Oh, it has to be, like, close to it.
Alright, nice.
Technically, I don't need air.
Technically.
Okay, and then...
Uh...
Oh, shit.
Maybe I should not have put it up top.
How do I put my solar pad?
Wait a minute.
Okay.
or seek fresh water intake all right we need titanium all
right maybe i shouldn't have put it up up okay i need one
more oh my god do i did i actually run out of titanium how
can this be no i didn't okay i knew it i know i have a
system all right not power
Um...
What do I want to put in this room?
I don't really have anything I want to put in here.
I guess I could put my materials.
But then it's working so well for me.
Though.
It's working so well for me in the other place.
I don't know what to put in here.
I guess I'll put a light.
I like how dark it is.
Nah.
Alright, whatever.
The slug house.
But I like having them live here.
I like them all here.
It's so convenient.
More room for the slugs.
I think they're fine.
Welcome aboard.
I guess I could put my bed.
Where's my bed?
I don't make a fucking bed.
Oh, I need a fabricator.
Uh, what's a processor?
I know where I can fit 50 more, though.
In my other, in the other place.
Ow.
Oh, wait, what's this?
Oh, it's another.
Oh, what did I eat?
Oh, there's nothing in here.
I'll just grab it.
Alright.
Oh, man, I guess that's where I'll...
I guess that's where I'll put this.
You know what?
I'll put one of you here.
See how I feel.
Having a slug in this room.
I don't know.
Doesn't feel this same.
You know?
Wait, how do I assess so much?
Just doesn't feel the same.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Alright.
Back in here you go.
That's fun.
Just try learning this game.
But, unfortunately, we have to move to Marvel Rivals.
And build a house, though, guys.
No, I didn't.
There's always been two.
I didn't drink any swag.
I only drink two.
Let me get these stuff away.
It's like two...
It's like getting a little too crowded in my inventory.
There you go.
Yeah, that seems good.
Very well organized.
I like my system.
Oh yeah.
Manual save.
I don't know.
I feel like it's...
I feel like it's very homey feeling.
You know?
Very comfy.
Check, thank you for the tier one sub, thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you for the tier one sub, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you, thank you for the tier one sub,
thank you, thank you, I was going so well too, I was on the
roll, I knew exactly what I was saying, and then the last
one, I had to stumble on the last one, it was very, it feels
very homie, you know, we're family, here very well organized
my little system that i have all right let us swap to marvel
rivals it's rivals time all right let's get this started
i'll do a couple of okay we're gonna do our placements we'll
see how it is for those who don't know there's apparently a
huge hacking problem um no we're not tanking we're playing
support we're doing placements on the main um apparently
there hacking issue in rivals and then today they released
the the cheater files they released the list and you can see
like um um you see a list of like all the hackers that they
banned um yeah i'll show you guys the link it's pretty funny
like actual list of everyone they banned so far yeah and
apparently there is like 184 of them They banned 488
accounts for using cheats and 184 of them were in bronze.
The cheater document, the cheater files.
It's crazy.
The fact that they were in bronze, though, that's sad.
Like, you imagine hacking and you're still hard stuck
bronze.
But it was fun.
It was fun learning about it.
It was fun checking out some Nautica first time playing the
game in the game scene.
series um and it's fun learning it as I go and saving those
poor defenseless slugs and giving them a home uh let's see
let me get everything here sorted all right thank you for
updating the game for me I'll change the title as well uh
don't worry I'll still have
Wow!
Alright.
Let me move this over to my other monitor.
It's so annoying.
I always have to move it back over here.
Alright!
And then change my data professional streamer here.
And then
Enable the channel skin.
Alright, get ready for not scripted Doki, because I'm
reading from my heart.
Marvel Rivals Season 8 is officially here, guys.
Meet the new Vanguard hero, Devil Dinosaur, and it's free to
play.
Drive into the new Season 8 gameplay, fresh strategies, and
ever-changing battle crowns.
all right here we go i am currently i did i was bored and
did already did some of my placements solo queue it was not
the best idea to do it off stream um it was it's the same
current meta is like it's based current meta is basically
like melee characters and it's as a support player it's not
that fun it's like triple support all melee so it's it's You
know, it's not the best time for the supports right now.
It's sort of, you know, you're like, you're sort of like at
the bottom of the food chain type deal.
Yeah, it's not the best.
Don't worry, let's explore.
Oh, let's go around Times Square.
Let's see what's up over there.
Anything new?
Oh, yeah, apparently there's like movie nights.
Oh, my God.
There's so many people here.
Oh, it's a fucking baby clip again.
It's always the baby.
Oh my god.
Which one's devil dinosaur?
I can't tell.
Okay, no wonder it's lying so hard.
Wait, wait.
Hello, sir.
Did you order the Venom special?
Bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump.
Well, he doesn't notice me.
I'm down here.
Pay attention to me.
Sir, you paid for the service.
Sir, sir.
Hello.
I would like to be acknowledged.
Oh my god, he's not looking at me.
Who is he looking at?
Oh, of course.
I can never compare.
How can I compare there?
I understand I'll never be there That's not That's hello
That's not even though Okay what about you Would you like A
dance Bum But, oh, oh, oh my god.
I know, would you also like a dance?
What happened?
No, my husband!
It's Venom old news now!
Venom's yesterday's news.
It's all about the hell of savage skin now.
Do you think you would be today?
No!
Venom's washed Oh fuck Mantis Oh wait Ultron Technically
it's Ultron but I don't I haven't played Ultron in a while
Who am I gonna banish from this match It's all about It's
all about hell
We don't have We're solo tank hug Alright First placement
match My It's warm-up, guys.
Going right into Rank Dism always has been.
It's how I roll.
No warm-ups straight in.
Alright.
I'm gonna let them decide for me.
I'm an Ely Terrorist at heart.
I've never warmed up.
I just go right in.
And then the hope for the best.
My warm-up matches are my rank matches.
I let the game decide what my fate is.
Exactly.
They're for the weak.
I raw-dog it.
Alright, here we go.
The Mantis Rocket Luna.
Right off the bat.
Let's go.
I just came back.
My warm-up is Subnautica, too.
Do you see my...
What is it called?
The clicks per second?
Damn, when I pick up the slugs...
Yeah, my BPN.
Yeah, my slugs go...
scooping speed.
That's how I practice.
That's how I warm up.
Slugs were my aim lab.
Yeah, my SPM.
My slugs per minute.
Slugs per minute.
You aiming to complete my placements tonight?
I'm aiming to get that hour in.
Okay.
All right All right, why did you shoot a rocket?
Wait for us Okay, no, oh look at that.
Whoops.
Oh man.
We're the fuck did ours.
Why is why was she there?
Oh my god, she's loud.
He's so loud right now.
I'll focus first.
That's not good No, that's not good
This is not good.
I can't...
Oh, please.
I'm trying... No!
Oh my god, I can't pay attention!
Dad, please!
I don't want to get a noise complete!
Oh my god, this is so bad for me.
So, okay.
What?
Ma, what?
No.
oh my god he's so loud jesus i couldn't do it okay i'm so
distracted what did she say bro you like front lined so hard
like what do you want me to do
Like, ma'am, please work on your positioning first.
Oh, goodbye.
That's all of us.
That's all the supports.
Goodbye, everybody.
Oh.
I mean, she can kill her.
Did she not kill her?
There we go.
Now we kill her.
I literally left her alone.
frozen you
know what can solve that if one of our dps wants to play all
right oh shit what the fuck
don't worry everything will be fine where's our luna there
we go everything will be I'm trying.
I used it all up for my guys.
Okay.
I used up all my leaves.
I don't know what else you want.
Guys, I told you.
First game is my warm-up.
Oh, there she goes.
There we go.
I still can feel jealous.
All right, that's cool.
It's all right, guys.
Everything is fine.
Now we have double tank.
Bro, I need to know where the fuck our Luna and Invis is.
They're, like, confusing the shit out of me right now.
Let's hope you're okay.
What?
Where was I close?
My cloak, why didn't we talk?
Oh!
It's not me!
She's talking about our cloak!
Okay, see you guys?
I'm not the problem here.
It's not the problem here.
It's not me.
Our cloak...
Wait, why are we throwing?
Wait, our cloak is actually throwing!
see you guys i'm doing my job i'm doing my job there we go
look look in the end we're all here we're all having fun
right guys guys it's just the beginning of season everybody
we'll climb right back hulk hate stupid fish man i assure
you boot
I mean, all right, you know what, fuck it?
Fuck it, all right, let's go.
All right, who needs my ult?
He's on...
She's on Wanda now.
Um, I feel like I should have kept my ult instead.
but okay like I guess if she doesn't want me to have my
health sure you're welcome I'm a hero I'm scared yeah
exactly I'm just listening to instructions guys I'm I'm just
listening instructions look and they're like why did you you
waste your own I'll be like oh just told I'm just a good
soldier not every cloak but oh guys not all clothes but
somehow always a cloak player
all right here we go not all cloaks but always a cloak all
right
Who do I have?
Who do I have on the...
Oh my god, I gave it to her, Wanda.
That's fine.
You know what we could do?
We could kill that...
Oh, fuck that Hulk.
You know what?
You're right.
That Hulk's not a threat, obviously.
Oh, never mind.
Alright, it's okay.
Our Invis is building up.
Don't worry, I'm here.
Oh.
Okay, Wanda.
Wanda, that was such an easy kill.
That, alright.
I think our Invis...
Oh.
I swear to the guy.
You can hold first, Luna.
Don't worry, I will.
Don't worry, no hesitation.
I will.
Alright, that's good.
Look at that.
I don't know why I would give it to my Wanda, but hey, at
least she's a Live, you know, I'm a team player even if
you're throwing I'm still a team player.
Look at me go Can't report me This is how you don't get
reported This is how you don't get reported guys I'm like
really worried about going cross there
Oh my god, I want to keep my keeper alive
Oh Oh Whoa, I'm still alive.
There we go.
It's okay.
We still have Invisal.
She's still alive.
Someone needs a snowball in the face.
You'll have to keep fighting.
You can't report me.
I'm a team player.
can't report me actually can't report me i didn't do that at
least i didn't do that at least i didn't do that
can't report me
now you see if she ever Talk shit.
I have that.
It's okay.
We still won the map.
Alright.
Look at that.
See, I'm doing my part.
I know I'm doing my part.
I'm surprised we even got that map.
Not gonna lie.
That was like...
That was a close...
You're fuck right there.
Namor.
As you are well aware.
Perhaps the two of us have been brought together here.
I'm surprised we survived.
Wow.
I'm so, yeah, I'm so warmed up.
I'm doing my part.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
All right, here we go.
After all this time, it's nice to finally have some help,
say.
wait oh my god they're actually wait they're running triple
support now wait a minute they're like it didn't work oh my
god you're jumping so much
i don't think they can i think my our team is trying very
hard to get on point But I don't think they can.
Oh, I got flown up in the air.
Oh my god, I can't believe they went triple support.
Because it didn't work for them.
That's crazy.
They went triple support now.
Alright.
They're like, this didn't work for us.
So we'll do it.
Go down there.
There's a Luna sign on you, bro.
All right, there we go.
Bro, I'm trying...
I'm trying to...
Please!
All right.
Oh, there we go.
You can all first, Luna.
Me first.
Yay!
There we go.
Oh, look at that.
You see me like just turn around too?
Cool guys.
Cool supports.
Don't look at freezes.
Look at that.
Cool supports.
Don't look at freezes.
All right.
Wait, I have MVP?
don't back on the point oh i almost got him i was trying to
predict where he was gonna fly to all right i hope we are we
all live
holy oh there we go nice hold i thought hydra had too many
all right we have no support else and have another one.
I think they have, they should have another, a Luna, right?
I don't think they use the Luna.
Oh, this guy is crazy.
Oh, it's unlucky.
No!
What?
Putting out myself.
Really?
I didn't get that?
Then you reload.
I'm clapping.
I'm still scared.
I don't want to go up there.
Yeah, that is.
Oh, we lost the control.
That's unlucky.
Oh, goodbye.
I need a gun.
Oh my god, I'm missing.
I'm so scared.
I'm panicking right now!
If you take too much damage, I'll whiff!
If you take too much damage, I'll stop shooting!
I'll miss everything!
Oh my god.
I got hit.
Jesus Christ.
There we go.
Oh, nice.
You got to stop.
Alright.
Three, two.
one i hope i can see where things are all
right nice we did it so um i sort of accidentally ran into
them because i was just let so what happened was that i was
like don't worry why did we okay there we go i was like
don't worry i'm ill and i ran straight into the emmol we're
too excited.
I was just like, don't worry, guys.
I'll be a hero.
I was like, why is this my queue working?
See?
Guys, who needs a warm-up?
Needs that.
Look at that.
Easiest game of my life.
Not even scared at all.
Who needs a trip?
Exactly.
Who even needs a triple support?
I told you, the slug is the way to go.
Just go full on slug.
Look at that.
Didn't whip my ults at all.
I'd say I was the most confident support player on our team.
Didn't whip my ults.
All my ults.
Went off naturally.
Alright, here we go again.
I'm so sad that they put a limit now.
They actually put a limiter on this.
You can't have it on for too long.
My FBI agent stops it.
Bada-dump, bada-dump, bada-dump.
Oh, did they fix it?
Did they fix the bug?
Can we now just twerk for as long as we want?
Bada-dump, bada-dump.
Oh.
Oh, I guess not.
Guys, I guess not.
We do not have that privilege in.
They forgot to rig the model.
Don't worry.
Surely I'm not solo healing, right?
Come on, guys.
Come on.
We're a team.
Guys, we're a team, everybody.
We're all in this together.
Hey guys.
Hey everybody.
We're gonna work together, right?
Oh, oh, our mag swapped Luna.
All right.
It's okay.
Now we're a team.
Oh, nice.
All right, 2-2-2.
Dive.
Defense, though.
All right.
It would be better.
I wish we were attacked, honestly, with this cop.
This is a little difficult to do on defense.
Defense.
all right don't worry we're 2-2-2 but this is like full dive
but it is a little harder to do this on defense all right
seems odd not seems it is it is not even seems but it is all
right here you go
Oh, all right.
It's all right.
Oh, I hear a spooderman.
Oh.
Let's hope our venom is.
All right.
Yeah, no, this is difficult.
Oh, my God.
Oh, they're also dying.
Oh!
Not as fun anymore.
Doesn't look as fun anymore, guys.
For some reason.
This might...
It's hard to heal too.
I think the biggest issue is that this is very hard to heal.
in general oh my god why every time every time why must you
bark when i'm in the very intense game i want to save my the
thing is i have to save my push too in case they're hard
diving again
i don't know if i can get the push in but oh oh he fucking
left he booked it
Oh It's a little I'm a little scared There you go.
I put that shield up so I know he couldn't grab me if I
stand on the other side Haha, that's right.
Oh, that's called team sense.
Haha get behind me ladies.
Oh my god our hero Who said that my Luna My hero my Luna Oh
my god, she's gonna protect me.
Yeah
There we go.
Don't worry, my support, my other supports got this.
The girlies will work together.
Let my Luna heal.
Let my Luna heal more.
I think our venom's gonna...
Nope.
But just watch the venom die right here.
Okay.
oh my god oh my god i couldn't get to i thought she had it i
thought what's going on no i thought our luna had it i
should have used it i i didn't the thing is guys she had so
much time to heal she had so much time to heal i literally
nothing so i was like she's got this right and i pressed tab
and then she was like 97.
i was like what do you mean 97 what what do you mean you're
at 97 luna what do you mean
i was just like i didn't move i wasn't even doing anything
how are you at 97
Oh, I did was just sat in the back, man.
Oh, shit.
Wait, oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Where's my shield?
Okay.
Oh, my God.
All right.
It's too bad.
I couldn't get there.
Wait, is anyone going to go on?
Oh, no one's on Strange.
Sin City, are you going to pick?
Yep.
All right, here we go.
That sucked.
The mag was like literally looking at me.
So I couldn't do anything.
Oh, that's very unlucky.
All right.
Oh, that's bad for it.
That's bad for us, Luna.
That's very bad for us.
Let's hope.
Oh, the rocket didn't hit a single shot.
Let's go.
Yeah.
I think if I wasn't like...
I think if I wasn't like blocked by the mag, maybe we could
have got this.
But is there the like hard block there?
Oh, hey.
That is very scary.
So I'm just gonna back up from the dino power.
Honestly.
I don't think I would like to be there in general.
Um, I want to wait a little bit for my dive players to go
up.
Oh, I would love to be able to.
I'm sort of stuck here.
Alright, let's go.
Alright, we- Alright, let's- What is going on?
What- Alright, hey, hey there, Luna.
Hey, I'm gonna be dead.
Goodbye.
You're fine.
It's okay.
My Luna has her other...
Oh, never mind.
Goodbye, Luna.
Goodbye.
My Luna might have died.
I really did believe in her on living.
But I guess not.
Oh my god.
This is it.
Just use your...
Okay, there you go.
She's one.
Oh my god.
I already...
It's just Usa and Hella.
Do not...
I don't know.
But I will try my best.
I did say I would try my best.
I don't know how I dare double die.
But that is very unfortunate.
I think I got triple grabbed.
There.
I think I got...
I actually got triple grabbed.
Oh.
Um, yeah.
I'm booking it.
I will try and protect.
There you go, Luna.
You're welcome.
I've saved your life.
That was like, actually just fuck you.
That was a natural hate crap.
See, this is sort of why...
Maybe I'm not like it.
huge fan of the new meta just just a maybe you see the new
meta is it's pretty yeah it's it's it's something for sure
oh my god get him out away from us there There we go.
Look, we gotta go up.
We gotta go up and help them.
Help them.
Save them.
Save the daredevil.
Save the world!
All right, there we go.
All right.
Save them too.
I see, I hear the spot.
I mean, oh, nice.
There we go.
That was a good push for me.
0, 2, 2.
Oh my god.
Time to switch things up.
Alright, there we go.
Everything is okay.
Everything is fine.
Don't worry about it.
Everything will be okay.
You see, with this cop, it's better on attack.
It is.
At least the cop, technically, the cop is better on attack,
guys.
So, it should be easy, right?
Defensive Spider-Man is not as good as attack spider-man
things will be okay surely right surely that's that is
better on attack that's what they all say they all say that
like theoretically theoretically we should be okay on attack
30 seconds before you attack get ready you can
Dad always knows whenever I'm streaming.
He always knows.
Like, the thing is, he doesn't bark when I'm, like, not
streaming.
There's just something.
Like, I think it's the way I speak, and he's like, he thinks
that he can get more food or some shit.
But he's fully fed.
That's the thing.
Like, he can't have more food.
I already gave him all the food for today.
He always does.
Whenever I stream, he's learned.
He's, like, streaming is when I'm streaming.
I can try to get food from her.
Today's not that day.
Okay, I have to make sure that she's fine.
How is she, like, trying to kill me?
try and, like, not.
Alright.
I hope that.
There's our other dive.
Oh, there he is.
Like, Their mag is just poking us from the front line.
Wait, what?
Why do we have a Punisher?
Wait, what happened?
Wait a minute.
What happened to our cat?
What happened?
I thought we had a plan.
What happened to the double dive?
I thought...
Guys, I thought we had a plan here.
It was going so well.
What?
Why change it?
Guys, it was working.
They're like, it was working too well.
I guess it was working too well, guys.
Our Captain America is Punisher.
Guys, what happened?
I thought we all had the plan.
What happened to the plan?
This is real firepower!
Feeling fantastic.
No, our fucking hella...
Our hella's cooked.
I'm... I'm...
Oh my god.
Okay.
There we go.
Our plan!
Our plan is still working!
Alright.
Okay.
All right.
The Spider-Man has up.
Oh, I'm fucked it.
I fucked up the push.
I feel like that Wolverine is gonna come right in and then
I'm just gonna be here.
All right.
I'm- I will say, I don't know how...
I...
Okay.
Maybe we could kill one dinosaur.
There we go.
Everything is fine.
Where's the...
Okay, there we go.
See you guys.
It all worked out.
Alright.
Yeah, you know what?
The game was too easy, guys.
I understand now.
It was too easy if we went...
If we went dive on attack, you know?
We want an actual challenge for our elo.
It makes so much more sense, guys.
Like, we don't want it to be too easy.
Oh my god.
We gotta leave.
We gotta go.
All right, Punisher, very brave of you.
The game would be too easy if we have two tanks, guys.
He wants a real challenge.
Look, we want to win this with style.
We don't want... We want to go off meta.
Yeah, we got to give the enemy a fighting chance here.
i really want to throw my orb in there but jesus christ see
guys it would be too easy it would be too easy if our venom
lived it would be too easy if our venom did not be i won't
disappear so easily everyone wants to win with actual skill.
We want to...
I think we're going to...
Guys, I...
I don't think we're going to win this.
And I'm still bugging it.
But I'm starting to believe we might not win this.
Alright, we're all here.
Venom, you're a little early.
oh yeah just a little bit just a little bit you guys
no there we go where am i where could i look i used that all
i used it to oh my uh look i used it to bait look at that i
used my use my invis ult to bait oh fuck Please tell me you
have Please Oh my god Alright, alright, we're live I used my
Invisal to bait Mag ult, guys Trust the plan The plan has
been established
See the swirl girl too She was like, it'd be too easy You
know I mean, that's fine I'm gonna go push the card a little
bit you know i'm gonna push the card a little bit i want our
luna to push card so i can build up that's okay that's okay
like i said the game would be too easy if we play like how
we're supposed to play
oh they definitely i need the other fucking well i need to
be behind the cart
Holy shit.
Oh my god, we actually...
Oh my god, this is fine.
Look at that.
Look at that, guys.
We didn't...
See, look at that.
We didn't need double tank, guys.
Yeah, where's the fun in that?
Trust the plan when it's not the plan.
Look at that.
So easy.
I...
In my heart, I believed.
In my heart, I believe.
I was just reverse jinxing it.
Why did you doubt them, Doki?
It was clearly so winnable.
Doki, it was so winnable.
How dare you doubt them?
You're so right, guys.
That was my bet.
I should believe from this.
I'm avoiding Balloon Kid.
Balloon Kid was...
Might not have been the best.
His hero pool is literally Spider-Man and Squirrel Girl.
I think that's...
That might be an avoid.
That might just be an avoid.
The solo...
The solo Venkari...
Guys, he has three...
He created space, though.
I will say he did create space.
He gave us the space for our...
Hella and our...
Daredevil.
Okay.
all right yeah i'm 4-2 at the moment to be fair i only
played two games today so 2-0 skiing he's the final hit
fireman all right i'm sad i'm sad don't move my arms anymore
look at me go though look at me go yeah
it removes my ability to move my arms almost spider-man that
do the little jig.
That's all I can do now.
They stole his swagger.
They did.
Remember when he could move his arms.
Remember when he could touch his toes?
Those were the good old days.
Alright.
Oh my god, guys.
I'm GM1.
I'm climbing up in the world.
So sad.
Why did they put a time limit?
Does anyone know why they put a time limit on emotes In the
lobby?
It wasn't hurting nobody.
We just want to dance.
We just want to dance
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
If it's a bug, it's been a bug for like A couple of months,
like a month already.
And they haven't fixed it yet.
So I'm like confused why Why they removed it.
Is it just Venom?
I don't remember.
How do I swap characters again?
Uh...
How do I swap my character for it?
It's been way too long since I swapped my character.
Oh, switch display?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, they changed it.
try Jeff because I have it on Jeff too oh well guess I won't
you know I guess we'll try it later the game was like stop
stop not now no no no no which hero do you think you want to
be stop not the shark oh I want to play I'm play rocket.
I don't want to aim right now.
Oh, please.
No.
I'm betting Loki.
I don't want to play Loki, Gavit.
Don't make me play Loki Gavit.
I just, I was like, I don't want to aim right now.
Don't do this to me.
Don't hate this to me.
I'll do black hat.
Black Cat is not fun to play against, too.
I don't think we have a Black Cat player.
I'll just ban it just for the sake of it.
I don't know.
It's like 50-50 now if a Gambit gets banned because there's
so many characters to ban now.
Star Lord.
Oh yeah, he is pretty strong.
I don't know.
Now the third one, I don't know if my team's going to ban
anything.
I feel like they're not, so I don't know who to ban.
Rude.
You counter Groot.
Can you fucking ban him?
Phoenix!
You can't just be like Groot and then pick Phoenix.
Oh, well, Gammon's ban anyway.
All right, pick your hero or villain.
I'm not judging.
What are you gonna play now?
Yeah, but it was last ban Gammon.
They were thinking real long and hard about it.
Okay, white fox rocket.
Not ideal.
But let's see how this goes.
I'll swap if it doesn't work.
I just don't want to aim right now.
I just...
I aimed...
I had to aim the last two games.
I'm ready.
I'm ready to clock out.
You can count on me.
I got a plan.
I'm ready to chill.
I did my part.
30 seconds before you attack.
We don't have Gambit, by the way.
Yes, because it's banned!
I don't care to fill them in, Miss Frost.
Of course we don't.
Yeah, what the fuck is this guy on about?
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
All you need to do is capture the mission.
all right i think i might get yelled at on rocket there is a
possibility that i'll get yelled at oh my god i have to go
there's a there's an angela i have to go in this god damn it
hello hello i hope we're all having a good day here.
I was like, please save me, White Fox.
Please save me.
Please save
me.
All right, let me see it.
Let me put my res somewhere right now.
All right, because then it's closer.
This is a lot more chill.
If I was on any other support, be dead let me tell you that
but I do think I have to play I had you have to play in this
though 100% because of their Angela which
sucks because I really really did not want to place you
don't worry we have res why is he not getting res oh he died
way too afar.
It's okay.
I have res.
Do not worry.
Just don't die too far, guys.
Oh.
Hello, everybody.
Hello.
Goodbye, everybody.
Yay!
Oh my god, they really want to kill us.
Oh my god.
Hey, there's a siloed back there
Where's the siloed go?
Hello?
Oh, there she is.
Oh shit.
Oh, goodbye Hello See, I'm so safe They will never know I'm
right here I'm helping.
Look at me go.
I'm helping.
Oh.
She knows.
You know what?
It's working.
It's working right now.
I don't have to swap.
Look at that.
It's working.
right now.
No one deaf on the team.
Don't jinx this guys and don't jinx it.
It's off going smooth right now.
What a load.
Yeah, guys, I'm not stressed at all.
I'm just the little guy.
Just the little guy.
Trying to make you in the scary world.
Alright, here we go.
Just little me.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
I'm gonna put when it unlocks.
Okay.
What if he dies?
Alright, this is not gonna... this might be a little too
far.
I'll be here.
They won't know.
Oh my god!
What?
Oh my god.
Alright, that's cool.
To fuck me, I guess.
You don't?
I got sidelocked and deviled.
It's okay, it's okay.
It's alright.
I'm coming back, guys.
I'm waddling over.
I'm here.
Just in case he dies.
Just in case if he dies.
And I waddled it back.
I'm waddling back.
I'm here.
The thing is okay.
I've waddled back.
I've made it back home.
I think I'll be fine.
I'll just chuck it.
You should be okay.
She should get red's Yep Yeah, I told you, you should get
reds
All right, there we go I told you Oh my god He's coming over
He's coming over He's coming over He's still coming over
Okay, I should have voted I thought I'd be safe I should
have voted I thought it was just one guy I'm sorry.
I should have ulted.
I saw one guy and I thought it was fine
I did was just he didn't even ult he just I thought me and
the fox we got okay I did legitimately thought that we would
have survived I thought we would survive like me and the me
and the Box looked at each other and I was like don't worry.
I'll be fine.
It was just one guy I didn't want to alt for one guy.
It's okay.
We'll win this fight.
Guys.
We will win this fight.
Don't worry, guys.
Here we go.
And then here I leave.
Sorry, bro.
Woo!
all right oh no he's gonna let the double out guys he really
is goodbye he let the look she did an alt for one guy guys
she did an alt for one guy it wasn't me she did an either
look at that she also did an alt for one guy So in the end,
it was not me.
Okay, I do need to throw a new res beacon soon.
I hope nobody dies during all of that.
It's different, Doki.
Her circumstances are different.
How is it different?
We were both looking at Daredevil, We both did an alt for
the Daredevil.
So in the end, we both had the same idea.
Why were we all for one person?
She died too!
She also died!
She died with me!
She did!
I clearly saw her die!
But she's a white fox and your raccoon.
Oh, you're right.
I have no rights.
You're right.
You're just, I forgot.
Guys.
Silly old me.
Yeah, but she's a bigger than you.
I forgot.
No rights for this little fella.
It's like it's like when you're talking about like
difference between a cat girl and a furry.
Cat girl's fine because that's different.
All right, let's see.
if it works let's see if it loops or not see you get it
i'm but i know but i know but i know but i don't but i don't
but i don't know
It's just not the same.
See, this one loops.
Oh my, this is discrimination.
It is actually discrimination.
I can't believe it.
Maybe that...
So it's just a venom bug.
Oh, is it favoritism?
This is favoritism.
This is fucking favoritism.
Of course.
Of course, Jeff.
Jeff the mascot gets to have the full dance a fucking course
This is outright favoritism right there His dance loops
forever, but oh Oh, but if I want the venom twitch it stops
me after 15 seconds He's an industry plat there.
I said it.
I fucking said it
all right i'll do one more guys i finished the campaign so
i'll do one more my record was what three three oh that's
pretty good oh four no three oh no three oh Yeah.
How many games are I need?
Technically, I don't want to play.
I don't want to finish placements.
All right.
LG, LG, LG.
Because I have a lot of other very long streams later.
Because I do want to get as much progress as I can.
Because I, you know, actually, I'm going to actually start a
three series.
Whoops.
My bad.
Didn't help it.
just so many games that just released you know all these
games are releasing
so i need to get as much progress as i can uh with armored
core batman and also well okay you know what when i was like
looking you know i'm always like youtube like how like oh
how much do i have left on uh how much do i have left of the
game by youtube being like uh like record no commentary and
then just to see where i'm at so the vod was like the video
was like 10 hours or something or seven hours it was like
seven to ten hours and i was at the two hour point and i
think but yeah i think i streamed for like eight hours
already i'm pretty sure but on but on the on the on the
video the playthrough I was at the two-hour point.
It's gonna be a while.
So my seven hours of progress.
So the dokey...
So I was like, how much...
How long do I finish this game in dokey hours?
That's true.
Half the time is spent on building the mecha.
That is true, though.
Oh my gosh.
If I don't find a game at five minutes, I'm calling.
it.
Nice.
See it?
You gotta threaten them.
They knew.
Thank you, FBI agent.
Put her in your game right now!
Oh, of course.
Of course I get the Celestia.
Of course the enemy team has three Celestias.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
There you go.
They heard me.
Thanks, Netties.
What do I want to play?
Do I want to play Cloak?
I want to do Cloak right now.
We are hope and fear.
Now, who am I gonna banish from this match?
They're like, oh fuck, put her in the game right now.
I hope that other guy plays support.
That'll be pretty awkward.
Oh, pretty awkward.
Alright, we found Gambit.
Yippee!
All the difference.
All right.
Surely this guy plays support, right?
Surely, right?
Ha ha ha.
Weren't you like to play support right now?
Ooh, I'm sending in my brain waves at you.
You really want to pick support.
Come on.
It's right there.
You're the last one to pick.
You're feeling quite supporty right now.
Is this domination again?
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Come on.
Don't you just...
Yay!
Oh, yeah, they're Lord too.
That's good.
Yay.
All right, they're also a Lord.
That works out for us.
All right.
I'll swap the invis if I have to.
Why, that reminds me.
I have to text my dog sitter if they're free.
for next week.
They're a little awkward.
Oh, okay.
All right, there's dive.
There's our road.
I hope our two tanks live.
Our two tanks live.
Okay, they're running rockets.
at him.
Okay.
Oh.
So our two tanks did not live.
Alright.
Okay.
In this time.
Oh,
that's awkward.
Oh.
I don't it hasn't been one minute.
Oh wait, they dodged
I don't I don't know if that's been one minute has it been
one minute guys has it has it had no way Yay
Yeah We're safe Yay
what was it she saw she saw what happened to her two tinks
and was like i'm out of here what if i'm out of here the
truth god never punished all right i'll think if i want to
do one more i need to use the bathroom first and then i'll
decide but for now why go pee you guys have because i get it
working jeff i'll be right back yay never punished
i'm back guys okay i thought about it i'm just thinking what
if that was a side what if what if that was a side from from
above but maybe you know what i feel a little i feel a
little quirky today very much i mean oh yeah i feel like
that's that's them being like stop
Also, Mr. Kellogg, thank you for Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
But I'll give you something else instead.
I'll give you one game of Apex Legends.
That's right.
Rare Apex Moment.
One game.
I would have kept going if I had a duo, but I didn't.
So I was just like, thank God.
No one to enable me.
all right let's see unless wait let me see it oh wait
wait i could get a squad right now i could get my buddies
are you guys playing apex right now
i could i could grab my buddies i but then they're also
european so i'm worried about getting them in the car
It might not be the wisest I joined.
What does that mean?
They can say some crazy stuff.
That's what I'll say.
They may or may not say some crazy things.
Okay.
These are people I knew before I joined Corp up, basically.
Uh.
Are any gamers or European?
I would join Dirt VC right now, but I'm scared of joining
the VC when I'm on stream.
I don't know what they'll say.
Let's see.
Oh, they're playing Deadlock.
Oh, they're playing Deadlock right now.
Okay.
Sadly.
Sadly, no European stack.
I text, I messaged, I text, I've discorded them.
We'll do.
I'm flat three now.
Look, guys.
I'm flat three.
We'll do unranked.
Alright, one game.
You need to practice anyway.
My channel lives for another day.
At least I'm on Twitch, though.
It's not as bad.
If it hits, it hits my Twitch channel.
So not as bad if you think about it.
Alright, here we go.
It has been a while since I've streamed this on Twitch.
Where the fuck are my players?
Hello?
I just missed a kill.
I wish I could, like, do a gun game or something while in
queue.
I think that's the one thing that I wish they've
implemented.
I never got bad.
I've only, in any game, I've only been like, they've only
had them change my name one time, which I told the story
before, because my name was Gamers Rise Up, and then they
asked, and then Blizzard was like, please change your name.
So, Gamers had to sit down.
I tell this story a lot, but yeah.
I don't know, they might be better now.
They, they...
Let's see.
Guys, maybe if I have another account for gamers rise up,
maybe it'll be fine.
Gamers are so oppressed.
It's so sad.
I fucked my lobby.
Oh.
I guess it's because NA, everybody's sleeping on NA, but I
don't want to play.
I don't want to play Asia servers.
I just want my ping.
Oh, the new character is really fun.
Well, it's really fun to play and, like, use your util.
But, like, I always, like I said, I always get, like, so
overwhelmed whenever I have to use your util.
Because I'm, like, not used to how...
Like, when things go too fast, I'm just not used to it.
I'm just really bad when things are super fast.
Hey, Ruben.
Everybody's asleep.
Yeah, I'm okay.
Yeah, I'm down.
I'm streaming right now.
All right.
Might have a squad lineup.
Hey, that's me.
all right here we go i haven't played while apex while
streaming in a while so i don't know how nerfed i'll be what
no one wants to be jump master i'm not being jump master
come on you guys won your last game yeah but we could run
some we can run down on something all
right why am i streaming slight because i forgot i took i
said i clicked like yes to two spots on the sponsor tab on
Twitch and then like one of them's deadline was tomorrow and
I was like whoops I was like where did the month go I had an
entire month I did have I had an entire month not anymore
that month passed by so fast
someone got first blood and that someone was not me all
right I still fight it funny that they have windows so the
meta currently right now is hemlock hemlock re re45 feels so
fucking good i love it i love how good it feels also the
hemlock too because it's like literally like uh it feels
like a faster re uh repeater i've always had issues with
repeater aim just because like it just feels slow so i like
that i really like that why are you guys running Did you not
win?
Did you not win your last game?
Why are you playing like fucking pussies?
Well, now I know how you won your fucking last game.
Like, what?
Why are you running?
Oh my god, the fact that they passed by.
You guys are actually pussies.
The fact that they're running away from a fight.
Alright.
Okay, I got invited apparently.
Alright, they're ready.
They're getting full lead for winning.
Like, what are they doing?
Did you not win your last fight?
Why are you running away from the fight?
Oh, I wanted to steal that.
I'm so bad with the...
I hate the timer thing, like, fucks me up a lot.
Alright, they're ready.
So I just gotta int.
I just gotta run it down.
Apparently it's not one game anymore.
It might be more than one game.
It might be several games.
It might have made of the...
Oopsie.
Like, why?
Okay, I need to put that on.
I don't like the...
I really don't like the...
What's it called?
The default thing for it.
I already forgot all the terms I
already forgot all the apex terms guys I don't like default
sites I don't remember what it's called there's a word for
it Iron site yes Iron site that's the word yeah I hate the
iron site for the hemlock
like tap 10 10 squads dead what are we doing lucifer why are
we following this guy why are we following mr lucifer half
the squad's dead what is our purpose
why are we here what are you two doing one guy is slowly
climbing up the wall when i'm already here i swear to god if
i get shot i swear Because your fucking support is
frontlining.
Bro, Lucifer is a fucking demon, bro.
Like, if we're doing this, I might as well start enhancing.
Oh my god, he came here to loot.
He came here to fucking...
Oh my god, I heard shots.
I'm going for this.
I swear to God.
If you're not running forward to that shot, I will be so
sad.
All right, we're all going there, right?
That's the plan.
All right.
I'm rolling it.
Oh, they won the fight already.
Oh, no, never mind.
That's from a different area.
Oh, I see them.
I see them.
They're right in front of us.
Surely we're going to start shooting, right?
And we're going to start blasting.
And then she started blasting.
I got this guy was so low.
He's thirsting you.
Give me your shit.
I'll grab that.
I mean, they were fighting people down there.
I see them.
Oh dear.
Sounds of targets this way.
I hope they don't make me the support come down.
That'll be pretty shitty for me.
support oh my god they're actually pushing in oh they're
running out oh there is a reason why there is a nope i hit
them jesus all right fuck this i feel like this is gonna
happen to us like they're gonna
why did you close they close
What did my teammate fucking oh my god you better rest me
you fucking better fucking rest me you whore You fucking
close the door on me it would have been we would oh my god
oh my it's okay it's okay it's okay
I swear to God, Lucifer, Lucifer, he's literally Lucifer,
you cannot, Lucifer lost this, Lucifer actually lost it, he,
oh my god, Lucifer, Lucifer, Lucifer, Lucifer, please,
anything that could happen happen i'm i don't know how that
team won last game i will say that i i don't know how i
really legitimately don't know how don't i swear to god just
i swear to god i could leave right now and then go to my
squad but i'm curious on how this is gonna i'm curious on
how on how they're gonna do this i really am let's see let's
see how this plays oh my god there's four squads left bro if
i see this man rat in the corner if i swear to god if i see
this man start ratting i swear to god
They're so fucked.
Yeah, I was gonna say, why would you...
You heard the redeploy.
You heard...
Why would you still keep running?
You've heard the redeploy.
So...
Oh my god.
You're not even gonna get the res!
Okay, he's gonna craft us.
Okay, on second zone.
Okay, we'll get our stuff back at least.
Alright.
Those who don't know, they had an update where you can res
on the box.
I...
Oh, come on.
Oh my god, no.
Oh my god, they actually don't know.
They actually don't know.
They actually tried to do the set-box res.
Oh my god.
How do you not know?
You're a baby cooked.
She's so dead.
She could have got heals from my box.
Alright.
They didn't read the patch, though.
Oh, they came back.
They just came back.
Yeah, maybe.
Maybe they just came back too.
He could res this right here, but I guess not.
Fuck us, right?
You know what he could do?
Res is right there in the back, and then we could grab a
gun.
All right, that's fine.
You know what he could do right now?
He could res this right here because he could grab the res
beacon.
I swear to God, this guy.
Okay, that's fine.
All right.
I'm going to get eight.
We're going to get eight so hard.
all right let's see oh i couldn't scout enough i should get
moving i don't want to get toasted i have come to save the
day maybe preparing all right i was gonna grab the heavy i
do not feel confident at all
Okay.
I'm just gonna grab all of this.
I have iron sights though for my hemlock, which sucks.
I'm gonna go up here.
All right, at least he's grabbing care packages.
There we go.
There's an opponent by me.
What?
Oh my god, how did they know?
How?
I made zero noise.
That's fucked.
That's actually fucked.
They literally rolled down and then didn't even like...
Oh my god.
They smelled me.
They smelled my god.
I just thought they were trying to rush into my teammate.
Because I just stayed there.
Like, hid there.
Yeah, but you would assume I would have, like, ran off.
They literally just insta-turned, too.
That's crazy.
They just...
Lucifer was like, fuck this.
Lucifer doesn't want to deal with this shit anymore.
It's me and Roxby, let's go.
Oh yeah, we're not winning this.
Like the moment he raises us, goodbye.
Good luck.
It's literally, she got second place, good for her.
I'm heading in.
Cat in the hat.
all right invite me
i hope that was my friend i hope i was like oh because
they're yeah in the hat let's go oh wait there you go wait
is r is rg inviting or who is inviting all right it's no
longer one game now it's Maybe it's several, several games.
It's now maybe a several games.
I'm waning.
Oh yeah, so one of my buddies is...
I think they're both roller players.
Wait.
Is RG a roller player?
Or I forgot.
It's been a while.
I haven't played with Archie in, like, years.
Alright.
I'm just waiting.
Alright, we're all here.
We're all here.
Alright, now we're gonna play on EU servers.
Wish us luck.
Oh, yeah, two roller players!
Let's go!
Let's fucking go!
That's two roller players.
Yay!
team for the tournament yeah i readied up i readied up i'm
like debating i want to do a vc with them because because
they're not they're just regular guys they don't have the
sensor built in the streamer sensor like so you're just bros
being bros John Gamer
yeah the streamer sense yeah
what's the worst that could happen I don't know maybe I get
suspended for a day
I don't know I'm just that's That's just how what I hope in
terms of punishment.
Worth it.
Oh, all right.
All right, let's hope everything will go okay.
Let's hope everything will be okay.
All right, let's go.
Oh yeah, I heard about Treadins.
I saw.
I played a pub where the Treadins were just gone.
Alright, I believe.
I believe in the play with no comms.
Yeah, Shifty is a Call of Duty pro for Twisted Minds.
And then Mac plays for Alberlale slash Mac plays for
Nemesis.
I'm pretty sure.
i don't keep up with apex esports as much anymore but hello
why did you ping he's like look at this shiny new gun i got
that's not yours that you don't get to have all right it's a
25k uh it's a 25k uh tournament hosted by a big rainbow six
siege player
whoa i almost fell down i mean they're all downstairs i feel
like we could honestly you're fighting over there we should
just go fuck it
wait wait Am I?
Oh, I forgot my 200 ping wingman.
That's not the smartest idea.
It is an idea, but might not be the smartest.
I was like, hmm, all right, 200 ping wingman.
Let's go.
Let's see how that goes.
Oh, that one second delay.
I sure love that.
Oh my god, are you serious?
Good luck to us, I guess.
I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
All right, goodbye.
Don't worry!
Don't chase me!
Don't worry, I'm distracting them!
So this is what I'm doing.
I'm baiting them to me so he doesn't fall.
You're so fat!
distraction successful so what I did basically it was I say
to fight them so my teammate did he run back why did you
come back I distracted them I said he go we had we did this
yesterday he didn't get the plan it looked okay so so
basically what the original plan was i thought he sort of
knew i thought i sent my brain waves over to him where he
understood was i basically i stayed to fight so i could
distract them for as long as possible so he could run away
and resume us and be far away so that the squad that was
chasing us would be too distracted to chase me to chase him
who was supposed to run to a different spot and res yet the
brainwaves were a little late like if only they knew if only
they read my brain waves in time guys you're right there's
there was a sorry there's a 200 ping delay between our
communications.
That's true.
That's true, guys.
There's a 200 ping delay between our brainwaves right now.
Wait, this is new.
What the fuck?
Where is this area?
What the fuck am I looking at?
If only they had...
If only they had voice chat in this game.
Too bad they don't.
Man, so unfortunate this game doesn't have a VC.
Where is...
Oh, I guess there was a team there.
This is...
We're just trying to find the closest crafter, I guess.
He's like, there's enemies here.
And I'm like...
So?
Pussy?
You can still get some use out of it.
Oh my god, we're like on the other side.
I swear to god.
I swear to god if he slides into a full ass team, I swear to
god.
Alright, there we go.
And the Ouija board talking.
We're talking via symbols right now.
I didn't realize that.
I forgot the censors.
I'll never know what I wanted to say.
I'll never know.
I mean, at least we have Heavy there.
Alright.
Let's get...
How far is it?
It's not that bad, actually.
Oh, he's not in Resonance.
is here okay it's fine
all right well let's see i could grab my art where is it
wait what all right oh you need a res silly
Oh, yeah, because he can get healed from it.
There's a heavy ammo.
I need to grab the...
Oh, it's so far.
Fuck that shit.
No, I'm not doing it.
I'm just gonna go to spawn...
Or go to point.
Oh, I thought there would be something.
Anything for us.
Anything at all?
No.
Just got garbage loot.
Now I'll grab the R9.
Like, it's something.
So at least I can heal.
I'm going to grab that bitkin, actually.
Alright.
That's fine.
It doesn't hurt that bad.
Alright.
I'm going to follow them.
Is that hemlock?
That is.
But is that an R&E 45?
Alright, I got everything I need.
Not ammo though.
Alright, nice!
Yay!
We did it!
Look at that!
So easy.
I was part of that fight.
I helped.
Look at me, girl.
I'm so helpful.
Alright, grab that.
Hooray!
Thank you guys, I know.
That was so helpful.
You see me?
You see me helping out?
Helping my team out?
Where are they going?
Look at that.
I was creating space.
I am the space maker.
As always.
I don't know.
Don't worry guys, the space maker is here.
You're gonna make space for all of us.
Look at that, already plus 35.
Look at that, and huh, another team died.
I've willed that into existence.
Oh, in front of me.
I say, I talk to myself.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I said it out loud, so maybe they heard me.
You know?
I'm sending out my brain waves, it's over.
That's good.
They're fighting.
Holy shit, that's too!
Wow!
Wait, where's the last guy?
I need to grab this.
All right, I'm met kidding.
Oh, I see him.
He's so far away.
Goodbye!
I'll see you next time!
Thank you.
Goodbye!
Oh, shit!
Okay, I didn't think he'd come back.
I didn't think he was gonna come back, guys.
I was taunting him.
I was just taunting him.
Who would have thought he came back?
Is?
Where is that little guy?
Oh, solo.
Okay.
All right, I do have too much shit.
All right, here we go.
Oh, where's that little rat?
Where's that little guy?
Okay, one.
Oh, there he is.
Hello!
Oh, he's gone.
Goodbye.
Don't worry, guys.
I'm here now.
Actually, there's no one's gonna take it.
I'll take it.
Look at that!
I did so much.
Alright.
I don't know about that.
When you account for ping, I keep forgetting to do that.
When I leave my... What the fuck?
Oh my god, the fucking sky names.
Those were good names.
That was a really good name.
What?
There you go.
Where's the other guy?
I don't know why he would do that.
But it's time.
We roll out.
Roll out!
Yay!
That was a good-ass nade, though, from that other guy.
It's so easy.
Yippee!
Yay!
And then we'll never know.
Wait, do I have to exit?
And then...
Ready, get it.
Alright.
Do I have to...
Oh my god, it's broken.
Yeah.
I hate that bug.
I hate that bug where you can't just queue up instantly.
It's so annoying.
Yeah.
I was gonna say, did it fix it?
It's so annoying, though.
Alright, I matched it up to join VC.
That was a little hard.
That might have been a little hard.
Okay, I will join VC.
Do not get me bad.
That's all out.
That's a little hard.
I only have one request.
Do not get me bad.
Alright.
I need to know they're in, like, their own...
Why are they...
Okay.
That's all I ask for.
If I'm gonna join the server, I would like to not be bad.
Alright.
Oh, he's typing.
I don't know what he's typing about.
I'm waiting for a response right now.
joining okay all right wait what's the discord i forgot i
know bro there's so many servers he's like joining his
server i'm like which one is his server bro i don't fucking
know the name of his server it's not even the server we hang
out on
bro what the fuck is what where which one's his survey
okay mutual servers oh i found it i found the server i'm
checking in what y'all do i'm pubs up
all right i'm waiting for the drag up where the fuck are
they drag me i'm literally here oh my god i lost track where
which server am i in Hello?
What's up?
Okay, don't...
I'm streaming.
Okay, I need a...
Oh, I don't want to be Jumpmaster.
Give me a sec.
Let me set stuff up.
All right, we got this.
I believe in us.
We got this.
Also forgot to bind my mute button.
So, if I'm talking to my chat, you're gonna hear it.
I'm a clutter comms.
Oh, I have 35 pocket notes.
nice I have 200 ping oh my god oh there's people in here oh
I'm dead I'm so dead I got one though the other guys right
here yeah he has a bow check like what's he gonna do with a
bow check oh they're racing they're racing they're
committing the rest they're committing the rest right here
Nice.
You know?
You can go for us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm so reasonable.
Nice.
I'm gonna heal.
All right.
I do only have one gun.
Are they downstairs or?
Oh, okay.
I'm zooming.
Nice.
Is that the only team?
Same team.
I know, no, but was that any other team land here?
No, no, no, no.
Oh, okay, cool.
All right, let me fix my settings now.
Give me a second.
I gotta restart my Discord.
Give me a sec.
I'm going to hide here and just hope to God no one comes to
us.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm going to restart my Discord.
Alright, guys.
I have to restart my Discord so I can do push to mute.
I don't have...
So they have to drag me back in.
I hope to God.
Hope to God I'd be safe and over here.
Alright, they got to redrag me.
Oh, where is the server again?
forgetting where where is the server where is the server i
did drag this it's like in 20 folders of so many folders
okay i need to drag the server out of my other folder you
know how like you think you now could use that server again
so it's dragged it's like in this folder within a folder
within a folder within a folder yeah that's basically it all
right okay and then i need to know what the channels call so
i set it up all right all right let's see i'm back in a oh
nice yay all right let me yay i'm back you're buying my mute
button all right there you go all right and then Oh my god.
It's a private channel, so I can't use my overlay.
Put us in the public channel, RG.
No one's gonna hop in.
I believe.
We should be fine, right?
All right, guys.
We're in the private channel, so I can't...
You won't see that... We don't have the Discord overlay.
We don't have a Discord overlay because it's in a private
channel.
so it doesn't have access guys, I need heals oh, alright I'm
coming back, I'm coming back here yeah people in the States
alright, alright, let's fight them let's go oh wait, I need
that actually I don't worry, I'll be there in like 10
seconds yeah I'm here they're scared I'm gonna save Alpha
tier, I think.
Alright.
Oh, I'm heading over.
Ooh, they're shy.
They're shy.
They know that I'm streaming, so they're shy right now.
They've never been this locked in before.
I'm heading over.
I don't see them.
I might be running right into them.
They're far.
Oh, they're so far.
Okay, okay.
Wait, wait.
I need...
Oh, yeah, okay.
Above, above, okay, okay.
Both three months.
He's resting, he's resting.
Oh, well, how are we gonna get up there?
I guess it's up to you, Tsuki.
I have two nades up there.
I can aid too.
I'm going around.
I need it.
I'm going to him.
Yeah.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
They're shooting from here.
Or...
They're fighting in front of us.
They're fighting right in front of us.
Okay.
I'm going up.
Yeah.
There you go.
There you went to my right.
We can fight this team over here.
Oh, I see him.
I'm shooting the ones on the bottom.
They're also low.
Okay, okay.
I knocked one!
Nice.
You might...
They're running.
Guys, well, next trade is okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Got him.
Another guy?
All right, I don't have nades, so...
I'm up in one guy.
I'm giving you shields, though.
You naded?
I'm thirsting?
I'm grabbing his hemlock.
Guys, you guys made them super shy, guys.
You guys made them so shy.
Is there any more teams?
Yeah.
All right.
Let's go.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, they're so shy now, they're shy that it was.
They're like, oh, we gotta, we gotta be a good boy.
So yeah.
Lucky one.
Good.
All right.
They're on the other side and we're going.
Yeah, I'm going from...
Yeah.
On me, on me, me, me!
Behind you!
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
They're all...
It's three, it's three, it's three.
They're pushing me.
One of them is low because I saw them shield.
I didn't think all of them were there.
One of you, Watson.
They're rezzing?
Watson's one in the corner, should they?
Yeah.
I'm chilling.
I'm chilling for you.
Oh.
Yeah.
I think we got...
You gotta leave.
They're full res.
It's all three.
Alright.
Okay, now I can set up my Discord.
Are we in the public?
Okay, we're in the public channel now.
Anyone could hop in.
So we're...
No, how are you not dead?
Okay.
we're in the public channel anyone can opt in i said i was
like guys we got this just go in it'll be fine so it might
be a little risky
where is it what the fuck why is it showing up where's the
closest craft is solo all right Oh,
so how's the sound?
Guys, how's the sound right now?
Where is the closest?
What even is the closest, Rose?
Oh my god.
I told you guys, dude.
could be louder they're little they're quiet boys they got
they got nervous now that i'm streaming
yeah you're shy they're shy gamer boys
all right let's see i need they could be louder i'll turn
them up a little higher I don't know sound I don't think
sound guy is here Let me know they're better I turn them up
a little higher Because I don't have to turn them up higher
You know Well one of them is
One of them is my friend who had I told he's fine with me
telling Guys this by the way Because I told you guys before
But one of them is the guy that is actually schizophrenic.
Yeah, he's that's Suki.
Yeah, we're back.
Go.
All right, I believe.
There's our teammates over here.
This looks great.
Okay.
Yeah, but he's like super nice.
Oh, wait, wait.
I might be dead.
I fucked up the slide I'm gonna look for you now Okay, I'm
so healthy.
I have another cube thrown to you guys right now.
Are they gonna?
Are they... Oh, okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
Yeah, yeah, I got it.
You got bats if you're gonna need to put out on me.
Yeah, I need a bat.
Are they pushing in or no?
Okay, I'm batting.
It's okay.
Fuck the mag too.
Do you need shield cells?
Are you Suki?
Are you good?
Oh my god, I forgot I was muted.
Suki, do you need shield cells?
Yeah, I'm bad right now.
Okay, okay, here.
He's got advantage.
There's a bat here.
I get it.
Thank you.
All right.
I'll grab the syringes.
Whoa.
I don't have like I don't have a scope for my hemlock so I
don't know what to oh I have a shield I have more shield
cells if you need some they drop they drop they're dropping
oh yeah I see one of them's got a vantage too yeah they're
behind the rock they're behind this rock we should push them
they're blue let's push them all right about names too I
have needs I have needs I have needs Oh my god.
One's here, one's here, one's here.
One's pushing me, one's pushing me.
I'm with you.
Yeah, I'm coming with you.
I burn one, I burn...
Flash, flash, one, splash!
Flash, one!
Wow, low on Wraith.
Right here.
Flash, flash!
I don't have him, I don't have him.
He's cracked.
He's not cracked.
He's no longer cracked.
Oh, he's not cracked.
Oh, he was not cracked.
Never mind, I'll go.
Yeah, he's dead.
He's dead.
I'll res.
yeah yeah
all right yeah they have Devo here there's infinite ammo if
anyone wants it oh yes I'm gonna take this time off I don't
want to heal I have like 18 shield cells if anyone needs any
all good enough all good enough all right I need a light
mode it's funnier where was that infinite ammo on Oh, he
took it.
Yeah.
Okay.
I took it.
Does anyone got light or heavy?
Uh, don't have enough.
I have an alt Excel.
Does anyone want one?
No.
I'm just fucking starting at my first.
All right.
You guys think again?
Oh, this team team team to right.
I want to try and get an angle.
I don't have an angle here.
They're like up on the third floor.
Yeah.
We should go this way.
Have double Q.
Come here.
Yeah.
I'm here I'm a little far might get shot at let's see I'm
okay we know
what the other teams are yeah one's in front of us too we
should be on right here all right yeah in front of me right
here I'm batting right here in front of me knock one okay I
almost crushed this kid flash flash flash he's like one he's
actually one he's actually one I hit 17 my grenade oh he's
so far
it was so low try out weighing my master for respect i have
a gold light mag i suddenly like picked it up
fighting on the right all right yeah that loba is solo right
he's in here he's in here yeah yeah i'm going should just
kill him should she be there yeah I think.
Nah, you're me.
She took the cure.
Oh, here!
On me, on me, on me!
She didn't think I'd be there.
She went that way, she went that way.
He's really well.
Oh my God.
He's literally just one guy.
Spawn them.
Nice.
Bye.
Yay.
Oh my God, he literally broke the window just to come to me.
when we grab the overflow.
What was the last thing that was the last thing that you
were like in front of us, right?
They were they were shooting at each other.
They're low ground.
They're low ground here.
There's also an alt alt Excel.
They just rest.
I don't know where the other one's team is.
I don't know.
One team is here.
There's a down guy here.
Well, there's boxes here.
That's a tear of that.
i see him oh i i think they're like all the way there i've
spotted an enemy they're far oh he's on oh yeah oh no he's
one he's so low he's resident the runner he's one he's one i
don't know we can get res though might be reasonable here
yeah i'm ready i mean they're pushing
i'm gonna turn soft on this box i gave you armor there they
come there they come they're right here at open heights
they're mirage cloned we need to move out not everyone's
home I hit one with my ult.
I'm ulting.
Wait, army?
Oh, I might be dead.
Oh, I got confused with the clones.
Two steps to be.
And the other one's cracked too.
I knocked one.
It's unlucky.
Ah, the clones!
The clones!
The fucking clones!
Oh!
That was unlucky.
Last one here.
I'm selling.
He's selling, yeah.
He's thirsting for armor swap.
You got it?
Yeah, you got it.
Okay, where is it?
Can you print?
Oh, you're dead.
We're both dead.
He's just full healing.
He's resin.
Yeah.
yeah I've always believed I knew you got it look at that
yeah let's go let's go we all saw it Archie we all saw it
let's fucking go easy I was there all right I can go turn on
my fucking heater bro it's like 20 degrees in my house I Got
it.
Oh My dead-ass fucking shivering in my fucking chair.
Wait, what's what's temperature right now over there?
It's like 40 degrees outside Jesus Like Celsius No
Fahrenheit.
Oh, okay.
I was getting it.
It's just gonna be like what?
Look at that guys, I was there.
I think I'm speaking American is
oh my god i was gonna say what what do you mean yeah and i
had my ac set to 50.
it's good thank you why is he talking in fair night all
right is the sound okay right now for everybody for their vc
is it okay look at that we're climbing guys that was there
That's good.
All right.
No, they're shy right now.
They're a lot more talkative when I'm not streaming.
They're like, what can we say and what can we say?
They call them out.
You haven't been on stream before.
obviously like not at like as a corporal I can't do that but
I'm indie I can bring anybody on stream yeah they don't see
anything can't be held against them what's the problem yeah
just casually two of thousand people come on say something
so broken it's crazy wait is it is it more broken than RE I
think so yeah it's a really oh wait what makes it oh i guess
just because you just don't let go i guess it's broken if
you're a controller player well for me i get extra bullets
in this character too oh oh that's true that's true yeah all
right yeah all they could they're like what should we talk
about let's talk about the game that's safe the game is safe
talking about the game is
You can't go around with the game.
I can't believe, yeah, so you can't believe you're back into
Apex.
What happened?
Is it really just the devil boy nerf?
I mean, you not want to play?
What was the second character you played?
Dicta.
Oh.
Oh, I don't have a gun.
Oh my god, they got landed on guys.
wait there no rg got landed on all right i have a gun down
coming over i do have here i gave you shields or the others
there's a team here too they're fighting over there it
should be two of us for you i'm grabbing the re then i'm
going for that guy yeah i'm coming over here all right i'm
coming over now too i don't have shields for you guys i used
it up it's fine
He's in the air, I think.
Oh, yeah, he's dead.
He stopped us.
Crack.
Let's sit on.
Sit on.
He's so low.
Crack, crack, crack, crack.
He's the same.
Oh.
I tried to find the swap, but...
Oh, my God.
How many?
Is it a full team team?
Okay, I'm going to res.
He'll shield us.
Wait, are you good?
Yep.
We're good.
They didn't push us.
They're racing.
Right outside.
Alright.
There's a rampage here.
I can nade.
I'm nading?
Wait, there's someone!
What the?
Here, here, on the balcony.
Yeah.
They're like right here.
Oh, they're alting, they're alting us.
Yeah.
Nice.
Octane one.
Inside, watch him.
I got Octane.
By Lush.
Where's the raid?
Oh, he ran.
Okay, I'm gonna thirst him then.
Shoot him there.
Oh, no, I'm...
I need heavy ammo.
I have zero bullets.
No bullets.
We're here.
I'm chasing this guy.
Not thirst, I'm thirsted.
Oh, you're on.
Nice.
All right, yay!
He still has a teammate, wherever he is.
And he ran.
I think I still got it.
All right.
Oh, I'm me, I'm me, me, me!
Cossie, cossie, cossie!
Let's be a solo.
Yeah, oh, he's a solo.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Solo, solo.
Wait, is there...
Does that mean there's still the other team?
No, no.
all right but i'll be back i gotta get everything jesus
christ all right yeah they left my champs okay i'm sad yeah
you see if you say hi to my chat this is the first time
meeting you oh yeah i told them i told them you're the guy
uh you're that guy yeah i'm just gonna scan real quick
actually okay
oh i hear shots at a state oh and i stayed uh oh wait
there's a team literally heading there's one solo there's
one solo heading to it oh i think he's resing yeah never
mind he's just resing yeah i'm just i'm still looking a bit
because i'll go protect rg yeah i'll protect them don't
worry he's safe
Wait, I think I heard something.
I'm coming back over then.
I don't know.
I heard the speed thingy.
Yep, yep, yep.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're pressing on us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I literally heard that.
3KB!
Oh, really?
Okay.
I'm gonna drop it off the ship.
Drop it off the ship right now.
Lo, it was still coming.
I got him.
Bangalore one.
I...
I need a reload.
I got him, I got him, I got him.
All right, res him.
Was that the res guys?
There's only two.
Yeah, I need energy ammo.
Oh, there's someone here.
Yeah.
I need to lose some audio crystal.
A lot of worthless stuff in my inventory.
I'm gonna craft ammo.
All right.
Okay.
Where'd you want to go?
No, this seems to come to us, I guess.
Oh wait, what the fuck?
I still have a massive re.
If anyone finds a hemlock, let me know.
Yeah.
I'm still running massive.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
He's one, he's one, he's one, he's one.
I'm dead.
I'm coming over, I'm coming over.
I have to climb them.
Oh, man.
She's going on this skin?
It's quite hard.
Yeah, but I'm...
Both team.
They're getting chased by him from Watson.
Oh my god.
You win this one, this.
He's scared.
He's flush.
He's so scared right now.
I got him.
Oh my god.
All right.
The caddy is here.
Look at me go.
I'm so, 200 ping carry.
That's right.
That's an armor suit.
Oh my god, I got a different gun.
numbers aren't big let's go honestly got away okay i'm gonna
grab this armor swap then oh wait i got him oh i you know
i'm doing i'm doing on the mast i'm gonna keep it i just
won't have long range above you yeah almost going oh in the
back no they're gonna they're gonna wipe us yeah yeah
they're gonna wait for us here they're both i do i'm gonna
ulti here though i thought you were else yeah yeah yeah look
look for us
careful careful there's a lot of needs watch and that's nice
i can't cross there's needs i hope to look in the back kill
the watch in here all right i need to pop my kit guys yeah
i'm covering i'm covering i'm checking they're they're
trying to res right here right here to try to raise right
here now oh i can't do anything yeah yeah i want to turn
this game coming over one there's just one guy above though
okay i'm above i don't see him i think he he's running off
yeah yeah i see him he's right there oh he's full god i
should be two teams careful yeah yeah yeah i'm getting
sniping i'm gonna snipe Yeah, I'll grab it.
Whoa, shit!
No, fight!
I'm okay, I'm okay!
I'm okay!
Yeah, I got, I got armor swap.
I'm fine, I'm fine.
I'm fine.
No, no, no, no.
The skill is in.
They're not good.
They have blues.
Do you remember this?
On me?
I mean, they're...
Yeah, they're pushing.
I'll take cells.
I got hit by the gas.
Flesh!
On me, on me?
Nice.
He's blue, he's blue, he's blue.
Oh, nice.
Where's the last guy?
All right.
He's resting in smoke, I think.
There is a...
Yeah, there's a big rest behind us.
One last week.
Nice.
Oh my god, we never left.
We have to go.
We...
Yeah, we have to go.
It's a gold hemlock in there.
It's okay if you want to.
Oh, it's too late.
We haven't left, but I finally got actual guns.
Yeah, pop-packs.
This was the first time we had guns.
Popping it up.
Guns low here.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
I'm here.
Yep.
Oh, what the?
Yeah, you saw that, right?
Here.
There's a solo below us.
I'm just going to go past them all.
Yeah, yeah, there's way too.
That's four teams.
Go that way.
Go underneath.
Go underneath here.
I'm sending a cue here.
We're sending going to gravity.
There's a team on the high ground here, too.
There is a
team in front of us, too.
Yeah, yeah.
All right.
AP nice they're on us okay I'm batting I'm batting and
batting right now I'm batting I'm good they're trying to
push us I'm on I got one I got one are they nice I ulted
them too Yeah above oh wait that's another squad right or
same squad no I'm not yeah no don't he should on he's low
lord okay I'm back coming on pushing up pushing on pushing
you up on me i couldn't get him i can give you i give you
armor swap behind you i give you armor swap behind you okay
oh he has a new squad i'm looking what's up with the team
well i want to be nice right here ventus last one it's a duo
no it's not a duo it's not a duo no um i'm gonna rest i'm
gonna rest Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, cover, cover, cover.
They're throwing nades.
Okay.
Behind us as well, careful.
Yeah.
They're just trying to...
We can't thirst, I don't think so.
I'm gonna grab the...
I'm actually gonna...
I mean, the master's been doing good for me still.
It should be a duo up here.
It should be last two.
Alright.
They're going for birds over here.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm right with you?
Yeah.
They're looking at me.
yeah we knock in practice good alert last guy's above yeah
I'm going to close I'm thirsting them
hello are you okay all right now I'm gonna grab hemlock I
think we're good to go all right now I'm gonna get the to
clean seriously oh res oh never mind i'm not getting it i
guess res here they're redeploying though third i'm
putting the second one all right oh they they went dealer
side i'm gonna try to get this guy that's meant to have been
before it closes i should yeah i should get the red bin the
two people open it does it go fat no it doesn't it's not my
wish i wish It's not like Fortnite.
Oh, I got the gold.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, no one got the paper?
Nope.
Wait, I just realized I have no energy ammo.
Does anyone got bats?
There's a bat literally right there.
150 in the sky?
I hit one of them.
In here, in here, in here.
I don't think we can do anything because this team is...
I do.
I can throw it if you can break it.
Actually, I'm gonna breach it.
I have a breach.
Okay, yeah.
I'm gonna heal right now.
I'm gonna out them in there.
It's gonna go out.
Oh, I'm in that one.
I did back up.
Yeah.
I cracked them.
He's so low.
Oh, you were so low.
Well, uh, a pair would give me en route up here.
Yeah, yeah.
again i need a shield cell guys that could be flash up by
the way all right yeah yeah hit him for 120 twice this guy
oh my god this guy is so annoying 150 on that guy stop not
letting me peek 150 on the bulk holy they have to run out of
beds by now right yeah i hope so oh we're in zone we're in
zone i need i've got no syringes left i have none i've
syringes i've syringes here you no no no we can go we can go
yeah yeah ahead
half one last one nice you gotta answer us that seems when i
push yeah i'm trying to and see yeah swap in here start
there's no energy at all come on okay but i have deeply my
butt okay i'm i'm swapping the alternator to go back to our
spot yeah wait is that
there's no ammo here either yeah i'm on alternator right now
i'm gonna chill on the rock here i think give me give me
sign like we said i'm solo we can kill this kid right here
okay yeah it's alone at.
Who are they shooting at then?
Okay.
Nice.
I'm covering for you guys.
I'm covering.
Nice.
They're not gonna slide.
Do you want to kill me?
Yeah, duo.
And then there's a...
Oh, wait.
They're redeployed.
Wait, wait.
The other team is...
The other team is also duo.
Wait, actually, no, no, no, no, no.
He's... Never mind.
He's not.
They got cross.
Okay.
Wait, that's the Newcastle from this from this team.
We should call out Newcastle on the right.
Yeah, I have the med kit Yeah, you know, I'm not there yet
He's running on me 70 80 purple
Nice Where are they?
I'm rising, I'm rising, I'm rising.
Yeah, you're good.
I don't have it.
I don't have another shield thing for you Very good.
I've over filmed it.
Yeah, we should swing the elephant without dying.
I'm ulting?
You coming, it's okay.
Dash.
One more?
There's a...
I'm getting armor swaps.
Yeah.
Nice.
One more.
Trying to get the rock here.
Oh.
I'm near me.
Yeah.
The fight.
Well, last of the team's fighting is a solo versus a duo
team.
I don't know where they are.
Holy shit.
But I got him.
Flash!
That's where we want to hide.
Just on one.
On me!
Solo!
Flash!
I killed one team.
Nice!
Oh, nice.
Good job.
Yeah.
Let's go!
The last guy was just hiding, and I looked it up.
Back to back!
I think I missed him in 12 for trouble.
Yeah, you hit every Krabry shot.
What the f- I was so surprised they still had meds.
He just kept metting.
I think Doki had like 10 resins on me, though.
Oh, yeah, that's true, yeah.
Look at that.
Easy.
Nice walk, okay, bro.
So easy.
That was a fun game.
I haven't had that fun of the game in a while.
Yeah, that was a nice one, yeah.
Yeah, that was nice.
These guys were actual plat players.
It was nice.
Whoa, it's too late.
It'll always be a mystery.
We'll never know.
It could have been 4K, 5Ks.
I didn't even know how much damage I did.
To be fair.
I was not paying attention.
Look at that.
Damn, Ducky.
Why did you guys...
ever leave because hackers right ducky yeah i'm mk i'm sadly
a plug i play on let me see i actually don't remember it's
been so long since i looked at it i play on 800 dpi 1.5 okay
yeah no we're cooked my other team the other teams have
actual pred players we're pretty we're good but at least we
might not be as cooked though not be as cooked now that I'm
I am at least trying to play my part yeah and it's
quarantine parade too so we might be a little cooked but
look at least I'm putting in the work guys I'm putting in
the work to at least not be too cooked you see I see the
girl that got banned uh They got, not bad, got suspended on
Twitch because she used her, was it Dark Souls?
She used her feet as a green screen.
I can't believe that's where they drew the line.
That's funny.
Not the BDSM shit.
It's, so there's this girl.
There's this lady.
If you guys didn't see the other clip where she had like a
pet, like an actual pet, like a guy who dressed up as a BDSM
pet guy that just sat like in full like BDSM attire in the
court.
corner um it's called gimp suit yeah that's what it's called
and she didn't get suspended for that because that's like
apparently that follows the tos uh but then later to i think
like yesterday she got banned um yes not bad she got
suspended yesterday because she painted her feet green on
stream and then used as a green screen to play dark souls i
can't believe you muted discord
yeah yeah but that's where they draw the line oh suki i got
this new charizard bro psa 10.
oh wow how much did it cost it was i think almost 1700.
what the it's the 151 charge i'm not sure if you know what
i'm doing i see i see So me attack when you come out.
Is that your most expensive?
Is that your most expensive card?
No, I got the felt hat Pikachu.
How much is that?
That's a comp soon.
That's crazy.
Yeah, that's a nice card.
Thank you for gifting a tier one.
So thank you.
The felt hat one.
It's going for the last server.
gross around this map sold for sold for what 80k 80k how
much did you spend on it i bought it when it was seven i
think seven k yeah oh my god are you ever gonna sell that or
no no 80k oh jesus i'm gonna sell that cover my kids for the
college oh yeah that's true that's true that's a good
investment i like that wait when did you buy the card for it
to be 7k it was uh 23 i think it came out oh what the i got
one of the first ones how did that that's crazy that jumped
that high and to like what in like four years three years
sorry i can't do math four what four years no i was right
wait i definitely can't do four years four years i was like
wait no i was right i doubted myself oh let's go around this
map i'm sorry gonna this map Okay, never mind.
This nap sucks.
I guess it's good for comp, I guess, because there's a lot
of places to play around.
Like, so boring in pubs.
Oh, yeah.
100%.
I want to run him longer.
I know, yeah, that's crazy.
80k in four years.
Like, times 10, like, that's crazy.
Yeah.
uh uh i need a hemlock you guys also found another one
see yeah i'm gonna scan and see if there's anyone around
this something that is i gotta give free dirt oh they're all
in quarantine yeah yeah i'll grab the med kit let's hope
this is in quarantine i think i still mean i still need a
little hemmy if anyone finds a little hemmy yeah i'll let
you know
see we're going quarantine you said yeah there was like 13
13 players in quarantine i need some heals though first from
the spin what do you need i have four bats and need more
heals yeah i'll open it yeah
I'm good to go.
We just need armor, honestly.
Can we grab this?
This is a diva on my way for this.
Oh yeah.
I mean, nope, it's alternator.
All right.
We got a light mag if you find.
I need an extended light mag.
Okay.
Yeah.
All right.
Fucking drop.
I think we're good.
You can kick.
Yeah, I'm good.
I have four.
Oh, okay.
I've been for now.
I'm good too.
I'm going with...
I'm going with Argyr.
Yeah.
Pressing on me?
He's running.
He's running off to me.
All right.
It's fun.
I'm just thirsty.
I'm nursing a teammate.
Here we go.
There's a mate.
The other team is pushing.
All right, I'm coming over.
Wait, they're coming to me.
They're coming to me.
I'm going to RG.
I'm with you guys.
Nice.
I tracked Loba.
Alright.
There should be two down guys too in here, I'm pretty sure.
No, I thirsted him already.
I didn't want them to crawl away.
Oh, it's the Loba.
Yeah.
Right here, close.
Right here.
Oh, they needed us.
Oh, I got... Oh my god.
I'm fine.
I'm okay.
In the middle.
You're good, you're good.
Yeah, they made me into an armor swap.
I'm grabbing the hemlock.
Yeah.
They're right here.
I'll kill them.
They took TP for...
All right.
They took all for TP.
Nice.
Oh, I hear them.
Yeah, this is two teams because the other team is shooting
someone else.
Unless he was trying to shoot me.
I don't know.
I heard...
I don't know who he was shooting at.
You want to go look at the level?
Yeah.
But you can scan here.
Let's see.
Oh!
There's one solo.
Wait, that solo is coming back.
Yeah.
I see him.
He's right here.
Yeah, he is.
Wait, I think it's from his teammates coming.
His teammates are coming.
I see it.
Yeah, he's not solo.
Right here.
This one's here.
Oh my god.
Got you?
I got you?
Oh, I think it's you.
Oh, me, me, me, me, me!
I got hit, I got hit, I got hit!
Oh, he slid in.
He wants a- I got a hero.
Yeah, yeah, leave.
Oh, he slid in.
Yeah, go, go.
Oh my god, it happened so fast, dude.
It's so fast-paced now.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's why I was saying, like, she's such a must-pick.
I literally couldn't even, like, I couldn't even hit the ult
in time.
I couldn't shoot.
If I shot that on the ult, I'll live, but I couldn't shoot
it in time.
That sucks.
If I shot the ult in time, I would have lived.
Alright, let's see if he gets the Rizzo.
or they're gonna they're gonna have to they're definitely
gonna ape us right yeah yeah i'm a scout you see them suki
another fighting actually oh nice you know better not be
lying dash it's the same guy in the kill feed okay nice all
right haven't even remembered it good neighbor yeah go back
for me still a flow case you can go you go first
oh shit okay i'm going backwards oh it's a full team that's
a good thing i'm not there i'm not there i'm not there okay
i'm coming over i'm coming over now keeping them uh i i'm
not putting them yeah You can't get the res or no.
No, never mind.
Oh yeah, I think you can.
There's a TP.
You can also get it.
Rising the resin.
They're rising too.
They're yeah.
Oh, that's good.
I knocked him.
I'm rising.
Yeah, yeah.
You can definitely rise.
Yeah, see me.
I got the thirst too.
They pulled the other kid though.
Yeah.
I'm dropping like 10 bats.
Thank you.
My res beacon as well.
both do though i'm batting should i i'll she'll sell close
to me somewhere here 100 100 actually oh okay careful mate
hey knock on nice i gave you shields i went this way he's
over here i believe you guys i'm gonna loot yeah i'm dead
Oh, okay.
No, yeah, see, I believe...
See, I believe...
I...
That kid 100 bangered me, damn.
You might also have been controller.
Well, that's not I died for three.
I believed in you.
I did not chase after him.
I went straight for the loot.
See, I trust my teammates, guys.
I trust them so much.
I believe in them.
That's called teamwork.
I go over there, I guess.
All right.
Kind of a slow game this one for me, guys.
Sorry, I think Archie's doing everything for us.
I have, like, I might have 300 damage, maybe.
Oh, it's gone.
Oh, I'm not being behind.
What?
Oh, shit, I'm really behind.
Got you?
There we go.
Is he on the roof, Sticky?
There's a guy.
There's a guy there.
Flash.
Yeah, yeah.
We cracked him.
Good.
I need a shield cell here.
My need is at zero damage.
Oh, they're out of me.
He's out.
He's looking at me right now.
He's on the roof looking at me.
He dropped.
I sucked.
I had him for 40 flesh.
I'm going to need a badge, Sticky.
The altars have 40 flesh on the ground.
Yeah.
Not bad.
Your shield right now.
Fine.
I'm just fine.
Someone's talking to Femeski here.
That's the altar, probably.
Probably, yeah.
He's in the corner here.
Go to him.
Your shield, so?
Is he literally going in?
Look at this guy.
I gotta grab.
I grab the three.
Oh, never mind.
I need to go.
Wait, there's a res.
I have no bullets.
There's a res right behind us.
I'm gonna scout.
I'll catch up.
You guys go.
I see the ammo.
Alright.
She got him first, so she was, yeah, properly.
Oh, what the fuck?
There is two teams down there.
Yeah.
I'm gonna go for that if you want.
Yeah, that's it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, come here, guys.
I love all of them.
Alright.
We're here.
Go over to you, can't we?
Yeah, we can.
I didn't hear any kills though.
Yeah, they're still fighting.
I'm sitting right here.
I'm landing on top of this building.
Oh, fuck.
I fucked up my bit.
I'll kill them behind.
I'm going to get one.
I took.
That guy's 50 flesh.
I'm coming over it.
On me, on me, Octon.
Good.
One more.
Got that guy.
140.
Nice.
How do you shield?
Nice, nice, nice.
The other team is like...
top here we need to go around now we're gonna get stuck by
so yeah i think i think they left honestly yeah we should go
now hold on that way
oh i missed it i i love this new legend yeah you so she's
just so fast yeah
zooming yeah the one i'm still disordered when i when i
shoot with her Yeah, yeah, you're sliding you gotta do a
drive-by Drive-by shot
Team up here, I think oh, oh, oh, oh, oh yeah, oh, yeah,
yeah, ramparts and all I think we have to go the other road
and go see where Okay, I'm moving now I'm okay oh i missed
it so sad when you miss it the rock backwards they even in
play too they took auto tp again yeah yeah i saw an alter tp
over there i'm looking for this team here policies aren't
they dog oh they're yeah shot of it wait i can breach it oh
they breached it too okay never mind it didn't work
oh they're trying to breach too
they're running yeah i saw them right there I'm on the
right.
I'm going the right.
One is two in the corner.
They're looking at me right now.
Yeah you better.
I have the back of a little bit.
They needed me.
I'm coming over now.
Dead one.
You got a backup for a sec.
I'm telling him.
Yeah, you're the one.
Dead two.
All right.
Squish it.
Nice.
Watch out.
Octane came out.
Oh, new team, new team.
New team.
typing on there there's there's back here there's back here
that's a type of team yeah yeah yeah
all right I'm always feeling a roof by the way is he heals I
think I even know probably probably there's a team behind
this ballistic team behind us yeah oh oh they have two
creepers they have two creepers yeah I don't really want to
peek that they're just breaching us They can shoot for the
crash.
They have to come to us.
Yeah, they have to.
Oh, Charles, Audrey.
Yeah.
This is all I can do for you.
They're pushing now.
They're walking over.
Yeah.
Oh, they're good.
He's looking, trying to look for a sniper.
He's got me.
He's one.
I got one.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm back.
I have to back out.
I'm batting.
I'm medicating.
Yeah.
I'm going to try to push this.
I'm like one right now.
I out of them.
It's a good off, really good off.
Did they res or no?
No, they're about to, they're about to.
He's funny.
He's for me.
Am I?
Yeah.
Flash.
He's one, he's one!
Oh my god.
I quoted.
I had to reload.
Another team.
another team, another team, another team.
They're pushing, they're pushing.
I got the RG.
Yeah, I'm just dead.
Okay.
Yeah Yeah, we got a second.
Oh, yeah, we got a second.
That's fine It's unlucky.
I have to reload.
We did third Wow, don't kill that thing.
Oh Unlucky That's lovely.
I have to reload Oh, yeah, same Look, you know, I can't
count guys, you know, I have trouble counting That team that
just started us, I killed that altar three times that game.
So annoying.
Yeah, it is annoying.
That's so broken, too.
I killed and thirsted him three times.
That's the thing, guys.
I think another thing why I don't play as much is that it
feels too baby sometimes.
You know?
It's like dying in the game doesn't mean you're dead
anymore.
Like, you get to, like, be bad.
Like, it's so easy to revive.
No, it's so easy.
I'm feeling bad right now, dude.
Okay.
I'm bored.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
I need a different character to play.
You have her?
Oh, no.
Yeah, I've got a little less account here.
I think that's the one thing.
My biggest issue is that I use all I don't think I did, but,
uh, but it's just, it feels like it's so easy to just.
be born again born again you can res on a death box you can
farm res on the crafters like it it's like you're always and
then the altar if you get knocked you use altar all and then
you're born again and then and i remember when altar first
came out there was a cooldown with altar but now you can
like use it so many times yeah that's one of the reasons why
i haven't been playing as much too
because dead should stay dead triple yeah triple support and
the effects
and it's true i'm in plat like i'm playing plat lobbies at
the moment but it's just a little like a little circus show
right now
this is a little circus literally we killed that guy three
times and kept being born again and now he's and then he his
team is now like top two They're top two because they're
born again
Jump master here wherever we land head for first.
You do my strategy
All right, let's go
All right, if I get jump master usually means death so
that's all right.
We've accepted it Yeah, there's a lot of teams here, I think
yeah, there's a lot of teams.
I'm landing on the bins Yeah, I'll take the building.
Alright, I have an army.
Nice.
Shame.
Drop him a master too.
There's a wingman here.
I'll take that wingman.
I'll try to steal yours.
I grab this.
I'm ready to go.
Lucky, let's go.
Up here on me.
Oh, they're stupid.
Oh, nice.
I don't know where his teammates.
Oh, I knocked him.
On us.
Hold him.
Knocked him.
There's no.
Yeah, it was his teammates.
It was his teammates.
Oh!
Hey, new team, new team, new team.
I'm in the octane.
I'm in octane.
Five.
Dead.
Nice, nice, nice.
Armour slop.
Anyone needs it?
I need a sniper anymore.
I got, I shot him where he's dead.
All right.
Yeah, they're in there.
I'm gonna push this team.
They're eating it.
I'm not going.
Back the guy here.
Or is he?
Octane.
Oh, I see him!
I see him!
He's over here!
Back, back guy.
Flash.
Half missile.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
That's the guy on you.
I think that.
Almost that's it.
He's flesh.
Got him.
Nice shot.
Behind you, you team.
Behind you, team.
Okay, look at your care.
It's okay.
I'm ready though.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm backing up.
Backing up fully then.
Yeah, yeah.
They're chasing me.
I might be dead.
Chasing me as well.
Yeah, I'm down.
Trying to get us.
You got me.
How many teams were there?
What the fuck?
Oh my god, there's another team.
There's another team.
Yeah.
No, there is.
There's a fifth and a sixth team.
Yeah, now it's over.
Holy shit Yeah, like I said if I get jump master it just
means death.
It just never stopped it was actually endless third parties
the whole lobby was yeah The whole fucking lobby was there
That's insane.
I did not expect that I was like that's that's the last guy,
right?
That's the last guy.
Oh, nope.
No, oh, that's the last no.
Oh, okay.
All right, we're the last guy if you really want to play
something else bro i'll go axel i believe in your axel suki
i believe in it thank you it's not bad it's not good see my
chap believes in me too oh nice yeah yeah thanks chef yeah
thanks for the encouragement he doesn't know guys he doesn't
know i'm lying but we don't say that
I don't have a courier sleep yeah see you guys look we all
believe in him guys all right I open on oh wait the
anniversary let's open that they said that they're working
on bringing the turbocharger back to the habit oh I saw that
that sounds so broken though what does that even mean though
just means we're getting turbocharger back even move it in
the first place i guess it's just because like it was so
broken i mean because it was just like it was just a better
r9 wasn't it that is true yeah if you had turbo yeah yeah
you have turbo it's literally just a better r9 on a me and
my comp team we like it without the turbo there it had turbo
i went away one afternoon oh it's like when they deleted it
was when they deleted what's his name one's trying to play
but was it ballistic or fuse It was Fuse.
It was like when they deleted Fuse randomly.
That's what they did with Turbo Charger.
He just got deleted.
There's no Turbo Charger.
What do you mean?
That was never a thing in Apex.
Turbo Charger never existed.
Alright, here we go.
We can do this.
I think I can make Diamond.
I'm pretty sure.
We're literally speed running.
I was like gold yesterday like gold gold too I'm fucking
speed running get me to diamond and I'll call it a day
oh yeah I'll never know why they deleted fuse for half the
early axis that's so that's so funny it's the moment I
actually got the worst part is like it was the moment I
actually was first picked too that was the worst part I was
like, oh, yay, I'm first pick.
I can finally play Fuse.
We deleted him.
Get to D2 so you can get to...
Oh.
Hello, look.
We are...
I'm streaming, I'm streaming, I'm streaming.
I'm streaming.
Yeah.
You can panic.
Okay.
All right.
We're good.
Everything's fine.
You can tell you was fucking freaking out because you could
see him fumbling on the phone or something.
Yeah.
Yeah, I heard that.
She was fucking clicking shit.
Yeah.
I'm gonna go here guys on me ping.
Okay, I'm going with you.
Oh dear.
Is there people there?
Oh, yeah.
Okay, I'm backing up, backing up, backing up, backing up.
Oh, I'm dead as fuck here.
No, I'm...
I've got double car.
Yeah, I need up.
What the fuck?
I clicked axle on me.
One of them was AFK.
One of them is AFK.
Word.
I clicked on that.
I'm sandwiched.
Keep up.
I'm coming over here.
This one.
Oh.
Nice, nice.
I'm coming over to help you.
i'm so up to where is he i've got no cube to get to you dude
wait it's the last guy on you no it's a full team on me okay
okay oh boy i'm dead i'm trying under this too i cracked him
i cracked him i cracked the other guy what would you say uh
i actually should also be low i got i got one i need a
reload i need a reload I need a thirst, nice.
Oh my god.
Hello.
Goodbye.
Okay.
So you can heal up.
All right.
Thank you for the raid.
Peach, thank you, thank you.
I've had a great stream.
Hello everybody.
My name is Toki Brood.
I am playing Apex right now because I have a tournament.
I'm gonna put that.
All right.
all right here we go we're good to go uh i don't know i have
lots of syringes here oh we both have a lot of syringes we
just another team of mid yeah fully healed up first yeah
they didn't they're scared i'm probably wrong yeah i was
gonna say why didn't they third us We're already inside the
next ring.
Good strategy.
We got an arsenal here, dude.
All right.
I need the mid-range weapon.
I need, yeah, me too.
I mean, this isn't looted, so I think we're fine.
There's a box here.
Yeah, no, I killed that.
No, I killed him.
That guy was like, that guy gave up.
Because he didn't land on the light thing in time.
He landed next to me and then dropped his thing.
So how am I okay?
Well, I'll take that.
Yeah.
I need a site and I'm good for whatever.
There's definitely teams in Eternal.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I dropped a... I dropped Purple Light Mag.
Do you want it?
I have one of them.
Alright.
There's solo here.
Oh, there is, yeah.
He might be rising.
He won't be a solo soon.
Yeah, sure.
And I'm heading over there.
Oh my god, I forgot how to slide after playing Axel.
for so long holy shit yeah yeah i i forgot that you guys
roll swap so i was just like oh he's on here oh wait he is
oh he's not yet he's above he is here he's above me he's
here he's scared i'm going up now oh i cracked him splash
he's flashed he's he's running he's sipping my home he's
sipping back up no he is not he's running wait he's not
alone he's not alone here's his teammates yeah is he yeah
number four hundred and thirty four and sad and sad yeah
where's your teammate buddy Why is he just there?
Oh, right here.
That's gardens, I think.
Oh, two.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Two teams, two teams.
Two teams.
There's conduits in the open.
That's something that's good.
Flash, flash.
Nice.
Knock one more.
Last one on height.
Draw them for them.
I'm bad.
I'm going to grab armor swap.
New team, new team, new team, careful, so please.
I have another armor swap on me down here.
Yeah, I'm almost at that.
People on me, I think, yeah, people on me.
Where are you?
Okay.
On height.
Alright.
I attacked one.
Axel on me, Axel dead.
I'm gonna need a climb up.
I'm healing right now.
On me?
Oh, wait, I got shot from my side.
Over here, to my right, to my right!
Yeah, yeah.
Last one.
He won it.
Yeah.
You don't want that.
You have aim assist.
Nice to keep.
Yeah.
Where's Delphi dishes?
I'm here.
I believe.
Your aim assist got it.
I thought that was actually unlucky then.
Oh, it's good.
All right.
You can grab that.
Is that Bangler, by the way?
No audio until Doki said on behind on your right.
How dare they?
I did not see him, yeah.
Okay.
Interesting.
Let's see.
Finally a scope.
Oh my god
Homie.
Oh, no, I'm dead.
No, I'm not gonna cover.
I'm covering.
I'm ulting this
Careful there's I'm coming with you.
I'm coming with you.
I'm chasing.
Holy shit.
Okay.
I'm coming over.
I'm here Where's his teammate?
Oh, Suki, I think he puts a wrong upgrade, by the way.
I did, I did, my bot.
Wait, wait, he might...
Oh, no, actually.
Where did this teammate come from?
You gotta swap to the Shionine.
That's a good idea.
Yeah.
Coming over?
Pick up the pace.
Let's go for burn.
Replicator As a reminder This is a non-spoken flight Yay
Are they good?
We do go here Yeah, we can't Should be able to Nobody near
us Does anyone need bats?
I have five Second of all good I believe, well Alright We're
heavy ammo There's What the hell is this team Wait, what the
fuck?
They might have res, maybe?
Yeah, possibly, yeah.
It must have been like, you know, we killed like three
different solos.
There's like two teams in quarantine.
And then there's a team here and then a team here and a team
here.
There's teams around us.
I can't even use a double jump because I'm on Valk.
What did you say, Audrey?
Actually, I can't even use double jump because I'm on Valk.
Yeah.
Because of his thrusters.
They'll just keep flying.
I see them.
They're all the way over there.
Way in the distance.
Okay.
Down here.
I don't want to see him.
I'm going for this guy.
Alright.
I don't see him.
I got that gun on the roof.
Are they inside?
I think I'm in.
Oh, they're resing too.
Everybody's just resing.
Right here.
Oh, to my left.
Yeah.
yeah yeah yeah to my left too I can hear him climbing yeah
down the door yeah this is 40 right here right close I might
be dead I'm backing up I don't know where I'm getting shot
at that's another team that's another team I'm backing up
fully I'm backing up to on us on us I need to play in there.
I need to play in here.
Oh my, I'm alting this there's another elite portal.
Yeah.
We have everywhere.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can we swim this one?
Yeah, I'm with you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Almost got one.
Then watch and watch them.
Careful.
Oh my god, I hit your back.
I'm going to go on this side.
I'm going to go to the other side.
I just cracked to him at my knees.
Where did they go?
On me.
Got 100.
through the window.
I'm running in the fuck out of him.
There is a Watson in the corner.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's a duo now.
It's a duo.
Let's run this.
On me, on me.
Right on me.
Right there.
Oh my god.
There's the Watson symbol.
Yeah, yeah.
He's running to you.
I got him.
Nice.
There's a new team on me.
A full new team on me.
There's a...
Oh, this guy's pro too.
Wait, this is a- wait, that's him!
It's the same guy.
It's the same guy, yeah.
That's where he went.
That's where his teammate went.
I put the fuck out of him.
There's a team here.
I don't know what they're doing.
Oh, nice.
I need an energy ammo.
Yeah, there's a team inside.
It's a team inside.
All right.
I'm just full Elem.
You wanna swing them all?
I can swing.
Oh, is this weird thing that's playing like, fucking like oh
yeah i see him i see him right here their armor swapping on
me come upstairs nice one more one more here the teammates
over there i'm gonna move you left left left left left left
oh what the he went left i heard him he's inside he's
running he's running full up
I see him.
He's back here.
I'm coming along with you.
Where did he go?
Where?
I'm lazy as fuck.
I'm just about fucking.
Hold on.
Yeah.
See where he is.
He's over here.
That's a duo.
I'm going for the guy on the right.
I'm going for the guy on the left.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm now.
Okay.
He's out.
He's out again on the right.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
he's out coming out nice there was a team there was a team
like inside here underneath yeah there was yeah yeah i saw
the scan yeah i need that i'm done just pink people are ape
whatever what the oh my god that that door was blocked of a
box i hear them you're close close oh my god
a rampart there rampart my rx store i need to heal i need
you all the way wait they're shooting me through this i'm
dead they shot me through i didn't realize there was a hole
down there i thought the guy behind this yeah i'm putting my
shit up i'm putting my shit up yeah Nothing to sell on him,
syringe.
I'm down here with them still.
I'm on hide, I'm on hide.
Yeah.
Nice, one last...
Can you help?
We're coming, coming, coming.
It's two, it's two, it's two.
It's two.
It's two, it's two.
Wait, was that two teams then?
Rafe.
We'll check see...
They're rising, they're rising.
He's one HP.
Fuck me.
Jason, yeah.
Oh, I didn't realize there was like a tiny little cubbyhole
back there.
Look at the weight's HP, bro.
Yeah, I'm like, God.
Oh, he was actually one one.
Yeah, I hit him for $1.99.
Oh, my God.
Bro, it was like a little, like, like, you can shoot the
legs or some shit.
I thought it was safe.
I thought it was against the wall.
Well, that was bullshit.
He shot my feet.
Behind me.
They fucking shot my feet!
That was bullshit!
I don't believe it!
I was like, I'm so safe!
I'm against this wall!
I'm against this wall and there's nothing behind me!
My feet was exposed!
I was like, nothing to worry about!
I'm protected!
That was bullshit.
Now I know.
Now I fucking know.
They changed this map a lot, too.
Alright.
I'm ready.
I'm ready again.
Oh.
I think I can get to.
You know, we can get another win, I believe.
I'm locked in.
I'm so locked in now.
I'm ready.
there's so many like little cubbyholes and everything i was
just not expecting it
but i haven't played this map in so long
i haven't played in so long i don't know i'll like i always
avoid this map because i hate this map during pubs because i
don't i rarely ever play rank
i actively avoid this map so just to see like what the fuck
is all of this around me what is this what is this bullshit
okay these guys seem like real plat players
all right all right all right g it's time to jump not me oh
dear all right cynthia it's time to jump i'm feeling some
action big old quarantine i think okay let's go yeah all
right all
right it's time for action
only two teams what the hell only two teams only two teams
in quarantine what the are they one team landed for energy i
don't know what i mean i'm gonna go look at this yeah yeah
just getting this fault and then i'm coming bro okay i'm
heading over now almost Yeah.
I have a P20 and a...
What the fuck is this Eva 8?
A faulty flash.
Good.
All right.
I'm gonna take the zip then.
Where is he?
In here.
I'm literally dropping in on them.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Not here?
No.
What?
I literally dropped it.
They made them throw it in now.
Yeah.
They're running.
Oh, they're running running.
They're scared.
Oh, wait!
Flash, flash, flash.
Yeah.
That's got a hundred bangers.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Kill him for now.
Is that in the other thing?
coming over where I'm looking we push that the team's gonna
be right behind me full-time yeah yeah yeah I'll come back
I'll swim in I'll swim in I'll swim 90 oh boy loving rangers
they're pushing me they're pushing me now nice nice nice
nice nice yeah he's cute he queued out he queued out I'm
pushing up me You splashed, you splashed.
Come on, Audrey.
Oh, low, low, low.
Okay, okay, I'm coming over here.
That's us.
Yeah.
I'm trying to dip.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm dipping, okay.
Yeah, it's two teams.
Two teams.
This one.
Yeah.
Can we go observation?
No.
We just go underpass, though.
All right.
You can go underpass to your left.
Just underpass and you...
Oh, yeah, I see you too.
Yeah.
I've got no view, yeah.
You want to go.
want bat I have bats yes please yeah the last bet okay I'm
never putting the 2x in the long run again is this thing
okay it's all the way over there I'm trying to see if it's
looted or not I don't see the bins open so we're good and
then the bins are open you didn't craft an algorithm yeah
put a night okay down speed
Oh Now wait I'm resing Yeah, don't lose to the actual you
can lose all of our G2 Yeah, nobody lagged here Okay, I got
a reno finally.
Let me know if I need a re or in hemlock Okay I'll look out
hemlock nice ammo Grab it I'm dropping ammo on it.
I have ammo.
Okay, I have ammo.
Okay I'm fine.
You didn't keep your ammo.
Oh my god, I fucking grabbed the...
I grabbed the...
the Mozam next to it.
I need to get an officer.
I need an RIE.
Getting the hemlock from the shim.
I'm gonna upgrade.
I'll drop two grenades here, I can't carry.
Fire grenade here.
No, there's a backpack here.
You're only as good as your gear.
And skill.
Oh, I just need an RE.
Yeah.
Why do you guys want to go?
There's one team in quarantine.
They're still in quarantine?
I thought they were going to push us, we didn't want them.
Extended energy mag here.
Nope.
Thank you.
Oh, he sat there it is.
That's what I've been looking for.
Oh, that's cool.
I didn't know the range goes that high.
Yeah.
There's a lot of Axel things here.
There's a lot of people running away.
It should be in front of us.
the boxes are true yeah yeah i've enhanced my weapon don't
hear anything yet they're in by hazmat tunnel i think
probably what do you
okay oh to our left you guys heard it yeah yeah check that
way all right
anyone oh yeah they're fighting in the choke no they're not
fighting this is a whole oh no never mind they're chasing a
solo yeah i mean if they're chasing a solo we can meet them
there right i mean yeah we could yeah left one behind so
yeah i'm like just sitting there yeah they're Is he okay?
Call you, Audrey.
We went the other way, Audrey.
I'm going to go for this because he's up through the boat.
Nope, they're all back.
Wait, there are audio?
They're back on me?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, are they?
Okay.
I guess they gave up chasing the solo.
Yeah, solo res as well.
Alright.
Oh, the solo res here.
We're coming back.
Okay, they ran back the other way.
Cool.
They're coming back!
Okay, alright, let's go back.
All right, they went to kill the solo.
They killed to kill the res
All right Oh, they're here.
They're here.
They're on his arms.
He's running, right?
No Another team on top of my head.
We're trying to we want to take TP another team behind me
There is.
Okay.
I don't know.
Oh, you there's them or no?
I don't think I can though.
All right, you want I'm going to take the altar.
I'm taking the I'm taking it Wait, I took it.
Bye.
Is it safe?
I'll check.
Yep, it's safe.
Yeah, take TP, take TP.
I thought we were taking it.
I'm dead, I think.
Oh.
You can take it when you're knocked.
I think it's good.
I think I'm good.
Yeah, you can come over.
I'm back.
Yeah, I'm coming back.
I'm coming back.
Nice.
Where's the other team?
RG?
I heard steps right here when I was pushing down to you
guys.
Two teams down there, by the way.
Oh, okay.
I don't even know what's happening anymore.
Oh, you can't take it when you're knocked anymore?
Unlucky.
I didn't realize they changed that.
Okay, they were this team back off them now.
Oh, what the fuck is going on?
Me too.
I'm so confused.
I'm so fucking confused.
You know what?
I'm gonna go right here for some of the guns.
Oh.
Yeah.
Are explosions to our left?
I'm not gonna look at it.
It's top five already?
What the hell?
Yeah.
Everyone's just like running away.
And we're in...
We're in zone four, nine zone.
I thought the purple thing was our zone.
down speed up good shots right here like you said yeah i
heard it it was like explosion maybe they ran i'm still in
that way i see them i'll meet i'll meet right here yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch the replay watch the one watching dead
trying to read the play right now
move me right here i'm fine
mommy he's one he's free that's that's
I just have to run.
I don't have enough heals for this.
Good.
There's two mercants right there.
Yeah.
I'm met hitting now.
I was worried of getting shot out while I run.
Oh, there's a team in front.
There's a team in front that could be ulted.
Oh, I popped up.
I didn't heal.
I'm dead.
Yeah.
I need it.
Let me give me a sec.
I'm dead.
Is he coming to me?
So come on.
I'm medicating or I'll die in zone.
Come on, come on, come on.
Okay.
I think you're dead again.
You have to heal him.
I think he's running, he's running.
I knocked him.
Knock somebody.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm with Siaqin.
I'm with Sia.
wait on me a move yeah I couldn't grab it all right I have
the heal I have to heal then yeah I don't know if I can I
don't have med kits anymore yeah I have syringes though I'm
gonna see if I can get this res off of you gotta get out of
here you haven't even oh my god how do I res this okay i'm
rising i've never done this part before yeah do i have it uh
yeah poppy yeah pop that pop that popped it yeah we gotta
fly towards that man i don't know what it's that way i'm
kidding again both bye oh my god i'm not they're over here
that's not good i'm just gonna fight these guys with them
you're gonna be fighting by yourself i'm not doing it well
no Can I please Q?
No?
They shot me.
I'm so... Yeah, I'm just good.
Yeah, it's up to you.
DQ is up to you.
I'm dead.
I'm not turning.
No!
We got camped out.
I'm talking about...
It's okay.
Nobody got points for it though.
At least.
Yeah, nobody got points.
That's the little things.
Oh my god, these guys can...
cringe they camped us out thinking cringe so my chat was
like that's what he gets for not playing meta just wanted to
have fun guys
oh my god so cringe they like they like camped us for so
long too
God damn It did not care Like fuck these two In particular
Yeah all three minutes The captain for three minutes That's
oh my god Our Our fucking KP is not that important It's not
that It's not that serious bro
Not even It was just two kills Not even a squad
It's alright It's alright
it's okay this game this game will be a win i believe i
believe i
think it's just um yeah like it's just a mixed bag like
people are actually plat and people who are like just speed
running out of plat we just want to climb down because you
don't want to like bump into all the pro players
these this is why i stack i don't solo queue in apex i don't
mind solo queue in other games but apex is like it's because
it's like you know it's more condensed too there's just like
three of us also falonka oh my god didn't see it but thank
you so much for the raid i'm sorry i didn't see your raid
earlier i whenever i play apex i like super lock in
apparently it was a bug oh wait no not bug sorry no now they
confirmed it yeah i saw the solo queue i was like that's
exciting that's exciting too because if you're like in the
high yellow solo queuing then it's like not not as like not
as like bad i feel like if everyone else is also solo
queuing when i'm playing eight um actually it's like five in
the morning uh but i have to practice for a tournament gully
is anyone landing with us i guess not put those people here
is there I didn't see anyone all right nice I had my hemlock
already nice I've
got your team in cliffside though all right yeah yeah don't
worry about ring fry we're in the next ring
as the creator tournament it's on my schedule i'm on max
team with shifty cod pro and i'm technically they put me as
the the pred content creator so speed running remember we
have to play this game
where are you are you backing to us yeah okay side now we'll
see if there's anyone there sound here there anybody oh
doesn't look like things are loose yeah I'll grab the
there's a people in call alright I'm enhancing my weapons
enhanced take the upgrade where you can put an idle gate
down speed out
the last time I was print season 2 and 3
Look at that, everybody in quarantine.
And then I stopped playing the game.
Why didn't I stop?
I just farm pubs.
Where'd we go now?
Where'd we go?
I farm pubs and I just played math.
Like, I just go get to masters and I'm, and I was like, I'm
good for the day.
But basically, I was supposed to be the gold player.
And they confirmed it.
They're like, it's good.
Like, I was like, I asked Mac if I could join his team.
And then I was originally confirmed as the gold player.
And then they were like, they made the rules stricter the
next day after they were like, yeah, she's good to go.
And I was like, all right, cool.
And then the next day, they were like, sorry, we're going to
tighten the rules up.
So the gold player has to have never peaked Masters at all.
And obviously, I peaked Masters because I fucking peaked
Fred.
but like anyway i told mac i'm fine with back just dropping
and so you could get an actual print he's like oh why don't
you be our how about you'll be our content creator he's
looting oh i cracked him there's a bangalore up top yeah i
cracked that guy up top
there's a guy up here too I'm gonna go up.
I'm going up.
Is it one guy or two?
One.
Yeah, it's two, right?
Or one?
He left.
He fully left.
He ran this way.
Um...
Basically...
So basically...
Oh, sorry.
So basically what happened?
Yeah, basically ran that way.
My god, he's far.
What the hell?
Yeah, he's fucking far, far.
But basically what happened was that, like, they were like,
so that everyone, every team.
So the thing is, so the thing is, is that everyone, all
teams are struggling right now, trying to find an actual
gold player.
I just got the fucking bitch.
Because obviously, you know, everybody's, everybody has hit
higher than gold.
Like a lot, almost like all streamers.
like that because it's not that hard we're like streamers
who play apex you know or just like or like who have played
fps games before yeah so it's very hard to find someone
that's like an gold player um and so uh what is it so but
now they made it so that they made it a little lenient more
lenient to the fact that like it's like masters You just
have you just need a fine player that has never peaked
masters before as the third anyway I told Mac I was just
like bro.
It's cool.
I can you I you don't need like I I'm cool I don't need to
be on the team because like obviously he'll be at a huge
disadvantage with me being categorized as the Content
creator category because all the other content creators are
Actually current preds He's like no, it's cool.
Let's just run it.
Let's just fucking let's just see how it goes and I was like
yet he was like hey we're all the people out so he was like
no it's cool we'll just run it i like it's it's all right i
was like all right you're sure about that um that's a lot of
teams i sent two people something's gonna work one doesn't
no I'm needing it.
I need the thought off.
Me too.
I have a breach.
Oh shit, there's another team down there.
I'm batting.
He's on me.
I'm in.
Yeah, dog.
He ran for me.
I'm gonna try and use your thing.
I'm gonna rush.
Did I tell you to die?
Air strike.
Reloading.
He's flying gold.
coming over yeah yeah he keep pushed back right here right
here right here nice i'm gonna go here oh oh never mind he
on the roof on the roof on the roof on the roof oh that's
you that's you never mind i was like who i thought that was
the enemy guy that sniped this oh he gave you up you know
what oh that's another team down there i'm gonna try and
crawl Closer.
Oh, he's coming.
He's coming.
He's right here.
Right here, right here.
I'm going to keep crawling.
He's pulled back.
He pulled back.
I'm still crawling.
I would tell you if they're coming for you.
Okay.
He's going back.
They're just healing.
I'm batting.
I'm trying to crawl to you guys with the luck and for me.
Yeah, the luck.
They've got me, I think.
I'm here.
We're here.
I don't have an angle right now.
Yeah, one's climbing up one.
Oh, I don't see it.
Wait, where is he?
Oh, he's below.
I'm going to ult this.
I hear them crawling over.
They're coming to my left?
Yeah, I'm biting them quick.
Yeah.
I already ulted so.
I'm in here Watson dead Nice I'm pushing up We're supporting
out Oh, I Okay, nice Alright We're knocked We want to take
care now We can raise them I'm going to raise them actually
Hey, I'm raising I'm raising You cover Yeah, I'm covering
Thank you That's you That's you
the champion fell what we called me divo was in gold oh they
must have talked uh unlucky there's bats which is bangles a
whole different team what the yeah the bangler was one guy
that for some reason decided grief us yeah this guy should
go here i've walked here all right
So that's why I'm trying to speedrun Apex again.
Besides, I haven't played Apex like for a while.
I mean, I have, but it's just like, you know, one or two
games, like two to three games, like every couple of months
or so just to be like, because I play a lot of different
games now.
So I just jump between games.
Like I can still aim, but obviously I don't know what the
fuck is the meta or like.
Damn, that's a great team would be over here.
I play like a lot.
I do like third.
It's hard to swap between third person and first person
games too.
Like if I feel like if I hard grind this game again, like
obviously I could be at that level again.
But I don't have that time.
I don't have that time no more.
I hear something else out too.
Yeah.
Yeah, positioning and stuff too.
I see you think I got a guy oh my god I had one no rank but
he's cracked though they did the support yeah yeah yeah
you need to chop him like careful he's one he's one flesh
flesh flesh I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead to this yeah another
squad and oh my god what wait who shot me oh here up here oh
i'm done oh my i got a shot we just shot by like three
different teams what the bro this random Watson behind me
just takes port and kills me oh my god can I go back on Axel
thank you Jesus yeah that guy sniped oh Suki once on X yeah
that guy like sniped us from the zone like we're freaking
freak oh yeah i'm thankful for i'm think oh yeah sorry i
forgot to mute but i'm thankful for uh for mac for still
wanting me on his team even though i was just like bro we're
not bro i was just like bro we're you bro we're not winning
this that's true i was like good mac we're not winning this
all right we're not winning this bro I made a joke being
like you know what he's through some of my tournaments I'm
gonna Mimi on his team will be thrown you know what I
deserve to throw his tournaments he's I remember this is my
chance now and I for an I exactly I still try it's just my
presence there is to throw but
I was like that anime girl battle royale.
I forgot what the name for it.
What was the name?
The anime girl battle royale.
And then he he invited he invited like the rank one, two and
three like players into the tournament.
And because like, he was like, oh, they're my buddies.
And he invited them.
And then we and then somehow we kept accident landing into
that team over and over again.
And we were like, Mac, you did this.
You.
You invited them.
No, it wasn't Trinova.
I forgot what the other...
It was another Anime Girl Battle Royale.
Trinova was a tactical shooter.
So it's my turn.
Oh, it was Fate Trigger.
Yeah, Fate Trigger.
Alright, let's go.
Yep.
Nope.
why i'd use afk oh no he's not he's here he's here yeah but
now it's my turn now we fight okay okay
we should be the only team doing this i hope well let's see
in the hole yeah
Nope, let's slash this.
I hear people behind.
Oh, there's a wingman.
They're fighting outside.
I might go for this instead.
I'm going to put RG right now.
I know.
Yeah.
I see a guy right here.
I ping.
I want one more.
Hello.
Oh my god, I'm lagging so hard there.
What the fuck?
I hear someone to my right, to my right, yeah.
Flash and collect on you.
Flash, player two, flash.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
I don't have to read what the mag here, though, if you
think.
Yeah, grab it.
Yeah.
I'm going to the ass, I want to grab one, sir.
Oh, my God.
I don't know if you guys saw it, but I couldn't hit the
fucking Eva H.
I was lagged.
It was, like, so slow for some reason.
i think it was the lag full team 200 pinging oh oh i'm going
over she got cute though 100 back 100 nice i'm going in the
number yeah yeah right now too let me raise right there
where are they where's his teammates wait another squad new
team new team word yeah what does that have to go inside
inside Yeah, ammo they were coming from here and coming from
here.
I see an that they're trying to...
The crossing?
Trying to get him up, trying to get him up behind you.
Oh, he got me.
He got me.
Oh, I couldn't.
Oh my god.
I was not expecting.
They're coming up.
They took two.
Yeah, it's two.
It's all three, it's all three.
You might believe you have to me leave.
Literally the moment instead of trying to kidnap, I turn
around.
I got kidnapped.
I was like, oh.
Goodbye, I guess.
I guess.
You got Riz is here.
You're fucking crazy.
I'm white, but I'm white still, so.
I think they're going to be on blue soon, though.
Yeah, probably.
Yeah, yeah.
Or it knocked us too.
That's what you mean.
Couldn't even have respawn in time.
Are you pushing?
I can see them.
I can see anyone.
Unless I can grab some attachments and heals.
Yeah, I'm getting Audrey.
No, I don't hear anything.
Probably still looting.
Yeah, probably.
I'm gonna grab the hemlock from the enhancer I don't know
what they're doing.
There's not much to lose I'm gonna it beacon Oh, they're
just sitting on Yeah, they're like They're going that way
Coming over Yeah I'm not with you guys Oh, they?
Yeah, they're on the outside Yeah I'm here Yeah.
And one's inside.
One's on the backside.
Hunter here on the outside.
Hunter dead.
Two left.
I'm taking it.
I thirsted him, I thirsted him, he can't risk, he can't
risk.
The point he's queuing.
Wait, the fact that my door.
I'm waiting on my door.
I'm waiting on the portal, I'm waiting on the portal.
Reloading.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, fuck these guys.
This bang does not want to die.
The 301 is still golden.
I don't think that's like enough damage, though.
Doesn't it?
Compared to the other guns.
Yeah.
He's on a...
Just getting another jam up.
right yeah or
we fly yeah all right government over oh
i got so far there wow whoa i think they're fighting in core
me too that'd be wrong nice let's go yeah yeah is that two
teams yeah that is we come back okay all right He'll be
there by the time we get there anyway.
He's so fast.
I'll land this on the house next.
Yeah, he's so fucking fast.
I'm going to move to the solo kill outside first.
There's like right, there's a guy right here.
Two guys over there.
Wait, there's two people on the roof.
There's two people on the roof.
Yeah, I'll move.
I'll move finally.
I don't.
I'm sliding on them.
Coming up.
There's, he's running, he's running, he's full run.
Why did he jump to?
All the way over there.
It's so far.
Okay.
I don't even know if we can get it.
No one's inside?
Nope.
I don't think so.
I think it was...
Wait.
No, no, no, there it is!
What the fuck?
It's on me.
Come back, come back.
Do not stop.
Use this nitro cage.
See inside?
Yeah, he's...
He's like, what?
Like, what are you doing?
Selfie.
Yeah.
Oh, I forgot that punnies from this year.
The guy made his own little house there.
Why is he still here?
He's not even... Yeah, he's... That guy wasn't even a
rampart.
It's the fucking... I know.
I knew it.
Should be looking right here.
Where is this guy?
Should be trying to res, weren't he?
I can epic, yeah, if you want.
Yeah.
I don't think I'll go.
Yeah, 12%.
I just saw him jump this way.
I don't know where to go.
Oh, yeah.
We'll find him now.
What?
Oh, he went that way.
Oh my god, he's so far.
How about moving there?
He's gone, gun.
Alright, don't worry.
We'll be right behind you.
Just so I can scan him, you know?
That's true.
I think he's fully gone by the time you... I don't think
you'll scan him anymore.
I think he's gone.
Oh!
He's still inside.
Yeah, I see him.
I literally saw him.
I literally saw him there.
Yeah.
He?
Yeah, he evac too.
Yeah.
Well, we have our fault and we'll probably get just then
Oh my god, he's just running like a little bitch
He backs right here is what I'm seeing it's all just res res
res res res Yeah, I can catch it Nice Nice How about all on
it?
Nice We'll be toasted by the ring if we don't move Nobody
here?
Yeah Whoa, whoa, okay, hey, there's a full team.
There's a full...
Okay, I went the wrong way.
So there's a full team here, by the way.
Oh, I went the wrong way.
We need to go to the...
Yeah, I went the wrong way.
I thought I missed...
I'm dead.
I misunderstood the plan.
I've...
Instructions were a little unclear.
So I'm dead.
What's coming?
It's okay.
It's all right.
You guys can res me.
I- Yeah, yeah.
I thought you guys were going a different way.
That's- there was a- there's three teams.
And then there's another team in front of them.
I have to kill this guy real quick.
No, there's- Kill this, kill this, kill this.
Actually, I have three.
I have three.
Just kill one of them?
in front of you guys though that's gatekeeping oh my
goodness that's up i'm at your shun dude i need to heal up
me i'm shooting dicks right now oh my goodness he's one hp
enough one that was that was awkward i
it's okay it's okay nice damage we they didn't see that guys
we didn't see that we didn't When you first asked me what am
I shooting, I completely fucking looked.
I saw your CPI.
I saw it.
I told you guys.
I told you guys there was a team camping.
I told you.
Yeah, I don't know why they're sitting there.
Imagine if I can grab Banner when I'm down.
Wait, can you actually do that?
No, I can't.
I can't.
Unlucky.
That's why I fought it and then the third just showed up out
of nowhere.
So that's me being stupid.
That's my bad.
I was not following the plan.
I thought the plan was to go that way.
And I was like, all right, see you guys.
Honestly, it would have been fine.
but then me and Suki are two teams in one of us.
Yeah, and then there was another team also.
Wait, where did Suki go?
I got code leaf.
Oh, yeah.
I'm Bakno.
Wait, I don't want to invite us.
I'm not lobby leader.
I want to be lobby leader.
I'm invited you guys.
All right.
There's just three teams.
Imagine if you could grab the banner when you're down that'd
be so broken yeah he just res the guy while knocked that'd
be crazy that they should add that just add another res
feature fuck it everyone can res
oh i'm pretty sure all right we get okay how many points 730
i think it's like one and a half win
as she wasn't supposed to be live but then but then we
played we started playing apex
just apex things guys oh my god it's remember six hours i
didn't even notice that i don't have too many games i need
to play too many games
i knew it was never gonna be one game guys i knew the thing
is my sleep schedule is just so which is pretty bad oh yeah
let me sign this thing real quick i need a sign contract
right now wherever it is where the oh here it is click and
sign all
right that's all right everything has been checked already I
just needed to Just needed to sign it It got fully approved
There we go Yay
Alright contract signed Alright guys we got core Perpetual
cord even Alright I believe I believe in this win Hmm We're
landing up here right It is.
Yeah, yeah.
Uh, one team contest on that thing.
I'm just going to your ping.
Yeah, I'm going to be ping it.
Yeah, me too.
They're contesting us, though.
I'm going to lose here.
Because they're going to lose right.
Not in here.
Where are they going?
Oh, they're all on you.
On me?
Yeah.
Of course they're talking, by the way.
Okay.
I have a gun.
I'm trying to click one off.
I'm getting shot on the back.
I mean, what the fuck?
You closed the door on me.
Oh my god, how the fuck do you aim with a P20?
Got one.
Got one inside.
Yeah, I'm still gonna go.
Flesh?
One.
I'm gonna shot.
I'm gonna triple take.
Yeah.
I'm dead.
Aw.
I'm backing up.
then i was i have not shot with p20 in so long i have
there's a crafter in front of me i'm gonna go there bird
yeah yeah i'll just wait did i'll come right away actually
didn't call to you go all right yeah we could all be let's
just stay where you were yeah stay here yeah we'll call to
you yeah it might take like five years but we're getting
there yeah i'm worried we have five years to wait yeah
crawling come on come on come on oh shit oh shit oh it's
a second on that dude that's good okay we've made a around a
little too much just a little bit just a little bit oh my
god that was another
i'm surrounded right now there's a team right here is there
do you think there's gonna be people on your boxes oh they
were saying they were sitting there like i don't know
there's death to be committed i think that's the ash
footsteps okay
okay oh my god i have a new team that's on me that's on me
no that's aнул team oh yeah that is a new team yeah that's a
full new team okay no if i waited if i waited i could have
waited for that team to roll in yeah oh my uh they were
waiting too sorry it's just a little octane just triple
taking me for my entire life i know i got yeah i got hit too
i mean they died for it at least yeah at least All right.
Here we go.
All right.
This is the win.
This time we won't have 20 people landing on us.
I believe.
I don't know.
I actually don't like the map rotation this way.
Same.
What's the map rotation?
Broken Moon, KC.
Olympus.
Oh.
Hmm.
I guess with KC it's gonna be like super it's like basically
super chaotic and stuff Yeah, KC.
I don't mind.
I just don't like the back-to-back KC Olympus about like
their bodies.
Yeah, it's true I wish it doing like storm point or
something that would have been fun
All right, let's do this
We're locked in now for real oh yes
no all right let's go rare lifeline main spots within the
ship
so we have one we have two teams all right i'm landing
wherever wherever you I'm going down here.
I got turned, I turned, I turned.
Okay, I'm turning too.
I'm turning.
There's a solo guy landing in that building in front of us.
Solo here.
Oh, he's on the bin.
He's on the triple bin.
I don't even have a 30x on him though.
Are you coming over right now?
He's low.
He's low as fuck.
There's D though.
He's 1H3 up top.
1H3 up top.
I did so.
I'll take the zip.
I feel like he's rad though.
I'm pretty sure.
His alternator.
Let's check.
Yeah, he's gone.
Oh wait, he's...
Yeah, I can't chase that.
There's another team here anyway.
That landed...
Yeah, there's a team inside.
There is a Devo in the right house if you want it.
It's in this house.
There's a full team here.
Yeah.
I'm heading over.
This is just a duo, no?
That's a trio.
No, it's not.
Oh, no.
I had him on.
He's out of the fight.
Yeah.
I'm in the roof.
Yeah, I'm new.
I see him.
He's inside, right here.
Nades.
What should he need, though?
Oh my god, he sniped me.
Snipe.
Snip sentinel to our left.
left.
So I'm the guy to your left.
I fell out.
Yep.
I got hit.
I got hit from it.
Nice.
I need that armor swap.
On me.
Oh, nice.
There's the fads.
The fads gone, I think.
Yeah, yeah.
No, it's on me.
Oh, there's one.
Oh, I whiff.
I only have one.
Oh, there's one as well as fuck right here.
Nice.
Did I saw a shot?
Okay.
I thought it was someone else.
Clifstar, still fine.
Yeah.
I need heals.
I'm gonna heal right now.
What do you need?
I have a lot of different types.
Yeah.
Energy?
Thank you, Doki.
See what this guy has.
Yikes.
All right.
On to facade.
I'm slowly hearing.
There's only two teams here.
They're still fighting this way.
Maybe they like res 20 times.
Should be in here then.
All right.
You know, that's not it.
Oh, no.
We ain't fucking Vantage screwed on.
120 Vantage?
He jumped off.
She jumped off.
Yeah.
That's a charge rifle, by the way.
Uh, 140 on target off the hill.
He's like 20.
Yeah, I don't have long range, so.
I don't have long range.
He's still peeking.
He's still peeking close up here.
Oh, wait.
What did the bandits go?
I don't know.
I usually went back up.
We're on a peaceful.
Yeah.
I only have close range, so I can't do much.
Good.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I need to get out.
Yeah.
I think you're gone, I don't see them.
Yeah, they're gone.
They're fighting here.
I'm gonna ask, man.
All right.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I'm grabbing the hemlock here.
Oh, you already grabbed one.
We'll wait for the hemlock to reach in.
Got it.
Fighting on me.
I'm coming over now.
I'm also coming at him.
Oh, that's it.
oh nice
Should we get chased yeah yeah yeah rampart oh rampart no
more damage on someone for still someone's trapped I got the
I got the aim I got the conduit Come oh my god, it's labbed
against the wall
Nice New team new team backing up backing up I can alt this
too
for you thank you i jump down i need to um i need to heal
flash yeah here's a there's a armor swap there thanks
there's another team below us i hear shots but i don't know
where they are i don't think this team is pushing no they're
not no they're still here they're still here they're Not?
Nice, talkie, nice.
I'm glad I'm putting up a video.
Lowe's not dead, is it?
That's what I mean.
Almost got.
I don't know where he is.
Oh, nice.
He's almost got again.
Nice.
I couldn't see anything.
Yeah, I couldn't see anything with the Watson fences.
Yeah.
I was like, where is he?
I have 48 light ammo, bro.
I can't really help you.
Very good.
Recharging shields.
I'm gonna take the time lock.
Oh, yeah, grab it.
There was a team.
I heard shots below us.
I don't know they're still there.
Behind me, behind me, behind me, behind me.
Okay, yeah, yeah, they are.
There was a shot.
I heard sniper too on that side.
I should keep backing him up.
I'm looking over here.
Just keep backing up.
Yeah.
Blue armor?
I need them low.
Fuse low, fuse low.
Yeah.
I'm Oh Yeah Cracked one as well I cracked one They're rising
I can't see them They're fusing me What the first?
I can try and res Yeah, I'll cover and cover I think they're
gonna res too I'm probably dead here not gonna lie I can
give you shields Nice and nice nice I'm batting.
I got two almost.
I'm batting.
I'm covering.
Getting strong.
We're getting strong on my left.
Yeah.
It's just alone over here.
I think.
Yeah, they're looking at me.
Two of them were on me looking at me.
Yeah, one's on me now.
On the resin.
The resin.
On me.
Can't keep that.
So can't keep for you, go.
Knock one.
There's another guy out there.
I think that's a new is that a new team or no is it just you
me as a teammate sir It's last guy last guy last guy No, no,
no, no, no Did I tell you to die?
Oh, bro, my ammo situation is terrible Just what do you
need?
I'm good now.
I just need a light-eyed zero I just want to fire hemlock
fighting me die down.
That's not right
oh i just need like i need like an re everyone no one has an
re that's crazy the fuse had a re someone's talking with an
arena fight no none of them have it they're involved yeah
it's just about gonna have it wingman i dropped a gold mag
i'm walking there oh i'll take it yeah I need one energy
mode.
Do you just want a valve hold to set it for me?
Sure.
Yeah, mate.
There's 50.
Wait, let's go.
Oh, no.
I'd see the mag.
You can take this.
I'm ready.
There's a team coming out.
Do you want to fight them?
No.
Yeah.
I feel like we're gonna get, we're gonna get like pins.
Uh, can't tell.
Yeah, there's nothing.
There's nothing.
there's a team on the left no is that in the back at that
beacon over here yeah yeah yeah yeah if it's there we can go
fight them wait there's an energy in here okay yeah yeah i
was gonna say drop your ammo for it there's some ammo here
too i dropped light ammo thank you they come to ship to take
on the ship uh they just went into the bins oh my god
there's one guy this guy's late here he jumped off he jumped
off i did
got him nice
there's more energy does anyone energy yeah no i'm good i'm
fine all right there's this guy right here yeah i saw him
okay Yeah, I see him.
They're far, far.
My clock is two or two.
Over there, I don't know.
Where the fuck did this ref go?
There's a rest here, right?
By the way.
Oh yeah, we want to focus?
Flash on one of them?
Yeah.
Oh my god, he's literally one.
Holy shit, he's actually one.
I'm so sad.
Oh my god, he was one.
Yeah.
I got him.
I got the safe cut.
there's a team up here careful to ramp our walls yeah is it
yeah yeah where do you want to go i'm trying to take one of
these donuts yeah you're getting the diva yeah i'm going to
do that i guess nobody in plot runs the diva because they
want to go to the hemlock the hemlock re
I think someone raised up here, right?
Yeah, they did.
They raised her, right?
Yeah, they're fighting up there, I think.
They had shots.
There's a horizon right here.
Going the other way, though.
I don't see them.
I guess that team is playing the opposite of the zone, I
guess, so.
Is that a rampage?
Yeah, that is.
Rampage is this economy?
all right i'm looking behind us i feel like the team behind
us might do something stupid yeah i'm looking behind us for
us yeah i'll just look in front another res because you said
the horizon went backwards right yeah she did uh they have
to come out like they have to come out eventually they might
they might come out here maybe as well right there Oh.
Shatter.
Almost cracked.
This is a nice fight.
We should fight this.
His teammates are coming over too.
Their teammates are running over.
Go, sir.
They're all purple.
Where do we?
Hold on, Audrey.
You're by yourself.
I'm just ratting here.
There's two from there.
All right.
Someone's...
We're going back, I guess.
Okay.
I'm better.
I'll give you Q's, Joki.
There's another one.
Yeah, give me a save.
On the tree.
I think you get an cross angle.
I can get across here, actually.
Are you okay?
Yeah, that's just my way.
I'm just...
They're pushing, they're pushing, they're pushing.
I almost got one.
They're...
They're not pushing, they're not pushing.
You can respite me too.
They're not...
I'm meshing.
They're not pushing.
Okay, that's not what I wanted to do.
I'm gonna try and get to you.
i'm trying to see i'm fine i gave you i gave you shields
thank you i'm just stuck on a i don't know what they're
pushing now i'm gonna work here i'm i'm covering for you i'm
looking i'm looking for you oh no i'm not gonna push i guess
i'm with you too the fuse was running 20 watch out he he had
shot me i think where are they yeah they're going to the
right fight fight for fight
Let's hyphen them.
Yeah.
I hit 40 on the Valk.
I'm coming over to you.
Do I be careful of the other team?
I don't know where they are.
Valk is literally one.
They're up here.
One's in front of me.
I got one.
No, I lied.
They're both there.
I'm pushing this.
That's fine.
I breached it.
I hit them with breach.
They're already guys.
Fuck me.
But I don't know how to commit or I don't know.
We can commit this.
We can't even get up.
Yeah, I think we should back up Only you only use something
We're getting shot from behind we're gonna shop for buying.
We're gonna shop for buying.
We're gonna shop for buying There's really a team like on
the other house
Close behind Yeah, there's the house, but I'm checking I'll
come I'll look here Yeah, they're in this house right here I
don't see them.
It should be two duos.
It's 410, I think.
Yeah.
I don't see them right now.
It must be in the corner or something.
Oh, wait, wait.
They rotate.
They're rotating.
You're rotating.
All right, we're, we're, we're.
Oh, let's shop.
Yeah.
That's fine.
Oh, Suki, can you pop our back off real quick from middle?
Yeah, yeah.
There's another squad I shot me.
This team is a duo.
We're just gonna kill this team in front of us.
Is it a duo?
solo right here solo yeah i'm pushing the skin i'm giving
you shield excess shield i'm gonna cover you i knocked one
nice he's here bro he's tanking gas oh what okay he's one
150 nice okay all right i'll say i'm gonna stay in the house
i'm gonna stay here that team's gonna kill you better i'm
pretty sure this one someone has okay yeah yeah they did
yeah we're gonna move back towards that building yeah
they're they're running to that building right now okay
they're trying to run to there they're right here they're
right here yeah no no roof we just play a roof then we're in
zone fairly they're running there they're running to that
building now we're nearly there i'm batting this team needs
this team my sensors on the left though is anyone heavy i'm
just gonna freeze me up and i can't freeze everyone who yet
and thank you we'll be tested by the ring if we don't move
in front of me here i'm looking to our right where they're
going up to the house this is the next move look at this
team three kills here all right i'm just covering our backs
okay all right 55 on the bulk 95 on the bulk we're gonna
shot in their backs now They have to fight that.
Yeah, they fight that.
They fight that.
We can wait.
There's a solo right.
He's out positioned to our left.
Ah, he's one.
He's solo.
Yeah, three shots if you try to.
I broke that window.
Baton.
Oh, I'm out of ammo, actually.
Oh, there's something.
Nice, he's flush.
I'm going to try to get him.
Wait, there.
There's a guy right there.
There's a guy right there, by the way.
They're aping him.
That's the Kramer team.
I'm full healing them.
Yeah, you're to your left.
Guy, you're left.
Slow to your left.
Shut it out.
I'm OK.
He's one.
He's only slow, slow, slow, slow.
I'm going, I'm OK.
I'm OK.
I'm going to move.
Try it out.
Can we cut out?
Yeah.
Sit on.
Flash, flash, flash.
Nice.
Good.
Got you.
Oh, no.
I'm ready.
I'm coming to you guys Just push the switch to do him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah Yeah, yeah That's the creeper team.
That's the creeper team I have to reload.
Fuck, man Wait, is he?
I'm up here.
Go with him here Flash on one That one Nice one.
Last one.
Be handy.
Oh my god!
Flash, nice.
Okay.
Oh, I forgot I had to.
You fucking slid right in there.
Tim while reloading.
That's crazy.
I pulled up my armor and it's durable.
Okay, well ended.
A win's a win.
I was like, I was trying to armor swap you and I grabbed
your banner.
I was like, oh, I guess I'll die.
Luckily he didn't kill me.
I'm glad.
I'm glad I need one clip there.
Oh, another win.
yay yippee okay i need 459 how many kp i need i need for
that anyway i got seven is there a cap guys do they cap
kills kp's points oh fuck i just opened a pad i can't even
see what i got there they cap it or no i don't i don't know
they always reverse it it's always it goes back and forth so
i can't tell anymore what's the soft cap is it possible to
get 400 plus points
I just need to know if I kill 35 people okay so it's not
possible also Estigan thank you for the tier 1 sub thank you
thank you 35 Jesus I'll do scrims go by the way Audrey it oh
there's always next grim block yeah we got uh 11th in pro
league swims no no we got 14th in pro league swims oh
mike brager always head up with rasty dark on this one every
time i said look left he would look late
like i'm not even joking every time i said like team behind
us he would look in front of us that's weird that's weird
it's fine we got today hey wapik said to step up and do
better rg who me yeah that's a wapik said what else am i
supposed to drop a five kid yeah drop a fucking five kid
it's that easy you're on roller okay but wapric is a buddy
of ours chat so we all yeah it's our job band two it's all
band two
all right team contestant yeah but contesting way
hello oh i got him luck there's a guy inside that.
At least two inside.
Oh, I, I, I, I'm gonna handle the weapon right now.
Come to it one.
Behind you, behind you, behind you, weapon.
Oh no, I forgot.
I had Siki.
I got him.
You're coming right.
Okay.
On me.
I'm in.
Oh, I'm in.
Oh, cracked him, cracked him, cracked him.
I'm gonna put my shield up.
Nice, nice, nice.
I like to said whapping instead of Suki.
He was in our chat.
Oops, sorry.
I went to loot.
I went straight to looting.
Just because because we're both EU.
Yes.
I'm gonna enhance my gun.
Ultimate at PK, what could go wrong?
I believe.
There's an R9 here.
Yeah, I got an R9 with the 2x now.
I guess I had to go with this game actually.
Oh, there's a lot of shots up- is it top-top?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
you
on me tracking on the roof yeah someone's supposed to move
where the fuck oh wait wait he's running he's running flash
flash those down here down here down here down here down
here yeah yeah they're Oh, I'm in it.
One HP.
I'm shooting the...
I got one.
I got the other.
Nice.
I need a heal.
I'm not too easy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm out of rest, I'll rest, I'll rest.
You cover, you cover.
Oh, wait, wait!
There's all, there's all, there's all!
I got hit.
I have to...
Come back, Audrey.
Yeah.
I'm gonna have to...
I'm gonna have to pay you, but I was fine.
I wanna...
Oh, fuck.
I took you.
I metkitted.
Oh, right.
It's a new team.
I'm dead.
Yeah.
We have to leave.
I might be dead.
It's either one of us.
I got one.
So well.
Nice.
One more.
I found it, bro.
He's abing you now?
I talked to him, but leave.
Just leave.
It's fine.
Yeah, yeah.
It's just another full team.
Okay.
Arna with the two of us, not the five.
I hope they're not aping me oh it is quarantine though no I
don't even know I can get a resin quarantine do you want to
try quarantine I should want you want try here if you can
get it in quarantine without dying try it but if you can't
please all right only
ten teams up though so much could be easy
Alright.
It would be funny if I accidentally crafted a bat there.
I don't know, somebody told me.
I can raise you guys here right now.
Do you hear a gunshot just now?
There's gunshots in front of us.
Like, around this direction.
I think they're fighting another choke.
Do you want to go for it?
Yeah, I'm done.
Oh, they give me up there.
Very good.
One team, two.
Wait, we got redeployed behind us.
There's a redeployed behind us.
They're finding them here.
Yeah.
Kind of starting down on it.
Holy shit.
Can I tuck it over there?
That's one that you seen flash.
Behind us rock, behind us rock.
nice give me off give me off this pk please i heard i heard
gunshots above us i'll go over i'm gonna go for myself yeah
just need a bit of a bit of ammo what do you need energy
there's energy here there's a they've had a lot and i'm like
yeah i got some i think those two teams were trying kill us
when we res and they bumped into each other most likely i'm
going for it i'm going
in front of me
splash oh they're both so low one's knocked and the other
one's flesh
My left?
I'm gonna spot the wrench.
Oh no.
Yeah.
Oh.
I kicked it and hit him.
He's gone.
Wait, I've got it now.
No, I haven't got it right now.
Hey, it's pop, pop, pop.
He's gonna be right here.
Yeah.
Oh, that's another team redeploying to us.
Do you see above us?
I think that's a book.
Oh, it is?
I hope so.
Oh, yeah, it is, yeah.
He's...
He's so far.
He's far, yeah.
That's crazy.
I was like, what the fuck?
Are we going to say hi to these people?
I mean...
Oh, it's an accident, too.
Oh, that's just don't fucking come back anymore.
He's dead.
Nice.
Oh.
More.
More on me?
Whoa.
I need you here.
He'll be ripped.
They also got it.
They also shoot in the laggy.
Got it.
All right.
60 on one.
We all did.
I need to go inside.
I'm safe here.
Here, I gave you shields.
I'm covered.
They're walking up.
Back one.
Back, Kippy.
A-bubbed again.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, they're...
To my left!
I altered left side.
I'm healing up too.
I'm gonna walk up a little bit I'm gonna walk up too.
I don't think they're I think they backed up.
Yeah So it's gonna take height on us What the fuck?
Where do they go?
Oh, I we're the one that's yeah, you syringe, right?
Alright, unless you want it though, you want it?
No, I'm good.
I'm not favoring 200 ping Fuck that Oh It's here and here.
Oh, the other team is fighting.
Oh, can I raise you?
They got a pot now.
They're potting now.
I need to come back here then.
They're both they'll be like, they're both.
They're all near.
Okay, 185 though, okay.
What, what, what, what anything here?
What anything here?
Oh, me, I'm in me.
All right.
Flush!
Oh, he's so low.
Wait, is that new?
Same guy?
New team?
No, same guy.
Same team.
Another killed one.
Yeah.
Horizon did?
Yeah, I'm going in then.
What, high ground?
I'm batting?
I heard the mirage to my right.
Yeah, mirage on me.
He's ready?
Nice.
Behind us, Kraybert.
How many?
Here?
Die, bro.
Thank you.
All right.
Did you grab a Kraybert?
No.
No, I have to go for nothing.
Oh, I have to go for it.
Oh, we have to go this way anyways.
All right.
Yeah.
Wee.
There is that team in front of us.
earlier where are we going
hate that bug it fucked me up
is that a repeater yeah it is i've got alcohol by the way
all right
Oh, I still hit him.
Nice.
He's gross.
Come on, long walk in.
Okay.
I'm a good little angle.
Yeah.
Alright.
I'm gonna look to my left just in case.
Whoa.
What the fuck?
Look off.
Think that's a rampart team, you know?
The wrong height?
Yeah.
I'm gonna double check to make sure nobody's behind us.
yeah it's probably gonna be a team behind us no way they're
gonna go home let's quiz yeah I almost got one it's like no
nobody behind us
you go Audrey yeah one for day one if you knock one we can
the patty the patty just died to a different team oh shit
there's a team behind me now all right you need us come
Actually, we just have to go through anyways.
We can walk over there.
We don't need a balcony.
Let's grab some heavy.
150 Pathy.
Why are they...
They keep on fucking peeking and just standing still.
Man, the team is dying.
They're still looking at you, but all them's not team up
there.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
If I crack one here, we just gotta aim them.
Yeah.
Joe Nades.
Aping, Aping, Aping, yeah, yeah.
Oh, Axel, five, one.
Flash!
Pathy, Pathy, Pathy.
He's soloed, nice.
Pathy's dead.
Lifeline moving, Lifeline.
Lifeline 150.
Lifeline.
How long, Lifeline?
Opponent wiped out.
He jumped.
Yeah.
Sipping up.
Sipping up on me?
Yeah.
Oh, it was the Lifeline.
Lifeline.
We are here.
Oh, that's just a thing.
He's resting right now.
Just give me.
Oh, fuck.
He's over here.
Big rafters.
Nice sun splash.
Oh, I hit 69.
Nice.
I'm not hitting that.
One's behind the car.
He didn't go.
Good night.
Oh, I couldn't get that.
That's fine.
I think there's a team behind us.
It should be.
There's another way of finding somewhere.
I don't know where they are.
There's a...
Oh, that's...
Never mind, that was yours.
Yeah.
They're going to come out here, I think.
Yeah, that's...
Holy shit.
Okay, I'm fully snagged me.
I'm feeling I'm feeling sitting.
Where are they?
Yeah, on the bridge.
on hide already there's a team here to be or what a little
run yeah oh yeah we're yeah so confused so they're literally
each of them how was that not a headshot try to see where
the other team is where did the other team go no no one two
zero one two is on them already okay one guy in the back
yeah they're so split i don't know what they're doing we
have to go to give the fuck i got in the open there nice he
did i'm gonna try and stop the rest i'm gonna i'm seeing up
i'm seeing up here yeah just stay up yeah they're looking at
me
putting them they give me yeah you're gonna give me also be
careful i'm going back up yeah they already got those
they're like they're not going they might oh no someone's
feeling yeah Are you guys okay?
Yeah.
One took pause.
After that.
Nice.
Last team is in there.
I can breach it.
I'm breaching it.
I was on height.
I'm coming over.
There's a guy.
I got down from height.
We need to play left side.
Yeah.
That's the last team.
Oh, wait, somebody...
I can't see any of them.
He's over there...
He's over there.
I pinged somebody.
On over there.
They're already on the wall.
Lolo on Conway, Conway dead.
On me, left side, right side, right side on me.
Cracked him.
Oh no.
No, it's the lowest part.
I'm done.
I can't see anything.
Oh my God.
That's unlucky.
I see that.
my bro i told you holy my all hit all of them though i
didn't realize yeah hit all of them and then it was just too
many things on my screen i was just like wait where the is
everything
damn i need damn wapik You saw what Wapik said about you,
RG?
You don't let him say that?
I need 200 points.
That's facts.
I just need 200 points, and then I'm diamond.
And I'll call it there.
Nice.
Damn, if we would have fought, like, two more teams, I would
have had the 5k.
Damn.
We could have farmed that team, though.
We just, like...
Yeah, I didn't realize.
I was spanking the one.
We gotta find them.
We're almost there.
And then I take and I sleep and then I stream again.
The grind never stops.
Guys, the grind never stops.
I'm like nine hours.
That's like one nap.
That's like a nap.
Or not a nap.
Full sleep.
Sleep stream.
Oh.
all right this could be the game this might be the game guys
remember when it was like one game guys and I was like you
know what huh you know what I got a squad maybe it's more
than one game huh what if what if it was more than one game
i am ready i'm so ready
all right i'm ready
hey there we go how do you go master yeah yeah where are we
going i just need 200 points whoa try to form a drop all
right i'm locking in for last game oh where Really?
That's interesting.
Okay.
You know what?
I'm gonna go R9 today.
Last game?
I'm gonna go R9.
I don't... Oh wait, can I remember?
We are alone.
I got the landing glitch.
Where it sounds like 20 people are landing on us.
Yeah, I suppose.
Eh.
Sentinel here.
If anyone wants to do the Sentinel.
to know I just need my hemi oh a gold charge rifle I have a
2x if anyone wants one
um oh there is something i've enhanced my weapon maybe all
right
all right oh i'm gonna go grab the yeah actually no i'm on
the i'm gonna enhance my light ammo all right My heavy ammo
Set and beacon
Yeah, let's go to Atmo I feel like by time we're there the
fights will be over
Don't worry about ring fry.
We're in the next ring I'm not fucking leaving that shit.
I'm not taking the gold charge that shit can retire I don't
think I've seen anyone with a gold charge rifle in 80 years
or like move a charge rifle in general I
hear gunshots though maybe they're done or any oh no they're
still fighting what the fuck right it's still fighting yeah
they're above right oh wait no one died patty patty patty on
you patty does inside are up top oh they might be up top
there's another there's another patty here kills them fin
them let's see i can get on the roof i'm way up i'm oh is
that it yeah i think so i knocked i knocked a path like does
it get the yeah yeah that team yeah oh
they're heavy mag
oh nice i need that mitten beacon again
what nobody do people quarantine yeah you want to go there
that's crazy literally no one you can baffle toky if you
want yeah i'm with you i'm literally behind you all right
goodbye
traveling with small children this is a blood sport what's
wrong with you
do you have just anyone here no doesn't look like i mean
your scanner would have shown yeah you can hit the beacon
again i'm just gonna move forward while you hit the beacon i
have an evap too i have an evap too oh okay yeah yeah i'll
wait for that there's two teams yeah
and then we have another beacon to hit after if we win the
fight
Oh, and there's another one right here.
Oh they're resing in front of us.
Yeah.
I see them.
They're running over there.
I'm down high.
He's low.
Um, climbing up.
I got some.
Oh, I got, um, people in the middle.
In the middle?
New team?
Where?
You go in?
Where he go?
Oh he delivers.
Flesh?
There's a conduit up top.
There's a conduit here.
Oh what?
Oh shit there's a window..
Yeah okay.
Back there back there.
Good kill me.
Good.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm blocking door.
I'm blocking.
I'm trying to block it.
Give me knock.
Yeah, I'm not giving me knock.
It's 300.
I'll let you know if they're resing.
There's a rave.
There's a rave on me, RJ.
On me one, on me one.
No, pops.
He's one at three.
Oh, it's the ulted.
He ulted.
Where does he?
He's like, he went that way.
That's another two.
Yeah.
Rape, rape on you.
Rape on you.
I think you have to leave.
You have to get out of here.
You have to get out.
They ulted us.
Yeah, Susie's committing.
I'm good at the thing.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Wait till someone's out.
I'm blocking him from getting out.
Yeah.
He's down to a different team.
Just heal.
We gotta move.
Yeah, the other team is moving.
I'm gonna leave.
If only you can res me right now.
Oh.
Oh, that's unlucky.
I guess that was an LG.
Yeah, he got it.
He got walk done.
Yeah, that's not what I'm doing.
Gigi, you stole.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh, we need to get...
Getting that diamond?
I'm kidding.
Oh, she said that wasn't, though.
Yeah, yeah, that wasn't.
It was LG if I get...
I just believed in us so hard that we were going to...
I just believed in us.
I just didn't think we were going to get granite so fast
behind.
yeah same thing that was gonna happen yeah because i was
like standing on the side so it's like how did i get shot at
and then it was just his teammate was on the window every
time i swing a conduit i always forget that the regen
happens through shooting yeah the fucking random guy at the
window fucked me up all right now it's lg okay now i'm
locked in guys for real i'm locked in for real now it's
all right 221 points they're still guys okay so this is how
i know like they're they're they're handing out new uh
leader slots for the apex tournament literally like six
hours ago they're still trying to find teammates people are
still trying to find players for it
yeah uh the The tournament's like on Friday though, so
there's still plenty of time.
I mean, there's still plenty of time.
Honestly.
It's worse than that.
They haven't found, like, they haven't fully found, and,
like, they're still...
People are just so struggling to find the gold player.
Because it's hard.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god.
That guy was prepped.
Gosh, I'm so scared.
This is the exciting part.
I'm Trumpmistress.
Do as I say, and we will win.
Alright, this is it.
This is the game.
I believe.
Yeah, it's a team down here though.
Do your team's dangerous.
I'll grab it.
Mind if I take it?
No, you can have it, Suki.
I'm gonna grab...
No, okay.
I wanna do R9.
I'll grab it now.
Gold wingman?
Oh, I'll take that.
Nevermind.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm ready to fight.
Yeah, I'm good too.
More than...
I'm enhancing and now I'm heading over to you
don't hear any shots yeah don't hear
anything I guess there was alpha base though I heard shots
yeah yeah it's an all right i'm a little far i'll wait like
10 seconds behind okay there's a gun
knocked them nice we're just one was that teammate oh my
goodness oh my god oh my guys i just blew up i don't know
what happened okay i'm fucking backing out then i mean i can
literally just craft you guys right now yeah i'd have to a
default bang lower the 4k one um i'm just gonna craft him
i'm getting spawn finished yeah i don't think you're yeah
goodbye oh what is what he was getting finished crash my
game what i was about my game my game just Oh, no.
Okay, I'm resing you, but do you want me to wait?
Yeah, yeah, I'll be.
No, no, I'll be back in like two seconds.
All right, you're back by the grab Suki now.
I don't know how long he was going to spam finish you for
it.
Yeah, no, that's fine.
I'm holding back in.
Yeah.
Oh, what do I need to craft you?
Yeah, you can craft him.
Oh, wait.
All right, so is it.
So keep showing up as a bloodhound on my screen.
What the hell?
That's funny.
I'm just covering right now.
Damn, bro, I have so much loot.
I mean, they're still there, so.
They're fighting still.
I'm coming here now.
They're hard fighting.
Actually, they're poking, they're poking, they're poking.
I'm waiting.
There's a default voxel as well who hit me all the
headshots.
Oh.
They're not hard pushing it.
Wait, I'm just waiting.
They are.
Are you sliding?
I think they are now.
Yeah, one's run.
Yeah, they're running in.
They're running in.
Yeah, one is dead on me.
One dies inside.
Oh, roof, roof, roof, roof, roof, roof.
Beyond you, behind you, behind you, behind you.
Wait, I caught one.
I'm not kidding.
Another squad, another squad.
New team, new team, new team.
No, no, no, no.
One.
Ten.
Oh, there's a team.
Three new teams.
Oh, my God.
Team here.
Oh, yeah.
I see that.
Yeah, yeah.
It's okay to stay roof, stay roof.
There's three new teams.
That's so unlucky.
You can find an axe or something?
I'll keep going, keep going.
Just slide, slide, slide.
Slide this way.
I think they're shaming, bro.
Yeah, they did.
They did.
Just run.
Slide if you can.
Yeah, they did.
I don't think.
You're good.
Go, go, go, go.
Slide, go, go.
I hope he's coming out.
What the fuck is the other new team?
Do they?
Oh my God.
They fought a different team.
They ran back.
They ran back those bitches.
find someone else are you serious oh my god i thought we
just needed one more game i can't believe we got through it
it's so hard so fast yeah oh my a course they ran away
because it's because it's never one game guys it's never one
game who would have thought it's one game.
I thought it'd be one game.
I was like, guys, alright, let's get that win and then in
and out, guys.
Just in and out.
Okay, this actually is last game.
We don't get it here.
I'm fucking, I'm calling it.
I'll get it another time.
I'm calling it here.
We don't get it here.
I'm gonna disassociate real quick.
I didn't say I'd be playing this line.
Oh.
All right.
I believe.
I believe in us.
Yeah.
I'm a bit disassociated.
It's hitting me now.
Now it's hitting me.
I might have...
May or may not have streamed a little too long.
I'd have a long weekend.
today was just supposed to be a i do i do my sponsors and
then i clocked out but might be a little longer than that oh
i'm missing summer game fest and state of uh five game of
state of play and summer game fest is next and the xbox
showcase they're all next week
I'm so sad.
I just saw on Twitter.
They're all next week and I'll be gone.
What the fuck do they know?
They knew.
They fucking knew.
You knew how it's going to be gone.
I want to fucking stream that.
I want to stream that we watch a lot.
Yeah.
Apparently they're all going to be next week.
Say to play Summer Game Fest and Xbox.
There's a lot of things here.
Alright.
Where are you going, Audrey?
Yeah.
i'm letting in the box it's so much in with us yeah i'm the
energy arsenal one guy i got a gun i got a gun i don't think
you got a gun right here bang inside on my door holy you're
lagging died in the back they're all lagging for me i
haven't packed a lot one just inside about from inside about
i got one nice one more one's for I
have three ammo.
I have three ammo.
Oh, this sucks.
Are you serious?
Fight each other!
I only had an alternate.
I had an alternator with one mat.
I can't believe... I had packet loss.
Insane packet loss there.
Yeah.
yeah hit my one bullet though so it's okay oh my god guys
all right this is the game okay okay all right all right
this is the game is this not the game this is gonna be lg no
matter what it is not this is not the game i might need more
than 200 now i it's okay we're just gonna win all right guys
this time this time this is the game this time this is the
game believe
yay oh
introducing your champion
oh we got a diamond lobby okay oh shit okay i was that all
right let's go all right well even even the game was like
even the game was like this this is the end yeah i was not
ready for that
all right we gotta try try do you want to re45 i'm grabbing
the r9
i'm mad for somebody
i need him yeah i'll take it Are you going to Spiceport now,
RJ or?
Yeah, yeah, they're going to be looking over if they look
over we're just dead.
Yeah, yeah, come on now.
On my way.
Many of you.
They're not looking, yeah they are, I think they scans, they
scans.
Yeah, they are, they are looking.
Ciao, long boat.
And they have snipers.
Lovely.
Wait for them to walk up or jump again on the roof?
They walk up after my breath, but...
They close.
Should I have one?
Patsy's low.
Catch us.
They cracked on one?
Cracked two?
I'm walking up them.
Yeah, I'm walking up to it.
Laying it.
They're jumping away.
They're still there, they're still there.
I'm taking the zip.
Okay, guys.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I need to make this.
I'm pushing up.
Oh, I cracked another one.
I cracked one too.
Yeah.
This is bad for us.
Nice.
Okay.
You're up.
I'm going one of those.
Come on.
Got two.
Let's like it.
Let's go.
Nice.
Oh, these guys were also flat.
That's not good.
I'll go raise yeah good swings all around good swings all
right
hamlocks and stuff up here nice I'll grab that I'm locking
this box over here all right
champ dead I'm gonna scan I'm gonna scan in case production
yeah they're coming one second I'm very close to quarantine.
Yeah, the closest is core.
I'm gonna go enhance.
Yeah, we're- Yeah.
I better pick an upgrade.
You know, I'm gonna keep up with the old timers.
Now my weapons enhance.
Just like me.
Alright.
So far.
wait
All right, what's fighting?
Are they where?
One guy's close.
I'm really far from you guys Yeah, you know, maybe I'm here.
I'm here.
You guys can go.
I'm literally right behind you guys Yeah
You're right here aren't they closest fuck to
Yeah, here.
I'm like, I'm fucked here.
I'm just fucked here.
Cracked him.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm batting.
I'm batting too.
I cracked the axle as well, by the way.
They went that way.
Oh,
my God.
Oh, I got the wrong guy.
Just my bed.
Oh, there you go.
Or Evac and...
Remember we call him off this?
Yeah, maybe.
He's taking it.
Axel.
I didn't get him.
I think it's just him.
Can't see with this one.
The damn sun, bro.
Yeah.
Where did the...
I need a light map.
I'm going with these boxes.
I need sniping ammo.
I'm gonna loot guys, actually.
Alright, I think we're all looting.
Yeah.
Stupid sunnerf.
There's light ammo here.
Sniper ammo I need.
I might swap to this nemesis actually.
Yeah, I'm gonna do that.
Yeah.
I'll go with the 3x.
Yeah, I streamed eight hours.
Yeah.
Um, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where is LG?
It's LG.
I don't need that.
There's sniper ammo here.
I hear shots.
Where's that?
On you, Audrey?
I'm good, yeah.
I'm above you, above you, above you.
What?
I'm talking to you, man.
I'm trying to...
I cracked one?
Are you?
I think I'm pretty scared.
Yeah.
I almost cracked the other.
What's that guy?
I'm batting.
So, uh, surrender.
What's so rare?
Surrender to?
Yeah.
I caught one and almost cracked the other.
I didn't even see them picking anything.
I think they're gone.
There was a res right this way.
There was a res back there, yeah.
Yeah.
I'm a little worried they'll push us.
Yeah, we can back out.
You're back out?
Yeah, yeah.
Go back towards...
where you want to go is that a duo oh this one it's a duo
wait wait there's a team here we gotta finish fast keep
going forward let's go forward walk on these kids I'm right
that Axel came on the way I've swept the fuck out of 15
flash 15 flash
I got hit by I got hit by that.
Oh, well.
Last shot, last shot.
Pushing out.
I need to fully up.
Also need team behind.
And that was the team.
He's coming forward.
Pushing out.
He's over here.
He's coming forward.
He axled out.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know where he went.
He's going towards production, man.
Is this team coming behind us or is it going to go the other
way?
short if we were sparrows here not sure i don't see them at
all i don't know i there
they didn't chase this oh wait there's two teams now yeah
but yeah there's a team right here come on there's a team
right here yeah on the roof now i see them i see them you
see me
i cracked one 30 plus one yeah
Wait, wait, wait.
The team rotated to us.
Yeah.
Yeah, they're on this bridge.
They're right here.
Good.
Yeah, run team here.
There's two teams behind us.
Two teams behind us right now.
Yeah, yeah, I see them.
Yeah, they were shooting a team to our left.
Oh, fuck.
I'm just looking at him for a record.
I'm just vantage.
I've got it now.
Advantage.
Yeah, someone.
There's a vantage.
Come this way, record.
Yeah.
Come here.
Gotta be going around this way.
George production yard.
There's another res.
Oh, that's, that's the team we killed.
Oh my god.
Team there, two left.
Who's going to move?
He's alone.
He's not, he's not, is he?
I just got two people.
I thought his teammates were inside.
Yeah.
Wait,
there's another team redeploying to us.
I'm looking to our left.
That team is pushing slowly, by the way.
The other team's pushing as well.
Valkyla, Valkyla, Valkyla.
Valkyla, Valkyla.
Valkyla.
He's low as fuck as well in the air.
They died.
There's a team over there behind us as well.
Yeah.
Over there.
On my ping.
I'm gonna get the Cvo for us actually.
Nice.
Flying back up.
They're looting.
I'm gonna have to...
I need more heavy ammo soon.
Yeah.
I only have 50 bullets left.
Someone close.
Someone's really close.
I'm not gonna I can't use I only have close range I don't
want we I only have one one mag left we're trying to get up
here onto a middle height if it's free we should just hold
yeah
yeah our team's inside they should just play up here we'll
have a care package on its way I can take that and give you
my heavy yeah I'll take Yeah, I'll do that.
Yeah.
I'm not shooting.
I'm trying to save.
I'm not double energy right now.
Me too.
Re-form right here.
Well, that was...
Is he sticking it?
Yeah, he is.
Where's the team behind?
I had the heal.
30 clash.
Team behind, right behind us.
I might be dead here.
Yeah.
I'm dead here, I think.
Yeah, I'm dead.
i'm good i'm good they're like on the roof as well they're
on the roof yeah i don't know if i can get to you guys i got
creeper amazing they sent to the i got sent them i will i
have a crafter on me if you can you res or full die i can
craft you i hope i just i just hope nobody pushes us
I don't know.
I don't think that's... I don't think that... No, no, no,
no.
I don't think it's smart.
And then we should split up.
I think he's playing inside.
Yeah, you play inside.
I'll see if I can stick a rose.
I think once Doki grabs she gets to spill back together
after you rose.
Yeah.
I can't.
I can't, Rose.
We try to push high ground.
I'm just trying to go for this death box then.
No, I think she got it.
I got it.
Yeah, she got it.
gotta get out of it I got in I got in I got in good luck
getting in they're getting absolutely fucked on hide all
right there's a team inside Doki in here help me nice whoa I
think we just hold in here for now yeah stuff behind me you
think i'm going to try and get it yeah this team that
suddenly has to move into us chop chop that's there's it
there's your list watch out to the both though how did they
wipe man just grab his stuff yeah what do you have any extra
loot or you sucked it all up i sucked the entire box okay
that's fine yeah they had heavy okay i don't need to chill
i'm fine yeah Wait, we need to go inside this way.
This team level suddenly has to move though.
They're inside pre-trips 190 on one, I think.
I have an angle on these guys.
Oh shit.
Oh shit on.
Dead.
I'm a full heal.
Yeah.
I'm gonna try to get the first one this kid.
He's my kid rose.
My kid rose out here.
Oh yes, yes, yes.
I see him.
Flash, flash, flash!
I'm grabbing ammo, I'm grabbing ammo.
Yeah, yeah.
It's playing side, playing side, we're good.
Look for people dropping.
Bang is here.
Can they get behind us?
I'm gonna double check.
I knocked him?
I'm up like, bang?
Okay.
He's in a knock, he's in a knock.
He's in a knock here.
Pull him back, I'm pulling back.
30.
We should get moving.
I want to get toasted.
Nice.
On top, on top, careful.
They're fighting each other right now.
I don't know where the last team, other team is.
Chucky, come.
Come to our dokeys and rip back all, like, fast.
Just rip it and go.
Right here.
Good, so good, so good.
Okay.
Oh, fuck it.
Oh, right here.
Right here.
lucky.
I have here, I have Alt-XL.
Hey, down there, down there.
Inside, sensei.
Nice.
Got here?
Where there's someone?
There's an evac tower.
Yeah, the team will tell us to move it for us, though.
They're dropping.
Knock one?
down last guy's right here other team is shooting you oh
it's not we got second let's go they're hard pushing you
here i don't have another cue yeah why did they drop on it
that's dumb i guess they were trying to guarantee second
yeah but if they dropped they died yeah exactly they got
third Oh, they would have I thought they would have like Ash
TP or something.
Yeah, I can't believe they committed to that Okay, wait, I
am like a less than a hundred points away.
I think All right, wait wait I just need 60 points All right
next game is last game for real And then I'm out Whatever
happens I'm out I was gonna say I'm down to keep going
guys i'm one more guys it's 16 points 60 points guys i just
see 60 points guys 60 more points they're almost there
we're so close
for real right here right now this is it just believe do you
not believe why don't you
just keep on believing oh this is a this is almost a full
diamond lobby yeah we got terraformer
i'm so ready guys i'm so ready for this last game for real
Did we get shame squad?
I don't know.
Yeah.
Oh, wait, we did?
That's funny.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm gonna grab the hemlock.
How's Matt?
Probably gonna push us.
Yeah, how's Matt?
We're gonna run on this probably.
My weapons enhanced.
Take the upgrade where you can.
Round one.
Neither way.
You see my gosh.
Yeah.
Or anon.
Anyone?
blue backpack
oh you're gonna do that side
i'm gonna guess find an r9 oh that's what i was like now
let's leave a mark on the world all right there's a little
like see it
um extended energy mag here level two
oh we're having our nine
waiting for it to reload
I don't mean to hide they left even over there for free.
Where are?
Wait, where did they go?
People you were shooting at.
I want you to go into.
Oh, I see.
I need that level three.
Got a new upgrade.
Our rivals will rival this.
Yes.
that too.
All right.
Oh, I hear shots.
Yeah.
All right, here I go.
I have alcohols.
I don't even.
It's weird.
Did they take this?
No.
I might take the alternator.
Unless you guys want it.
No, no, no, I don't want it.
You can add it.
Definitely an old man car, then.
Oh, hey, thank you for the 100 biddies.
Thank you.
Thank you for the...
Oh, wait, no.
La doo-doo.
Go boo-boo.
Thank you.
Wait.
What are the evil harvests for here?
We've got an evil harvester here.
Anyone?
All right, here we go.
Nobody's dying.
Oh, never mind.
and then somebody got shot yeah i guess somebody did die
yeah by and i'm like fighting i don't know if you want to
look at that
the trading hat oh look i'm in the kill feed at that they're
like all the way over there i'm not if you come tough
There's a guy right here.
Axel.
Who's resting on me?
Just drop.
Go look it up.
They're chasing this kid.
All right.
In the water here?
Got Axel?
Remember, yeah.
Flesh.
31 flesh.
He has.
That's nice.
where do you get hit where do you get hit uh over the other
thing uh south i don't see them
i have no idea where you got shot at he's back there he's
back there easy oh i see you can buy all those out if you
want they might be resting my rest is good The ventures are
knocked.
Oh, I'm just gonna...
That's cool.
He just turned back and shot me.
No, he just turned back and shot at me.
I'll take you back.
Let's go there.
I don't see anybody.
Yeah, I got the kill on the ventures though, so...
Yeah.
He went to Abba.
He went out.
He's going to go to Abba.
All right.
There's we head there.
Yeah, we can go.
Yeah.
I'll go from the right side.
I'll meet you guys there.
Yeah, yeah.
Hey, Heavenly.
Just one last game.
This is my OG, because I'm almost there.
We're almost diamond.
We did it.
We're doing it.
Oh.
I don't know where it is, but it's like really far.
Are they still there or are they still there?
I think he crossed it on the left.
No.
He's inside.
No, no, inside, inside.
Yeah, I'm on.
Oh, me, on me, on me!
Right here.
That's another team.
Eventually, he went for that team over here.
Yeah, it's another team.
I pinged the team to my right.
I'm running, yeah, I'm running.
I'm done.
I'm done, I think.
I think I got you?
Yeah, I did.
Hold up.
Thank you.
I'm just getting English right here.
Good, guys.
I'm, I'm dead.
Yeah, I couldn't.
I couldn't.
I did alt here.
Oh, no, you got the run.
My run.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
He armor swapped.
Yeah, I'm out.
If you get back on us, we're good.
Bye.
That's unlucky then.
Why would they run in there?
I don't know.
I don't even know why they came here.
Yeah, why would they be here?
It was a three man, too.
Yeah, I don't know what they're doing.
I mean, at least they get to kill the other solo.
I guess they're going to kill the other solo.
Did we even get that kill now, right?
No.
I didn't do it in enough ways.
I just ran into a full team and I have to back off.
No, no, no.
I'm saying, like, did we get the lobo?
Or did they get the lobo?
No, I totally, I totally did.
Okay, so they got the lobo.
Yeah.
That's so weird, though.
I don't know why they were just there.
Yeah.
my head i couldn't even run away in time i was like in such
a weird position i couldn't even i'm gonna scan an insta i
couldn't even like reposition myself i knew i was gonna die
i want to see i could get someone down with me before i die
i couldn't see if there was anybody in time oh nobody's
rushing us though yeah we're good we're good i hate this
game You might have maybe this team, I don't know, but
nobody's running at us for now.
You just couldn't lose hope here.
It's lucid like, but still might be some stuff lying around.
Yeah, I'm gonna punch him into cover.
Yeah, so basically you've had him.
All right.
I'm gonna punch him into zone, Audrey.
Are you holding back in?
Yeah, I'm punching him in the zone.
I'm punching him.
I'm back in.
He's fine.
He's in.
Team, team, team, team.
I see him right here, right here.
Almost cracked up, Hathy.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
There's a guy here on me.
I'm pushing up.
They're still there.
I almost got them.
I'm pushing up.
I'm good.
They're getting shot at.
Blue here though.
Can you get another box?
Can you use the ult?
She's still.
Yeah.
She's even used.
One, one, one, one, one.
One, one, one.
One HP.
She went back.
That was one HP for you.
Yeah.
That's so fucking...
That looks so dumb.
Dead.
New team.
Yeah, the new team's here?
I think it's okay.
We're having...
They're coming here.
I got fucking sentinels.
Nice.
You need bats, I have no bats.
Do you guys have any?
Uh, no.
I got no bats, bro.
I'm on my last four shows.
Wait, I have four, I have four, I have four, I have four.
Oh, word.
Here.
I threw it.
I don't have an angle, I don't have an angle.
One time they're left, one time left alone.
I'm looking at the run to on the right.
I have no shield, that's left.
i have i have some shields
here yeah i dropped i dropped shields next to you thank you
though i'm gonna check behind in the garage yeah i can loot
the bins at the back see if we can get more shields okay
i've got this good too guys the mirage oh my god oh my god
He's flesh Chalakras alone over here He's rotating, no, no,
he's rotating He rotated
Okay, he's still here Is he back?
Oh, sorry
Oh my god, you got me, I'm batting Do you need syringes?
Because I have syringes I don't know, I'm good I'm just
getting this box We're still safe here But There are bins
back here you want to check check if there's meds We might
need to wipe these I think
Come out Jesus I don't have meds anymore.
I'm gonna I have to loot the back side your shields Yeah,
yeah, yeah my full heal here and then blue in the back dude
they're still just fucking sitting here like what i know i
know wait is that are they redeploying or what yeah they're
moving okay i found oh i found unlimited but i need two bets
i could drop you one i've got two cells that's all i've got
yeah i need one more bats i just need one more bat and i
should be good yeah i'm good i'm good now Oh shit, no, I'm
diamond now.
Let's go.
Nice, nice.
Yes.
Oh my.
What's up?
Back him hard.
Yeah, be on the rock.
He's at the rock.
Hit him 25.
On the roof of the 30th.
He's at 30.
Oh, the ammo.
Guys.
These guys should get condom roses.
Oh.
Almost cracked them.
100 altars.
What the fuck?
Right here.
You can battlecult if you just want.
Yeah, we need a battlecult.
One guy's walking up, I don't know.
I think maybe there's a March clone?
About to hold him from here.
We're ready?
Oh!
Oh, I got...
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
It's fine.
Time to go back, RJ.
No, no, it's fine.
It's fine.
Just go, just go, just go.
Just okay.
He had shot at me.
I mean, okay.
I'm gonna go near.
I think we're a duo though, so that's a good thing.
I'm a little...
No, no, not on left, by the way.
See, I can slowly come to you.
I can try and throw you at you.
They're shooting at me.
We'll go to the right, so can you have the right?
Sorry.
Yeah.
From top three.
Are you coming?
They're coming for me.
I'm batting.
I got shopped.
I got creepered from the right side.
Ah, do you feel any shields?
No, I'm almost out.
I have two left.
Yeah.
He crawling's okay.
I'm crawling, I'm crawling.
I have the unlimited, so you might be able to grab the
unlimited from me.
Oh no.
Okay.
Oh my god, I got crazy.
No, no, you're honest.
Honestly, because it's good.
What the hell?
Why are they pushing us?
What the fuck?
Freaks!
Yeah, now you're not getting first stupid.
Wait, what?
Oh my god, they all pushed us.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
No, they're not going to get first.
I didn't have audio on that duo.
That was solo.
It was a duo.
Yeah, it was two.
It was two.
All right.
Well, it's all right.
I got my diamond.
I'm fine.
GG's, guys.
Gee, thanks for the games.
Yeah, thanks for the games.
Yeah, it was fun.
Jeez, everyone.
GG's.
I'm going to say bye, my chat and then pass out.
Oh, I'll talk to you guys later.
bye bye We did it See I told you I told it was one more last
game I told you guys I told you it was one last game guys I
told you I told you It was one last game Oh like I але
joined instantly He's like Oh she's gone now Now we can say
whatever the fuck we want to say
He's just like Now We can say whatever we want
I'm immediately there to talk shit No, I don't I'm scared
Oh my god Anyway guys Thank y'all for coming This was a
short stream But it ended up being a short stream It ended
up being an 8 hour stream Today's gonna be a long week of
streams I hope my voice will be okay Oh shit Wait.
Oh, I can't fuck up.
I just realized I can't fuck up my voice too much next week.
I was really like, it's fine.
I have like one week to just realize.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I can't do.
Oh, no.
I can't do soup.
I can't I can't fuck up my voice for too long.
I just realized.
Yeah.
Because I was like, wait, I do need to talk a lot next week.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
They won't be too long.
Starting...
Oh, no.
Anyways, thank you all for watching.
If you guys want to check me out, my name is Doki Bray.
I use the stream on YouTube.
So please feel free to follow me on YouTube.
Explanation point YouTube.
If you want to support me, the other means.
I have so many things.
All my music is now...
Not music, but girlfriend cover is now on Spotify.
We just uploaded a new YouTube video.
Please support it because we're trying to get into a lot of
form content now.
You want to know whenever I stream my Twitch, follow me on
Twitter.
That's everything.
Yay!
Oh, merch.
Buy my merch.
Yeah.
Anyway, guys.
I'm going to head off now.
I'm going to sleep.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Foster check.
Get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Also, new ending screen.
Oh, updated ending screen.
Bye-bye, guys.
Bye.
Shout-out to the squad.
You shout-out to Tsukian RG for coming.
I forgot to say thank you, guys, for them playing with us.
Anyway, bye-bye for real.
you